MY NAME IS MIKE
GIPSON I SERVE- THE COMMUNITY
WHICH RAN RIGHT NOW AS
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I'M WE ARE LOCATED IN THE CITY
OF CARSON- BEFORE I DO MY
OPENING REMARKS I WANT TO-
IDENTIFY AND ARTICULATE SOME
HOUSEKEEPING RULES- FIRST OF ALL
WANT THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE WE ARE PARTICIPATING-
PHYSICALLY AND PARTICIPATING AND
PRACTICING PHYSICAL- DISTANCING-
AND SO WE WILL HAVE A LIMITED
AMOUNT OF INDIVIDUALS HERE- AT
THIS LOCATION AT THE HEARING
ROOM IN PERSON. WE ARE ALSO
REQUIRED THAT WE WEAR A MASK. I
WANTED TO DEMONSTRATE WE WERE
PUTTING ON MASS WE WEARING
MASKS- LESTER SPEAKING- BUT
EVERYONE ELSE IS GOING TO BE
WEARING MASKS AGAIN WE'RE GOING
TO. CONTINUE TO PRACTICE- SOCIAL
DISTANCING- WHY ARE WE IN THE
END IS A ROOM AND ALSO- WHILE
THE PUBLIC IS TESTIFYING MASS
WILL BE WARRANT WORN AT ALL
TIMES- DURING THIS HEARING. IN
ADDITION TO THAT. NGUYEN YOU ARE
HERE TO HAVE HIM PROVIDE- PUBLIC
COMMENTS WE ASK THAT YOU NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE THAT'S
HERE- WE WILL RAISE IT FOR YOU-
AND AFTER YOU FINISH TESTIFYING
WE ASK THAT YOU CAN FEEL FREE TO
REMAIN. A RETURN BACK TO HER
SEAT OR YOU CAN EXIT THE ROLE
BUT PLEASE AGAIN EXERCISE SOCIAL
DISTANCING PHYSICAL DISTANCE. OF
WIRE YOU ARE HERE- WE ALSO HAVE
PEOPLE- DIALING IN- WE WILL ALSO
BE USING A TELEPHONE- MODERATOR.
A SERVICE FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT
SECTION SO THOSE WHO ARE IN THE
PUBLIC WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY-
TO DIAL IN AND PARTICIPATE-
THROUGH THAT MECHANISM. OF THE
CALL IN NUMBER YOU MAY WANT TO
TAKE THIS DOWN. THE CALL IN
NUMBER IT'S AREA CODE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN ONCE AGAIN THE
CALL IN NUMBERS. 877-692-8957
THE ACCESS CODE. IS. THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONCE
AGAIN. ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE
EIGHT FIVE ZERO. YOU CAN ALSO
FIND. THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE AND ON YOUR TV
SCREEN THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE
WE'LL GIVE YOU SOME INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO BE PLACE IN THE QUEUE
AND CALL YOU UPON- WIMMER READY
FOR YOU TO SPEAK. DURING THE
PUBLIC COMMENT SECTION. AND TO
THAT. OF AGAIN WE WILL- WE WILL
HAVE TO WE HAVE WE HAVE A HARD
STOP AT ONE PM- SO WE WANT TO
TRY TO. WORK EXPEDITIOUSLY AND
MAINTAIN- PEOPLE'S TIME TO SPEAK
SO THAT WE CAN- STOP EXACTLY AT
ONE O'CLOCK. SO THAT'S THE
HOUSEKEEPING RULES. I DON'T WANT
TO SAY GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME
TO EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU FOR
TAKING TIME OUT OF YOUR BUSY
SCHEDULE. AND JOINING US FIRST
OF ALL WHEN I THINK CALVET
UNIVERSITY MINGUS HILLS AS OUR
HOST. KATHY UNIVERSITY MINGUS
HILLS- FOR ALLOWING US TO BE ON
CAMPUS. I WANT TO HAVE AND DO A
SPECIAL SHOUT OUT AND THANKS TO-
PRESIDENTS- THOMAS PAR HIM FOR.
A ONE AGREEING TO WHILE ALLOWING
US TO BE HERE. AND ALSO FOR THE
CAPABLE STAFF OF- THE INTERIM
CHIEF OF STAFF I JUST BEEN MADE
AWARE OF BOOSTER DAVID GAMBLE.
AND ALSO DR BRAD SHAW FOR YOUR
AMAZING WORKING FOR- THE TEAM
WHO IS HERE WE APPRECIATE YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
TODAY. WITH THAT BEING SAID-
FOR. FOR THOSE WHO ARE ARE HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM THE FOCUS
WILL BE. ON A DRESSING SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS SPECIFICALLY THIS
HEARING WILL PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
. OTHER BECAUSE OF THE
DISPARITY. AND COMBATING SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH WITH
HEALTH WITH THE HELP WITH THE
HELP EQUITY LANCE I FIRST LIKE
TO THANK ALL OF YOU ON THE PANEL
THOSE WHO ARE WITH US PHYSICALLY
AND THOSE WHO WILL BE JOINING US
VIRTUALLY. FOR GIVING OF
OURSELVES TO MAKE HIMSELF
AVAILABLE TODAY TO BE PART OF
THIS HERE WE ABSOLUTELY
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
YOUR INPUT YOUR CONVERSATION AND
YOUR COLLABORATION IN THIS IN
THIS SPACE SO I WANT TO SAY I'M
HUMBLED BY YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND VERY GRATEFUL THAT YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY HERE. FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE IN THE AUDIENCE YOU
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS AT THE END OF
THE OF TODAY'S HEARING TO WEIGH
IN ON WHAT YOU'VE HEARD SO WE
CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO WRITE
DOWN QUESTIONS THAT SOMETHING
THAT ONE OF THE PRESENTERS MAY
SAY THEY MAY SPARK OR ENCOURAGE
YOU TO COMMENT ON WE ASK THAT
YOU- WRITE IT DOWN SO WE GET TO.
THAT SEGMENT THAT YOU WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
BY CALLING IN OR COMING UP TO
THE MICROPHONE WE PROVIDE IT FOR
YOU. THE BALLOT IN HEALTH AND
EQUITIES- EXPRESSIONS FOURTH
STATE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IS THE
ONGOING BATTLE. AND I AM DOING
EVERYTHING THAT I CAN IN MY
POWER TO ENSURE THE RESIDENTS OF
THE SIXTY FOURTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. THAT YOU MATTER AND WE
WILL DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
ADDRESS- THESE EQUITIES IN FACT
LAST MONTH I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT
I HOSTED A KICK A VACCINE
VACCINATION EVENT IN
COLLABORATION WITH S. B. C. C.
WHICH IS A- KNOWN- NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION HERE- IN THE SIXTY
FOURTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT- IT WAS
WELL AS WHAT OTHER- COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS. AS WE WENT DOOR TO
DOOR KNOCKING ON OVER TWO
THOUSAND DOORS. AND PROVIDING
OVER TWO HUNDRED VACCINATIONS TO
RESIDENTS THAT ONLY O WE DO
THIS AND START THIS WORK- IN
SEPTEMBER ON SEPTEMBER
EIGHTEENTH IN THE WATTS
COMMUNITY BUT ALSO. ON OCTOBER
THIRTIETH WE DID IT ALSO IN
WILMINGTON. AND WE AGAIN KNOCKED
ON DOORS TO MOBILIZE
COLLECTIVELY CLOSE TO FIVE
HUNDRED- VOLUNTEERS WHO WERE
COMMITTED IN THIS WORK I'M WITH
US TO KNOCK ON AS MANY DOORS AS
POSSIBLE AND ALSO TRY TO
CONVINCE MANY INDIVIDUALS. TO
GET THE VACCINE AS POSSIBLE AND
WE ABSOLUTELY DID THAT WORK AND
I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT ON A
STATEWIDE LEVEL- MY COLLEAGUE
WILL BE HERE MOMENTARILY. I'M
NOT HAPPY THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS WILL BE JOINING US
BUT- ON A STATEWIDE LEVEL
EARLIER THIS MONTH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS AND
MYSELF AND ABOUT TWENTY THREE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. I'M SUBMIT A
BIPARTISAN LETTER TO THE
GOVERNOR- TO COMMIT FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY AND
RACIAL JUSTICE FUND WHICH I'M
HAPPY TO SAY. THAT IT WAS
RECEIVED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THESE BONDS WOULD SUPPORT
PARTICIPATION. AMONG COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS COMMUNITY
CLINICS. TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS
AND HELP. LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS- THAT WILL SERVE
UNDER- UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES-
IN MY DISTRICT BUT THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. IT IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS AIM TO
ADDRESS SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
INCLUDING HOUSING- AND FOOD IN
SECURITIES EMPLOYMENT
INSTABILITIES- UNDER RESOURCE
SCHOOLS AND- CHILD CARE
COMMUNITIES OF VIOLENCE AND HATE
CRIMES AND ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICE. BEFORE WE BEGIN I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE- MY COLLEAGUE
AS SOON AS HE COMES IN- FOR HIS
GREAT WORK AND GIVE HIM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WROTE ROBERT RIVAS TO SAY A FEW
WORDS AND TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
GREAT WORK THAT HE- IS
ENDEAVORING AND CONTINUE TO DO
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY- SO A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCHING THIS- VIRTUALLY SO
AGAIN WE WANT TO THANK YOU WE
WELCOME YOU. BUT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE RIGHT ALONG AND SO WITH
THAT I WANT TO INTRODUCE- JUST
THE GROUND RULES FOR PRESENTERS
WE WANT TO INVITE YOU TO HAVE UP
TO SIX MINUTES- TWO ONE INTO
YOURSELF AND ALSO- BEGAN TO
PROVIDE YOUR PRESENTATION TO ASK
ARE YOU WILL GO IN THE ORDER IN
THEIR GENDER IS LISTED- BEFORE
YOU THAT'S THE ORDER WILL GO IN
AND OUR FIRST PRESENTER. WILL BE
DR- SHEILA YOUNG- DR SHEILA
YOUNG IS AN ASSISTANT PROFESSOR
AT CHARLES DREW UNIVERSITY OF
MEDICINE AND SCIENCE- WHO COULD
NOT BE WITH US- PHYSICALLY BUT
SHE'S WITH THAT'S VIRTUALLY. A
DOCTOR SHEILA YOUNG ARE YOU WITH
US. YES I'M HERE. YES I'M HERE
IF YOU HAVE SIX MINUTES AND
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR
AVAILING YOURSELVES- WITH THIS
ON THIS TOPIC TODAY YOU HAVE UP
TO SIX MINUTES AND IN THAT SIX
MINUTES TO COMPLETE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AND COMMENCE- GIVING US
A PRESENTATION AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH. YES THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME HERE
TODAY MY NAME IS DR SHE LEARNED-
I. AM FROM OPENING CALIFORNIA
AND I ALSO WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL
IN LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA I WANT
TO SHORTEN HIGH SCHOOL. AND I
DID ABOUT A MEDICAL SCHOOL
PROGRAM AT B. DREW UCLA. PROGRAM
AND SOUTHERLY. AND SO I'M HERE
TODAY NOT ONLY. AS A POSITION.
THAT THE FAMILY MEMBER AS A
FRIEND. AS A PATIENT TO.
DESCRIBES YOU ISSUE THAT THOSE
WHO ARE MY FRIENDS AND FAMILY
ACTIVITIES WELL. TRYING ACCESS
HEALTHCARE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I WANT TO BRING YOUR
ATTENTION TO WHAT I'M GOING TO
SHARE MY SCREEN. IT IS THE LACK
OF ADEQUATE RESOURCES FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE PENTATONIC WE WORKED WITH AN
AMAZING GENIUS AS DR PAUL RYAN
SAID. AND I ASKED HIM TO CREATE
A MAP OF ICU BEDS IN CALIFORNIA
SO WE HAD ABOUT THAT SPANS.
CALIFORNIA WHEN I SEE YOU BETTER
THAN I WILL FOCUSING ON SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SHOW. YOU WHERE
WE ARE RIGHT NOW. ANY WILL ROAD
. YEAH I DO WANT YOU GUYS TO
TAKE A LOOK. AT OUR MEDICAL
DESERTS. WE SEE HERE THAT IN
LONG BEACH THERE ARE OVER- THIS
ONE SAYS ADAM WITH MILLER
SCORING THIRTY AS HE LEADS. HERE. RONALD REAGAN A HUNDRED TWENTY
ICU BEDS WITH FOUR HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE A LITTLE BIT IT'S. HERE
YOUR SITE. NINE HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX. HI THERE SEN SAID NINETY
SIX. THANK YOU FOR NOW I WANTED
TO COME DOWN TO. THE AREA WHERE
WE ARE. WE ARE HOSPITAL. SIXTEEN
HE AGE SEVENTY EIGHT. ST FRANCIS
HERE IT SAYS ZERO AND A HALF.
THIRTY SIX. AND WILL TAKE
HOSPITAL HUNDRED THIRTY ONE BAGS
TWENTY ICU BEDS. LOOK AT THE
AREA. THAT DISTRICT SIXTY FOUR
AND THEN. WE CAN SEE THAT WE
WERE SET UP FROM THE BEGINNING
TO NOT BE ABLE TO APPROPRIATELY
RESPOND. TO NINETEEN. SO ISSUE
IN HEALTHCARE IS ACCESS. IT IS
STRUCTURE. THE ROOT CAUSE-
HEALTHCARE DISPARITIES IN MY
EXPERIENCE YEAH THE PATIENTS.
AND AS THE PROVIDER. IT IS A
CULTURE OF RACISM. AND CLASSISM. NEVERTHELESS GRADING
CALIFORNIA THAT MIGHT NOT BE
TRUE. UNFORTUNATELY RACISM
CLASSISM IS EMBEDDED IN OUR
MEDICAL EDUCATION. I PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCED SAYS LAST YEAR WHEN
MY MOTHER. SMALL ELECTRICIAN.
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT CAME TO OUR
HOUSE. AND I TOLD THEM SHE HAD A
HISTORY OF OVARIAN CANCER. SHE
HAD WHAT WE CALLED BIO THAT WAS
AN COMING UP IT WAS GREEN. I
KNEW THAT SHE HAD A SMALL BELL
STRETCHING. YES FIRE DEPARTMENT
DID NOT INFORM THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS OF THIS VEHICLE IT
COULD. WE WAITED OUTSIDE THE
EMERGENCY ROOM FOR OVER AN HOUR. I BEG THEM TO COME AND SEE MY
MOTHER. THIS IS LAST YEAR. THE
BUSINESS S. THEY DIDN'T CARE
THEY HAD MEDICAL TRAINING. IF WE
- IN OUR OWN HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
. CANNOT RESPECT THE EXPERIENCE
. OF PHYSICIANS OF HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS OF COLOR HOW MUCH LESS
OTHER OCCASIONS. WHERE SOLUTIONS. THOSE OF US WHO ARE WORKING ON
THE GROUND THOSE OF US YOU KNOW
OUR COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE TO GET
AN ACCESS TO RESOURCES. WE KNOW
HOW TO WORK TOGETHER WELL. WE
NEED FUNDING FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
THIS THAT WE HAVE HERE CANNOT
CONTINUE. WE NEED TO CHANGE THE
EDUCATION OF OUR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS. AND OUR EXEMPLARY
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS. SO LET ME
CULTURE OF RACISM CLASSISM DOES
NOT CONTINUE. THIS IS CRITICAL
IN ORDER FOR US TO STOP. THE
CURRENTS ACROSS CITIES THAT ARE
OCCURRING. IN OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DR YOUNG IS THIRTY THREE
SORRY- YOUR PRESENTATION- AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR GOVERNOR
SELVES AND AGAIN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HEALTH INEQUITIES- HERE IN
A NON IN THE SIXTY FOURTH WHEN
CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE AND SO HER
PRESENTATION WAS FOCUSED ON
THAT- AND SHE ALSO MADE MENTION
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE MORE MONEY
IN TERMS OF INFRASTRUCTURE IS
ALSO IN EDUCATION SO- WE GOT
THOSE THINGS NOTED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR PARTICIPATING WE
HOPE THAT YOU WILL BE ABLE TO
STICK AROUND. IN CASE THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS THAT I'M I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS TO FOR YOU AS
WELL- MY COLLIE HAVE SAYS JOIN
US I WANT TO TAKE OPPORTUNITY TO
ONE INTRODUCED- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS AND ASK HIM TO SAY
A FEW WORDS AND ALSO INTRODUCE
HIMSELF IN THE DISTRICT IN WHICH
YOU CAN IS HE REPRESENTS- RIGHT
NOW THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSUMES
A WELCOME AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE. YOU ARE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. ALL THANK YOU- SUMMER IS
GREAT TO BE HERE WITH EVERYONE
MORNING UP. LOW BIT LATER. GOT A
GREAT TO- A TO A THE CAMP- IS A
BEAUTIFUL CAMPUS ALL WALK IN.
WONDERING NOT AIMLESSLY HERE ON
CAMPUS BUT I'M NOT HAPPY TO. TO
BE HERE NOW- BUT REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE AND BE PART OF- THIS-
SELECT- COMMITTEE- THAT WAS PUT
TOGETHER BY- MY FRIEND AND- AND
A COLLEAGUE- MISTER GIBSON. WHO
IS A CHAMPION FOR THE SIXTY
FOURTH YOU GUYS ARE VERY LUCKY
TO HAVE HIM REPRESENT YOU IN
SACRAMENTO. I CERTAINLY ALWAYS
DOES WHAT IS RIGHT- BUT YOU KNOW
I MYSELF- I REPRESENT- THE
THIRTIETH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND
ITS IT- INCLUDES. PARTS OF FOUR
COUNTIES. THE SALINAS VALLEY THE
PARO VALLEY IS CONSIDERED THE-
CENTRAL COAST REGION OF THE
STATE IN THE MONTEREY BAY AREA-
AND YOU'LL CERTAINLY WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE- IN
ENSURING THAT- WE HAD THIS
HEARING- HERE THIS MORNING- AND
FOR BRINGING ALL OF US TOGETHER
TO ADDRESS IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC- AND YOU KNOW
THIS ISSUE HAS ALWAYS BEEN AT
THE FOREFRONT OF. MY MIND-
BECAUSE I REPRESENT A DISTRICT
THAT IS LARGELY UNDERSERVED IT
IS RURAL AND IT IS LATINO. AND
AS MY ROLE- AS CHAIR OF
AGRICULTURE IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY IS AS AS AS MY ROLE AS
VICE CHAIR OF THE LATINO- THE
CAUCUS IN THE STATE. LEGISLATURE
YEP EQUITABLE HEALTH POLICY FOR
OUR LATINO- ARE. COOK
COMMUNITIES AND IN FACT ALL OF-
OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IS A
TOP- IT'S- TOP- PRIORITY FOR
LEGISLATURE OF OUR STATE. ENJOY
THIS COVER NINETEEN AS PANDEMIC
ALL OF THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE
UNDERSERVED- OUR- REGIONS-
LOCALITIES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT THAT WE FACED- THAT WE WERE
ALREADY FACING A CERTAINLY
EXPANDED. BEYOND ANYTHING WE HAD
EVER ANTICIPATED YOU TALK ABOUT
EDUCATION WAS IMPACTED IN IN NEW
AND SOME PROFOUND WAYS IS THE
DIGITAL D. D. DIVIDED IT TORE
OUR STATE APART SEPARATE THOSE
WHO CAN ACCESS THEIR SCHOOL
WORK. AND THOSE LIKE THE YOUNG
GIRLS AND- THAT VIRTUAL PHOTO
THAT WERE SITTING IN FRONT OF A
TALK ABOUT TRYING TO ACCESS. THE
INTERNET TO DO THEIR HOMEWORK
UNFORTUNATE THAT WAS IN THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT IN THE
SALINAS VALLEY. UP BUT YOU KNOW
THERE WAS NO ECONOMIC STABILITY
FOR SO MANY OF OUR RESIDENTS SO
MANY OF OUR CALIFORNIANS BUT IN
PARTICULAR. WE SUCH A WORKERS
WORKERS IN HOSPITALITY IN
AGRICULTURE AND OTHER INDUSTRIES
THAT WERE HIT INCREDIBLY HARD BY
THIS PANDEMIC. BUT I THINK YOU
KNOW TO PUT A FINER POINT ON IT
IN SO MANY WAYS ARE- LOCALITIES.
ARE COMMUNITIES WERE SUFFERING
ALREADY. WE WERE WOEFULLY
UNPREPARED FOR THIS PANDEMIC-
AND AS WE RECOVER WE CAN JUST
REBUILD WHAT EXISTED PRIOR- IF
WE WANT TO ACHIEVE TRUE HEALTH
THE SOCIAL EQUITY FOR ALL
RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WE MUST MOVE FORWARD. AND I'M
EXCITED BE PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION AND OF- THIS
COMMITTEE SO THANK YOU MISTER
GIBSON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SO
AGAIN PREFIX OR COMMENTS I JUST
WANTED PIGGY BACK ON SOMETHING
HE'S THAT HE SAID- PRIOR TO THIS
PANDEMIC WE ARE READY KNEW. THAT
THERE WAS- HEALTH DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH IN EQUITIES- IN THE BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITY. AND SO
CERTAINLY BECAUSE OF THIS
PANDEMIC IT HAS BROUGHT TO THE
FOREFRONT WE'VE SEEN IT- WE'VE
SEEN IT FIRSTHAND IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND IT THE PURPOSE
IS TO ONE EXPOSE IT EVEN ON A
GRADE LEVEL. ON A STATE LEVEL
BUT ALSO MAKING SURE THAT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE NOT
LEFT BEHIND- AS IT RELATES TO
THIS PANDEMIC OR ANY OTHER
PANDEMIC MOVING FOR. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT ONE WE PUT A
FOCUS ON THIS WE SHINE THE LIGHT
NECESSARY. TO TALK ABOUT THE
INEQUITIES IN THE BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES AND WHAT THE
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE AND HOW
DO WE- MAKE SURE THAT WE
ADEQUATELY FUND THESE
COMMUNITIES. SO THAT- WE DON'T
HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE DYING WHEN
IT COMES OUT TO A PANDEMIC. OR
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
HYPERTENSION AND THOSE
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS THAT
EVERYONE TALKS ABOUT THAT IS
MOST VULNERABLE TO THIS PANDEMIC
AND SO. I AGAIN WANT TO THANK DR
SHEILA YOUNG AND MY COLLEAGUE
WHO'S THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS- IS
HERE- WHICH I'M HAPPY TO ALSO
RECORD- TO BRING UP AND ALSO-
RECOMMEND AND- INTRODUCE. A
DOCTOR LEBRON'S THERE ARE ALSO
CORRECT ABU IS THE ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR. OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH-
AND SIX- CHICAGO A LATINO
STUDIES AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE WHO'S HERE
PHYSICALLY IN THE ROOM SO
WELCOME THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
AND YOU HAVE UP TO SIX MINUTES
AND JUMP. TAKEN AWAY AND YOU
JUST CELLS AND PLEASE MOVE FOR
TO PRESENTATION WE'RE HAPPY THAT
YEAR THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
THE INVITATION O JOIN THIS
PANEL AND ALSO FOR THE PROMOTION
ALL NOTE I'M A LOT OF LEBRON AND
I AM STILL AN ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR- OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
TO KIND OF LET YOU KNOW STUDIES
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IRVINE. I AM PORTER RICAN. I
GREW UP IN SOUTH CENTRAL TO
ACCESS. I AND I KNOW IN. WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO LIVE PAGE. TO
PAYCHECK AS A YOUNG CHILD. I AND
IT IS THESE EXPERIENCES AS WELL
AS THE PUBLIC HEALTH LITERATURE
AND ADDS SOME LOCAL COMMUNITY
ACADEMIC PARTNERSHIPS IN ORANGE
COUNTY. THAT I'LL BE DRAWING
UPON WHEN SHARING MY COMMENTS
THIS MORNING. I'M SO I'M GONNA
SPEAK A BIT ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY HEALTH
EQUITY COBIT NINETEEN COMMUNITY
ACADEMIC PARTNERSHIP OF WHICH
I'M A FOUNDING MEMBER. AT BUT
FIRST I WANT TO GROUND THIS
CONVERSATION IN A STRUCTURAL
RACISM LANDS THEN THE BAILEY AND
COLLEAGUES DEFINED STRUCTURAL
RACISM AS THE TOTALITY OF WAYS
IN WHICH SOCIETIES FOSTERED
DISCRIMINATION THREE MUTUALLY
REINFORCING SYSTEMS OF HOUSING
EDUCATION. EMPLOYMENT EARNINGS
BENEFITS CREDIT MEDIA HEALTH
CARE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE. THESE
PATTERNS AND PRACTICES IN TURN
REINFORCE DISCRIMINATORY BELIEFS
VALUES AND DISTRIBUTION OF
RESOURCES. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
LENS THROUGH WHICH TO UNDERSTAND
THE WORSENING OF HEALTH
INEQUITIES FOR RACIALLY MINORITY
HIGHEST LOW INCOME AND IMMIGRANT
CALIFORNIANS DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. OUR COMMUNITY
ACADEMIC PARTNERSHIP DRAWS
PARTICIPATION FROM COMMUNITY
BASED HEALTH EQUITY
ORGANIZATIONS COALITIONS AND UCI
FACULTY STAFF AND STUDENTS FROM
A RANGE OF DISCIPLINES. WE
BELIEVE THAT BUILDING LOCAL
RESILIENCE AND RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC IS NOT ABOUT BOUNCING
BACK TO PRE PANDEMIC CONDITIONS
RATHER IT IS ABOUT BOUNCING
FORWARD TO CREATE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY INTERVENTIONS
THAT WE NEED. IN ORDER TO
ELIMINATE INEQUITIES AND BUILD
HEALTH EQUITY AND WE BELIEVE
THAT WHEN LOCAL ACTIONS
REFLECTED THIS ORIENTATION
ORANGE COUNTY AND OTHER
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES WILL BE
BETTER POSITIONED TO REFRAIN
FROM INCREASING AND EXACERBATING
HARM TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. OTHER MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE SUFFERED
DISPROPORTIONATELY FROM THE
VIRUS AND SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
HARDSHIPS. AND TO SPUR AND
FOSTER SOCIAL COHESION INCLUSION
AND TRUST IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY PANDEMIC RESPONSES IN
WAYS THAT INCREASE THE POWER
PARTICIPATION AND LONG TERM
VITALITY OF SUCH COMMUNITIES. IN
ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE SEEN THAT
HEALTH EQUITY HAS BEEN AN
AFTERTHOUGHT AT BEST IN THE
DESIGN AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
STATE AND LOCAL CODE NINETEEN
RESPONSES. IN LINE WITH OUR
POLITICAL CONTEXT ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES OFTEN DISCRETION
IN COVERT NINETEEN TESTING
CONTACT TRACING AND VACCINATION
STRATEGIES WAS LEFT UP TO LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. IN
CASES WHERE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
HAS A STRONG EQUITY BACKGROUND
THIS APPROACH MAKES PERFECT
SENSE. UNDER THOSE CONDITIONS
PUBLIC HEALTH PRACTITIONERS
WOULD BE KEENLY AWARE OF LOCAL
HEALTH INEQUITIES AND THE ROLES
OF POLICIES SYSTEMS AND
ENVIRONMENTS IN SHAPING THESE
INEQUITIES. THEY WOULD ALSO
ALREADY BE WORKING IN CLOSE
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL HEALTH
EQUITY LEADERS WHO WOULD HELP
THEM TO SEE EMERGING AND
PERSISTENT INEQUITIES TO SHAPE
THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE
. IN ORANGE COUNTY THIS WAS NOT
OUR EXPERIENCE. WE THOUGHT
TESTING AND VACCINATION
OPPORTUNITIES FIRST BECOME
AVAILABLE TO WHITER WEALTHIER
COMMUNITIES OFTEN COASTAL
COMMUNITIES EVEN THOUGH THE
EVIDENCE INDICATED THAT PANDEMIC
RESPONSE IS NEEDED TO BE
CONCENTRATED IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THAT WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
CODE CASES MORBIDITY MORTALITY
JOB LOSS LOSS OF HOUSING AND
SIGNIFICANT TRAUMA DUE TO LOSS
OF LOVED ONES. ADDITIONALLY
COVERED NINETEEN VACCINES WERE
FIRST MADE AVAILABLE VIA AN APP
THAT WAS ONLY AVAILABLE IN
ENGLISH. SO THAT RESIDENTS COULD
GO TO THESE QUOTE UNQUOTE SUPER
POINTS OF DISTRIBUTION.
COMMUNITY HEALTH EQUITY LEADERS
AND OUR PARTNERSHIP TIRELESSLY
ADVOCATED FOR VACCINES TO BE
DISTRIBUTED ON A SMALLER SCALE
WITH WALK UP OPTIONS USING A
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER OR
PROMOTE THOUGHT AS MODEL. MAKING
THE VACCINE AVAILABLE READILY IN
RESIDENTS PRIMARY LANGUAGE
VACCINE INFORMATION. AND WE URGE
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH TO FIND
LOCAL COMMUNITY BASED GROUPS TO
LEAD THIS WORK. ADDITIONALLY WE
TRAINED RESIDENTS WHO LOST JOBS
OR UNDEREMPLOYED DUE TO CODE RED
WE TRAIN THEM AND CONTACT
TRACING SKILLS THE HOPE WAS THAT
THEY WOULD BE HIRED BY OUR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. TO INTERN
CONDUCT CONTACT TRACING INSTEAD
WE FOUND THAT THE CONTRACT WENT
TO A FIRM ON THE EAST COAST WHO
OFTEN OPERATED DURING EAST COAST
HOURS AND DID NOT HAVE MANY
SERVICES AVAILABLE IN RESIDENTS
PRIMARY LANGUAGES. THESE ARE
SOME STORIES FROM THE FIELD AND
THESE ARE NOT SIMPLY STORIES
THESE ARE NIGHTMARES THAT
CONTINUE TO HAUNT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. IN TERMS
OF REDUCING COVERT INEQUITIES WE
HAVE TO THINK OF THIS IN TERMS
OF ADDRESSING HEALTH INEQUITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN WORSENED THAT
WERE EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC. AND BUILDING COMMUNITY
POWER SO THAT COMMUNITIES ARE
POSITIONED TO RESPOND SWIFTLY
AND COHESIVELY TO THE NEXT
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND TO BE
GUIDED BY A HEALTH EQUITY LINES.
WE HAVE BEEN IN A CYCLE WHERE
JUST ABOUT EVERY THREE YEARS WE
AS A GLOBAL COMMUNITY HAVE BEEN
ON THE BRINK OF A MAJOR
PANDEMIC. AND HISTORY TEACHES US
THAT IT TAKES ABOUT THREE YEARS
TO EMERGE FROM A PANDEMIC. AND
KOBE TEACHES US THAT DESPITE ALL
THE WAYS IN WHICH OUR SOCIETY
SEATS TO SEPARATE US BASED ON
RACE CLASS AND NATIONAL ORIGIN.
OUR FATES ARE INTERCONNECTED SO
THE PATH FORWARD IS HEALTH
EQUITY. AND APART THEIR. SURE SO
IN TERMS OF WHAT THE PATH
FORWARD LOOKS LIKE- WE NEED TO
REALLY BE ELEVATING THE VOICES
AND PERSPECTIVES OF AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES. AND JUST LIKE
STRUCTURAL RACISM INVOLVES THE
TOTALITY OF FORCES ARE COLLUDED
EQUITY RESPONSE REALLY NEEDS TO
THINK THAT ONLY ABOUT STOPPING
THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS
VACCINES- AND RECOVERY BUT WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW COULD
SHAPE HOUSING EDUCATION- AND JOB
OPPORTUNITIES. AND WE NEED TO BE
CARRYING AN ANTI RACISM LANDS
THROUGHOUT OUR CO BAD RESPONSE-
AND RECOVERY PROGRAMS AND
POLICIES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH TACLOBAN THANKS
VERY MUCH FOR THAT AND
INSIGHTFUL PRESENTATION I'M
CERTAINLY IS THOUGHT PROVOKING
AND YOU RAISE A NUMBER OF ISSUES
AND- HOPEFULLY YOU'VE EVER STICK
AROUND SO THAT WE CAN NOW FOLLOW
SOME SOME QUESTIONS WITH RESPECT
TO THAT- SO AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR INSIGHT MAX-
GIVES ME GREAT PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE DR- ROLE HAN GONNA
KISHA- PLEASE- IF YOU CAN PLEASE
PRONOUNCING YOUR NAME CORRECTLY
FOR ME IF FIVE OF FAILED TO DO
SO AND WE'RE VERY HAPPY THAT
YOU'RE HERE- HE'LL BE JOINING US
VIRTUALLY. ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
I AM ABLE TO SEE MY SCREEN- NOT
AS OF YET DOCTOR BUT- WE THANK
YOU SO NOW WE ARE WE GOT IT NOW-
WEIRD THANK VERY THANKFUL HE'S
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY AND AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH- THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH FOR PARTICIPATING WITH US-
THIS MORNING IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TOPICS SO IF YOU CAN-
TAKE SIX MINUTES TO INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES AND MOVE RIGHT INTO
YOUR PRESENTATION WOULD GREATLY
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR AVAILING YOURSELF. GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON. RELIGIOUS MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC KOKANEE LISTS IN A
DISTRICT SIXTY FOUR THIRTY. MY
NAME IS RANA AFICIONADO. IT IS
MY HONOR TO SERVE AS A DAD I
DOCTOR. ACTOR AND SHE OFFICER
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. THE APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR PART OF MY JOB IS TO
MAKE A SLOGAN CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
SLOWLY COME TO LIFE IT IS AN
EQUITY AGENDA IT IS WHAT THE
TESTIMONY THIS MORNING IS ALL
ABOUT. WHERE WE TALK ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT. IT IS SIX MINUTES I
AIM TO SHARE WHY RISK FACTORS
ARE NOT PREDICTIVE FACTORS. HE
HAD A PROTECTIVE FACTORS. AFTER
THE SPECIAL RACISM AND CLASSISM
AND DISCRIMINATION AND
SOCIOECONOMIC INEQUITY IN
HOUSING INCOME IN JOBS AND
EDUCATION CANNOT PREDICT THE
FUTURE LIKE THEY HAVE IN THE
PAST WE HAVE TO LEARN TO READ
AND I WAS FORWARD AND PROMOTE
COMMUNITY. LET'S FIRST PETER THE
OF THE RELEASE OF CALIFORNIA IN
THE BOTTOM RIGHT SIDE OF HISTORY
BEING THE COMMITTEE ON
INFECTIOUS DISEASES THINK BACK
TO WHEN OUR STATE WAS FOUNDED
DURING THE GOLD RUSH ERA. WHEN
IT HELD ONLY A PART IN A PUBLIC
HEALTH WAS FIRST FOUNDED NINE
OUT OF TEN CALIFORNIANS DIED OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASES. CHOLERA
TYPHOID AND OTHER DOCTOR TO TELL
YOU IT WAS INCREDIBLE. IT WAS A
CONDITIONS THE SAME CONDITIONS
OF CROWDED NOUS POVERTY. UNSAFE
WORKING ENVIRONMENTS THAT
CONTINUE TO PLAY. SOME MORE THAN
OTHERS. LAST FOUR TO THAT IN OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY AND WE SEE S.
DIFFERENT BURKE INSERT EIGHT.
LOWER LITERACY HIGHER. DENSITY
WORKPLACE ARE UNEMPLOYMENT DOES
IT IS VERY GOOD ACCORDING THE
PROCEEDINGS THE NATIONAL ACADEMY
OF SCIENCES WILL PRESENT OUR
CASE RATES AND MORTALITY. OF
INFLUENZA. HISTORY WILL REPEAT
ITSELF UNLESS WE ADDRESS THE
ROOT CAUSES. SADLY NOT A LOT HAS
CHANGED IN THE PAST CENTURY FAST
FORWARD TO TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THIS IS STACEY PH DATA ON THE Y.
AXIS IS THE PERCENT INCREASE IN
THE DEATH RATE LIFE EXPECTANCY
DROPPED BY SEVERAL YEARS IN SOME
COMMUNITIES MORE THAN OTHERS. WE
CONVENE THE TOP LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY IN THE MIDDLE
HOUSING OVERHEAD IN THE BOTTOM
POVERTY. IT AND CALLED SENATE
DOES RESPONSE. I THINK INCREASE
THE DOSE OF ANTI. THE RESPONSE
HARM TO THE BODY IN. AS YOU
INCREASE HOUSING OVERCROWDED IS
IN POVERTY YOU SEE A RISE IN
OVERALL DID NOT JUST COMMITTED.
AND SADLY THE RIGHT YOU CAN SEE
IMPACT ON RECENT. NOW OF THE
SOCIALIST OF HEALTH IS NOT
EQUALLY FELT ALMOST BLACK ASIANS
ONE AND PACIFIC ISLANDER HAVE A
POPULAR. AND WORST HIT LOBBYING
OR- YOU SEE THE DIFFERENT DEATH
TO ME THE WORST FORM OF INEQUITY
IS DISPROPORTIONATE TO AND
EQUITY DIVIDEND. BY DEFINITION
IS UNFAIR UNJUST INCREMENTAL
WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE TO BREAK
THOSE CYCLES TO BUILD BACK
STRONGER BOUNCE FORWARD AND BE
BETTER PREPARED FOR THE NEXT
CHALLENGE. BUT THE WORD HAD A
CHALLENGE WE SEE MORE KELLY
REVEALED COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
ARE GREATER FOR THE EMAILS
AFRICAN AMERICANS IT IS NOT JUST
RACE WE OVERLAY OTHER STRUCTURAL
FACTORS IT'S A MULTIPLIER EFFECT
IN GETS WORSE. PERFORMED LATINOS
AN ESSENTIAL WORKING AGE TWENTY
TO SIXTY FOUR WITHOUT MORE THAN
A HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION TEN
TIMES CODE NINETEEN DEATH RATES
THAN WHITES. IN CALIFORNIA. PART
OF THE HOT FOR IS TO MOVE UP.
NOT DOWNSTREAM LATE IN GAME OF
WE NEED ASK AND EASY YOU MAY. AT
THIS POINT I BY DOC YOUNG. BUT
WE TO MOVE US TO WE'RE- AND
SUPPORT THOSE. HOW HE SHOULD
CONNECTED CULTURE CAREGIVERS
THAT. THE SAME ROOM CAUSES THAT
BECAUSE REPORT DE IN THE COAL
MINE IN JUNE AND. ONE WE NEED A
PROGRAM. AND DOCTOR THE RAW AND
THE STRUCTURAL IN ARMENIAN
SYSTEMS REQUIRES P. S. C. MORE
OF POLICIES. AND IN. APPROACH
HERE THE BAR MODEL YOU SEE THE
DATA CRITICAL I THOSE UP THROUGH
LEAD CONDITION BACK THAT WE HAVE
ADDRESS. WE DON'T WANT HISTORY
TO REPEAT ITSELF THIS IS A POOR
. COMMUNITY PASSD BUILDING. SO
THE OF THE HELD A WE OVER THE
PAST NINETY. HAS WORKED TO
PROMOTE WELL BEING FOR ALL FORTY
HEALTH. BY DOES NOT CONDITIONS
TO A LITTLE INEQUITIES. WE DON'T
A VARIETY OF WORK IN A LOT MORE
AND TO BE. WE HIRED EMILY OSTER
A AGENCY AND AT THE STATE LEVEL
IN REFUSING FLOOD FEDERAL
FUNDING PROMOTING A LOCAL LEVEL
AS WE. WOULD NOT FALL ARE RACIAL
AND WE ISSUE. RESIDUAL LIKE THAT
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY INDEX TO READ
IF YOU RESOURCES TO AVOID THOSE
DE. THAT DOCTOR YOUNG S. DESERT
BAHASA OR ANY- SIR ELTON'S DATE
. THE SAME SAFETY SECURITY- SAY
INCREASE MY- IT LISTS THE
DIFFERENT STILL DETERMINANTS OF
. INCOME FOOD ACCESS IS A
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT QUALITY
AVOID JUST AND STRESS AND REALLY
HELD A APPROACH ALL SECTORS
COLLUDED HOTTEST ALL AGO. ALL OF
RESPONSE BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
LOOK A LOCAL COMMUNITY LEVEL.
TRACK NOT ENOUGH THE QUALITY OF
IT WILL EXPERIENCES ARE
EXPRESSED. IN THOUSAND TEN BY
EXECUTIVE ORDER OR SEEK HOLDEN
ALL. TASK FORCE HE CAN SEE IS
HER OF THE FACT IS EMBEDDED ALL
THE WE ARE LEVELS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IN. LOW COMMUNITIES.
SO ALL BY RETURNING THE SCHOOL
THAT REALLY FACTOR ON PERMITTED
TO BACK. BECAUSE OF PROTECTIVE.
WE HAVE TO. SAFE WORKING. IS
PAID CYNICAL. C. HOUSING AND
WELL IN IN A- AND COMMUNITY. SO
WE GET A BALANCED FORWARD AND
THE ROOT CAUSES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
ROHANI OCCASIONAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION- I. I
THINK YOU. YOUR PRESENTATION WAS
ABSOLUTELY ON TARGET AND IT'S A
COMMON THEME FOR THOSE WHO SPOKE
IN PREVIOUS- THE RACIAL
OVERTONES- THAT EXIST THAT WEEK
IT IS UNDENIABLE THAT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS THIS WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN HIT
THE HARDEST- THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC BUT- IT'S NOT A
SURPRISE FOR THE SIMPLE FACT WE
ALL KNOWING IT EXISTED BECAUSE
THE LACK OF RESOURCES. BUT AGAIN
THIS PANDEMIC IS BROUGHT TO THE
FOREFRONT AND I'M GLAD WE HAVE
IN THIS CONVERSATION AND THOSE
THESE EXPERTS HERE IS ACTUALLY
ARTICULATING THAT PARTICULAR
POINT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WE HOPE THAT YOU CAN ARE ABLE TO
STICK AROUND FOR A FEW MOMENTS.
ARE WE GOING TO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR YOU AND WE WOULD
LOVE TO- BEGIN THAT PROCESS
RIGHT NOW BEFORE WE INTRODUCE
OUR NEXT PANEL SO I HAVE THE
FIRST QUESTION I'LL- SEE IF MY
COLLEAGUE- SILVA RIVAS HAVE
QUESTIONS AS WELL. BUT THE FIRST
QUESTION I HAVE IS TO EITHER-
DOCTOR YOUNGER DOCTOR LAVON- AND
THE QUESTION IS THIS WHAT CAN
THE STATE DO BETTER FOR
COMMUNITIES IN AREAS FOR THEM TO
BETTER SERVE- COMMUNITIES. WHERE
HEALTH DISPARITIES INEQUITIES
EXIST. SO WHAT CAN IS THE DO
BETTER AND SO I'D INVITE- EITHER
YOU TO BE ABLE TACKLE THAT
QUESTION FOURTH. I'M HAPPY TO GO
FIRST. I'M SO I'M REALLY
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR ABOUT THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE COMING DOWN
THE PIPELINE TO ADDRESS COVE ED
ARE INEQUITIES AND RECOVERY. AND
I WOULD ARGUE THAT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WHEN DISTRIBUTING THE
STATE RESOURCES TO BE GREETING
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH ON HOW
THEY'RE APPEARING WITH RESPECT
TO HEALTH EQUITY. WHEN IT IS
FOUND THAT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE FAILING WHEN IT
COMES TO HEALTH EQUITY IT THEN
THE STATE REALLY NEEDS TO BE
THINKING ABOUT MECHANISMS OF
COMMUNITY ACCOUNTABILITY. SO
THAT THE RESOURCES CAN BE
FUNNELED TO COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BUT
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
ARE NOT AN IMPORTANT BARRIER TO
IMPLEMENTATION. THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND HE'S A COLOR NEED TO BE TOP
OF MIND- AND SO WE NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT THE MULTIPLE
FEEDBACK LOOPS SO CERTAINLY THAT
DIRECT- HOPEFULLY SORT OF
INTENDED OUTCOMES OF. THE
FUNDING AND DIFFERENT POLICIES
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO BE THINKING
ABOUT FEEDBACK LOOPS AND
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AS WELL.
I AND MY HOPE IS THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TO STRENGTHEN
EFFORTS TO WORK ALONGSIDE LOCAL
GRASSROOTS INITIATIVES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DR YOUNG YOU WANT
TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT IF YOU'RE
STILL THERE THEN I WILL GO TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS AND THEN
WE HAVE GOT ABOUT JACK DAVIS IS
JUST GETTING GOOD RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT.
WHEN EDITING A EVERYTHING I
EDUCATION. HOWEVER WE HAD A
BLAST EDUCATION SYSTEM NEED
COLLEGE. HOW NEEDS AT. THAT ARE
FUND. HOWEVER ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT- HELLO OF OUR STUDENTS. IS
RACISM IS. IN THE SCIENCES SO IT
IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
STATE TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
ACCESS TO EDUCATION. ESPECIALLY
FOR THE HEALTH PROFESSIONS. SO
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES. HELLO YEAR
. THE CAN ADD OUR OWN MEMBERS IN
FRIENDS. ON THE MEASURES OF THE
NATION'S. WHAT IF I DIDN'T HAVE
THE KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING WITH MY MOTHER. WHAT
IF I DIDN'T HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE
OF WHAT WAS HAPPENING WITH. MY
NIECE WHO HAD INTO THE SESSION.
I DIDN'T ABLE TO DIRECTLY IMPACT
MY COMMUNITY MY FAMILY. BECAUSE
OF THE EDUCATION I RECEIVED. IT
IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
SPEECH WAS SHORT THAT MORE
STUDENTS OF COLOR. THAT BLACK
BROWN NATIVE AMERICANS THAT WE
HAD ACCESS TO EDUCATION. THAT
WE'RE NOT LOADED WITH STUDENT
DEBTS THAT ARE DEBTS ARE
FORGIVEN. ADD THAT OUR LOANS ARE
FORGIVEN AS WELL THAT WAY WE CAN
WORK IN A COMMUNITY MORE. SO IT
IS IMPORTANT IN ALL OF THOSE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS TO ENSURE.
THAT THERE IS ACCESS FOR THOSE.
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES I WANTED
TO ADD ONE MORE THING AND THAT
IS THAT IS AREAS THE STATE HAS
FINDING OUT HOW THE NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE THE BILL HAS GONE
OUT AND WE HOPE THAT WILL GO
THROUGH. WE NEED TO BUILD-
ABSOLUTELY NO REASON WHY RIGHT.
ACETAMINOPHEN LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD. THAT WE DO RESOURCES
FOR PEOPLE. THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
NO REASON. AND SO REGARDLESS OF
WHO. YOU KNOW CARRIES BELIEVES
OF RACISM OR CLASSISM. THE STATE
HAS RESPONSIBILITY TO ASK PEOPLE
. TO ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE
MAKING DECISIONS THOSE ARE
ALLOCATING FUNDING. ELIMINATE
THESE DEBTORS. THAT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE STATE. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITH YOU THAT'S WHY THIS
HEARING IS ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMMENTS
I WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO NOW-
MY COLLEAGUE- SO MEMBER RIVAS
FOR HIS QUESTION OR COMMENT YEAH
SO MY QUESTIONS AROUND STRATEGY
I THINK I REALLY APPRECIATE
THOSE COMMENTS YOU KNOW.
OBVIOUSLY HERE IN OUR STATE. OUR
OUR OUR YOU KNOW ECONOMIC
PROGRESS FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD AS WE JUST HEARD ON
VERGE OF BECOMING THE FOURTH
LARGEST IN THE WORLD WE HAVE A
LOT OF RESOURCES BUT IT'S THE
EFFICIENCY OF ENSURING THAT
THOSE RESOURCES YOU KNOW-
SERVICE- THE INTENDED PURPOSES
AND THEY REACH THE RIGHT-
RESIDENTS IN THE COMMUNITIES.
AND I JUST ON THE LEGISLATURE
THIS IS ONLY MY THIRD YEAR I AND
I'VE LEARNED THAT I SEE AS VERY
LARGE STATE IT'S A DIFFICULT
STATE TO GOVERN IT'S A DIFFICULT
STATE TO SOLVE PROBLEMS AND
ADDRESS ISSUES EQUITABLY BECAUSE
WE ARE SO LARGE GEOGRAPHICALLY
WE ARE SO LARGE BY. POPULATION A
LOT OF NEEDS A LOT OF- SOME DEAD
AT THT DIVERSITY HERE IN OUR
STATE. AND I WAS ON AN AG TOUR
IN SAN FRANCISCO YESTERDAY- AND
I MET WITH A COHORT- OF US
PROFESSORS FROM- UC BERKELEY.
ABOUT EXCESSIVE HEAT WHAT CAN WE
DO AS A STATE AROUND YOU KNOW.
PREVENTING ILLNESS TO THOSE ARE
MOST VULNERABLE SPECIAL AG
WORKERS WORK OUTSIDE. AND
IMMEDIATELY AS POLICYMAKERS WE
SAY HEY WE WANT TO PROTECT THESE
WORKERS AND SO MY INNATE
REACTION IS YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT
TO LOOK TO IMPROVE WORKING
CONDITIONS AND THESE PROFESSORS
BASICALLY SAID HEY YOU WANT TO
HAVE THE GREATEST IMPACT ON
THESE WORKERS. YOU HAVE TO
IMPROVE THEIR LIVING CONDITIONS-
HOUSING HOMELESS CRITICAL
OVERCROWDING I EXPERIENCE IN MY
DISTRICT I GREW UP IN A IN IN IN
FORMER HOUSING. YOU DON'T HAVE
YOU KNOW ADEQUATE I WAS COOLEY
SYSTEMS SO THE REASON I MENTION
THAT IS BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH
WHEN WE TOOK WHEN WE LOOK AT
THAT HEALTH- THE DISPARITIES
WERE SEEKING TO ADDRESS AND
SOLVE. THEIR SO MUCH INSTABILITY
WITH YOU KNOW THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE ESPECIALLY FROM WAS ONE OF
A RESIDENTS HOUSING INSTABILITY
AND SECURITY FOOD SECURITY
ECONOMIC INSTABILITY. AND SO.
WHAT IS THE BEST STRATEGY IN IN.
YOU KNOW IN IN IN SEEKING TO
ELIMINATE THESE HEALTH- THE
DISPARITIES IN IN UNDERSTANDING
THESE DISPARITIES IN SEEKING TO
ADDRESS IT WHAT IS THE STRATEGY
AND HOW DO WE ACCOUNT FOR. THE
DIVERSITY THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
DO WE HAVE A GOOD UNDERSTANDING
OF THE PROBLEM STATEWIDE AND HOW
DO WE ADDRESS IT IS IT A
PIECEMEAL APPROACH BECAUSE WHAT
WORKS WELL HERE IN THE SIXTY
FOURTH MAY NOT WORK WELL IN THE
FIRST DISTRICT UP NORTH OR IN MY
OWN DISTRICT SO HOW DO WE
ACCOUNT FOR THAT IS IT A
REGIONAL APPROACH WE HAVE TO
TAKE IS A STATE. YOU KNOW- IS A
STATEWIDE APPROACH. SO OFTEN
ALONG WITH A QUESTION. SO DOES
ANYONE WANTS TO TAKE A STAB AT
THAT BEFORE WE GO TO DOCTOR
DAVIS. I'VE HAD- THANK YOU FOR
THAT REALLY IMPORTANT QUESTION
AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE
ANSWER IS A BOTH HANDS AT THAT
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE
BUILDING UP STATEWIDE COALITIONS
TO BE ADDRESSING THESE QUESTIONS
WHETHER IT COMES TO COVERT
RECOVERY TO CLIMATE RESILIENCE.
WHATEVER THE EQUITY ISSUE IS OF
OUR TIME AND WE ALSO NEED TO BE
INVESTING IN- LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS
TO BE DEFINING COVERT RECOVERY
PLANS- AND CLIMATE RESILIENCE
PLANS. AT WE IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THESE ARE STRATEGIES THAT ARE
DESIGNED BY THOSE WHO ARE MOST
AFFECTED BY THESE ISSUES OF
COVERT INJUSTICES CLIMATE
INJUSTICES. AND OFTEN- WIDE
SOCIAL MOVEMENT LEADERS TEACH US
IS THAT WHEN AFFECTED COMMUNITY
LEADERS MEMBERS ARE DESIGNING
THESE PLANS THEY BOTH- YIELD
INSIGHTS INTO HOW WE NEED TO
CHANGE CURRENT SYSTEMS TO
OPERATE MORE EQUITABLY. AND THEY
ALSO PRODUCE- RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR NEW SYSTEMS THAT ARE NEEDED
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEMS ARE FAILING LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AND THOSE
SAME COMMUNITIES HAVE THE TOOLS
AND SOLUTIONS AT HAND AND WE
NEED TO BE FUNDING THEM ROBUSTLY
TO BE DEVELOPING NOT. THANK
DOCTOR ARE RUSH ARK KITCHENER I
THINK YOU WANTED TO COMMENT.
THAT ARE HEARD YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT
WE SAW FROM DOCTOR YOUNG THE
GEOSPATIAL ANALYSIS WHERE
THERE'S BEEN LESS RESOURCES AND
POWER IN DECISION MAKING OVER
TIME THAT'S LED TO THAT DESERT
YOU BEDS- DEBTORS DEBTORS AND
OTHER RESOURCES. AND SIMILARLY
WE DO HAVE TOOLS IN PLACE TO HOT
SPOT ARADIA FULL CONCERNS
HEALTHY LEAD AFTER THE MEETING
THAT WE USED TO GET DOWN TO THE
CENSUS TRACT LEVEL IN
NEIGHBORHOODS TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONDITIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER RITA
SPOKE ABOUT AND WE CAN USE THOSE
FOR COMMON RISKS FOR ALL.
ETERNITY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIFTED
MISSION. FOR EXTREME HEAT DAYS
THAT ARE PROJECTED INTO THE
FUTURE WE USE THIS TOOL. BILLION
DOLLARS STATE GRANT FUNDING TO
GET THEM TO THE COMMUNITIES THAT
NEED THEM THE MOST AGAIN TO
BOLSTER THE PROTECTIVE. IS TO BE
PAIRED WITH LOCAL EXPERTISE FROM
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS AND
LIMITATION. I ALSO WANT. SURE
YES DOCTOR WHEN I AGREE A 100%
WITH WHAT WAS JUST SAID AND THE
LIMITING FACTOR THAT WE ALWAYS
HAD IT THANK. WE DON'T NEED MORE
RESEARCH WE KNOW WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE AND WE DON'T HAVE
FUNDING. IF WE HOW THE FUNDING
WE CAN GET THINGS GOING AND
REALLY DO THE WORK TO ELIMINATE
THESE HEALTH DISPARITIES. YOU
VERY MUCH AND THAT REALLY GOES
TO- AGAIN ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS AND TWENTY THREE OTHERS
INCLUDING MYSELF AS WE AUTHORED
A BIPARTISAN LETTER TO THE
GOVERNOR REGARDING THE
CALIFORNIA- HEALTH EQUITY RACIAL
JUSTICE BOND- TO TALK ABOUT AND
PUT RESOURCES- TARGETING
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR BUT ALSO I
OFTEN. EIGHT THAT SPECIFICALLY
WOULD HAVE EMPOWERED RESOURCES-
CLINICS- TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN THIS
BILL WOULD HAVE FOCUSED ON-
HOUSING OF FOOD INSECURITIES AS
OF THE STILL A MEMBER INDICATED
EMPLOYMENT INSTABILITIES UNDER
RESOURCE SCHOOLS AND ALSO CHILD
CARE AND ALSO COMMUNITY VIOLENCE
IS ALSO ONE AND HATE CRIMES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE AND SO I
THINK WE'RE ON TO SOMETHING I
THINK THIS WE JUST NEED TO ONE.
COME AROUND AND COLLABORATE ON
HOW TO MOVE THIS FORWARD TO GET
THE KIND OF RESOURCE THAT
CONTAINER HERE THEY RESOURCES
CONTINUE TO BE AN ISSUE. IN OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. I REMEMBER
RIVAS YEAH IF I COULD ADD
SOMETHING REALLY QUICKLY BECAUSE
YOU KNOW AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS WE DEALT WITH A
LOT OF THESE ISSUES- ESPECIALLY
LAST YEAR- AMID THE PANDEMIC.
AND I AGREE WITH WHAT HAS BEEN
SAID AS FAR AS THE APPROACH. YOU
KNOW- WE HAVE A GOOD ASSESSMENT
OF THE PROBLEM. FUNDING IS KEY.
AB ONE FUNDING WAS MADE
AVAILABLE. YOU KNOW FOR CERTAIN
REGIONS OF THE STATE. OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AGREED OR- THEY
DISAGREED I GUESS I SHOULD SAY
WITH THE PROBLEMS AND ISSUES.
THEY DIDN'T USE THOSE FINDINGS
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS AND THEY
JUST EXACERBATED THESE- HEALTH
DISPARITIES AS WE KNOW IT. R. AS
WE KNOW THEM AND SO I GUESS YOU
KNOW KEEP THAT IN MIND AS FAR AS
HOW DO WE OVERCOME THAT TO
WHERE. PEOPLE ON OUR YOU KNOW
SOME RESIDENTS AND OUR STATES
AND- IN SOME PARTS OF OUR STATE.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A GOOD
STRUCTURE GOOD FOUNDATION BUT IN
OTHER PARTS- THEY'LL BE LEFT
BEHIND AND SO IF WE'RE GOING TO
REALLY ELIMINATE THESE
DISPARITIES. ACROSS THE BOARD
STATEWIDE ESPECIALLY THOSE
REGIONS THAT NEED IT MOST YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO DEVELOP A YOU
KNOW A COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY ON
HOW WE OVERCOME. I WANT TO BRING
I WANT TO BRING IN- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DOCTOR DAVIS FOR BEING
SO PATIENT. OF DOCTOR DAVIS WHO
IS A HEALTH OFFICER OF LOS
ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH- PLEASE TAKE A FEW
MOMENTS IT INDUCES SELF AND
ALSO- IN LIGHT AS IF YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. O. K. NO
DOCTOR DAVIS. THEY WILL ACT GET
HIM SOON. SO AGAIN IS THE COMMON
THEME HAS HAS CERTAINLY BEEN AND
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT PANEL-
IS IT RESOURCES AND I THINK
THAT- WHAT THE LEGISLATURE DONE
WITH THE LETTER TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- AND I THINK
ALL OF YOU HELP CAN HELP PLAY A
MAJOR ROLE IN MAKING SURE THAT
WHEN WE GET THOSE RESOURCES
BECAUSE I'M I'M NOT I DON'T WANT
IS HAVE MEETINGS TO HAVE
MEETINGS HERE ARE SELF TAUGHT.
WE DON'T NEED TO DO FURTHER
RESEARCH WE ALREADY KNOW WHERE
THE ISSUES ARE- WE CAN PULL THEM
UP BY ZIP CODES ARE AREAS AND
NINE TIMES OUT OF TEN IT WILL
ABSOLUTELY DRIVE- AND SHOW
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- WITH THE
HELP DISPARITIES WHETHER IT'S
HYPERTENSION DIABETES THE LIST
GOES ON AND ON AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN LATINOS HAS BEEN ON A
LIST DAM AND I'M READY FOR US TO
BE OFF THAT LIST. AND REALLY GET
RESOURCES SO THAT WE CAN TURN
AND RIDE NEW NARRATIVE- FOR ARE
NOT ONLY ARE GENERATIONS BUT OUR
OUR OUR PARENTS AND OTHER ELDERS
IN OUR COMMUNITY SO THAT THEY
CAN LIVE A LONG PROSPEROUS LIFE
IT SHOULD NOT BE WHERE IS
CHRONICLED INTO THE DATA WHERE
DO YOU LIVE IN ONE SEGMENT OF
LOS ANGELES LIKE SAY THE EAST
SIDE. THAT YOUR MORTALITY RATE
IS DIFFERENT AND LESS THAN IT
WOULD BE ON THE WEST SIDE OF LOS
ANGELES AND WE HAVE THE DRESS
THAT THAT'S THE ELEPHANT IN THE
ROOM AND WE NEED A PLAN IN ORDER
pPARTICULAR POINT SO DURING OUR
FIRST PANEL- WE HAVE HEARD FROM
THE CAUSES EFFECTS OF HEALTH-
INEQUALITIES AND HOW THEY HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED- ON THE STATE AND
COUNTY LEVEL NOW WE WILL TURN TO
THE HEART. OF OUR COMMUNITY AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING CLINICS AND TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS EACH ORGANIZATION
WILL DESCRIBE HOW THEY ADDRESS
THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH IN THEIR WORK IN ORDER TO
PROMOTE- HEALTH EQUITY AND SO
IT'S KIND OF WOULD HAVE UP TO
SIX MINUTES AND PLEASE THE NO
SIX MINUTES TO COMPLETE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND THEN.
PROCEED WITH THE PRESENTATION.
AS SO I GIVE A GREAT TO- OFF-
MISTER CARLOS TORRES- WHO IS
EXECUTIVE. LGBT Q. LONG BEACH
CENTER WHO IS HERE PHYSICALLY IN
THE ROOM THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US HERE CALCI DIVERSITY
BECAUSE HILLS. AND WELCOME AND
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND
PERCY. GOOD MORNING- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON AND REVERSED THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE WITH YOU THIS MORNING- IT
IS. I'M HUMBLED BY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE BEFORE YOU
TODAY AND I TRULY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE. AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL THIS AND A SOFT OFTENTIMES
IN SKIT- FOCUS IN SACRAMENTO AND
SO I REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOU
COMING. TO OUR COMMUNITIES TO
LISTEN TO WHAT WE HAVE TO SAY.
MY NAME IS CARL STORIES ARE YOU
SEE HIM PRONOUNS AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LGBTQ
CENTER LONG BEACH- THE CENTER
HAS BEEN AROUND FOR ABOUT FORTY
YEARS. AND WE REALLY ARE BECAUSE
ON COMMUNITY SERVICE OR SERVE IN
OUR COMMUNITY. I'M SADDENED TO
SAY THAT YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY
I WILL BE DOING SOME REPEATING
OF- TWO ONE MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ALREADY BROUGHT ATTENTION TO THE
ISSUE OF HEALTH EQUITY- ITS
FOCUS ON THE THINGS THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT- SERVICE THAT
SERVES AS DR YOUNG. SHARE WITH
US EARLIER WHICH IN OUR REGION
THEY ARE S- DEMONSTRATED BY THE
MAPS THAT WERE SHARED WITH US
EARLIER YES IT IS. A HUGE GAP
RIGHT IN IN. ADEQUATE WELCOMING
SAFE- SERVICES FOR OUR COMMUNITY
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOUSING
BUT AGAIN I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
. RIGHT SO WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT MARKET RATE HOUSING.
BECAUSE THOSE MARKET RATE
OPTIONS ARE NOT AVAILABLE TO THE
PEOPLE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SO WE
HAVE TO. BE INTENTIONAL ABOUT
HOW THOSE RESOURCES THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT IN THE LAST
FEW MINUTES ARE ALLOCATED. SO WE
HAD TO BE INTENTIONAL ON WE HAVE
TO BE PURPOSEFUL ABOUT. HOW THE
RESOURCES ARE BROUGHT ABOUT AND
WHO GETS ACCESS TO THOSE
RESOURCES S. IT WAS BROUGHT UP
BY. DR LEBRON EARLIER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FOOD INSECURITY.
RIGHT AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HEALTHY FOODS NOT FAST FOOD
RESTAURANTS HEALTHY FOODS.
RESTAURANTS. RIGHT SO WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
HAVE ACCESS TO SO WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DATA FOR WILL
HOUSING WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS
WITHIN NEIGHBORHOODS OF
OPPORTUNITY I NEVER HEARD OF
OPPORTUNITY AT THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT HAVE. GROCERY
STORES. ARMOS SEES EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AFFORDABLE DAYCARE
SAFE ROADS ACCESS TO PUBLIC
TRANSIT AND THE LIST GOES ON AND
ON SO AGAIN WE HAVE TO BE
INTENTIONAL JUST BUILDING
HOUSING AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEXT
TO A LAN FIELD IS NOT ACCEPTABLE
. THAT IS NOT THE ANSWER THE
OTHER PIECE OF COURSE IS
EMPLOYMENT STABILITY.
UNFORTUNATELY ALL THESE FACTORS
AT ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE WHICH
OF COURSE HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP
BUT FROM OUR LANDS AS- AND LGBTQ
COMMUNITY SPACE. WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL THESE AREAS. BRING
ABOUT ELAN'S OF SAFETY.
WELCOMING AND ACCEPTANCE WE
CANNOT. HE EXPECTED TO NOT BE
OURSELVES WHEN WE WALK WORK
EXCUSE ME WALK INTO A PLACE OF
EMPLOYMENT. WE CANNOT. AFFORD
NOT TO BE OURSELVES IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE WE LIVE WE
CANNOT AFFORD NOT TO BE
OURSELVES WHEN WE ACCESS HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. RIGHT SO AGAIN I
GO BACK TO THE PEACE WE HAVE TO
BE INTENTIONAL HOW DO WE
LEVERAGE THE KNOWLEDGE THE
EXPERTISE AND THE LIVED
EXPERIENCES OF THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE TRYING TO IMPACT. WE ARE
INTENTIONAL ABOUT FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES ORIENTATION ABOUT
LEGISLATION WERE INTENTIONAL
ABOUT PARTNERSHIPS AND WE'RE
INTENTIONAL ABOUT OUTCOMES.
THAT'S HOW WE BEGIN TO CHANGE
THE LANDSCAPE. AGAIN I AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES WOULD ANY
RESEARCH THERE'S PLENTY OF
RESEARCH WE KNOW THERE SERVE
WHERE THIS IS AT THE SERVICES
ARE. NOT LET'S GET TO WORK LESS
ENGAGE- AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID
EARLIER LISTING GAUGE THOSE
COMMUNITY PARTNERS LESS ENGAGE
THIS COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT HAD
THE LIVED EXPERIENCE THAT HAVE
THE HISTORY OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
THAT HAVE BEEN THROUGH THE UPS
AND THE DOWNS IN THE VALLEYS OF
. SOCIAL INJUSTICE AND
EQUALITIES RACISM SEXISM
XENOPHOBIA HOMOPHOBIA ALL OF IT
. SO LOOKING THROUGH A THE
HEALTH EQUITY AND AN INFECTIOUS
DISEASES SUCH GIVING FOR A
MOMENT I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
LATEST PUBLICATION FROM THE LONG
BEACH DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
STATES THAT IN LONG BEACH. I
RATES OF HIV. RATE OF HIV OUR
DOUBLE THE RATE OF HIV AT THE
STATE LEVEL. DOUBLE AND I DON'T
NEED TO TELL HIS AUDIENCE BUT IF
YOU WERE TO GUESS. BLACK LATINO. YOUNG MEN ARE THE PRIMARY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE INFECTED
WITH HIV. SO WHAT CAN WE DO.
AGAIN WE HAVE TO BE INTENTIONAL
WE HAVE TO BE PURPOSEFUL. WHEN
THOSE RESOURCES AND I KNOW THAT
IN CALIFORNIA WE THINK WE HAVE A
LOT OF RESOURCES BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY WHEN WE PRINT ADDRESS
THE DIFFERENT THINGS THAT ARE
NEEDED. THOSE RESOURCES BECOME
LIMITED WE HAVE TO BE
INTENTIONAL ABOUT HOW WE
ALLOCATE THOSE RESOURCES AND
SHARE THOSE RESOURCES TO THE
COMMUNITY THE OTHER PIECE THAT I
CAN SHARE WITH YOU IS- AS A
STATE. AND THIS IS A NATIONWIDE
PROBLEM BUT AS A STATE WE LACKED
THE ABILITY WHEN WE ARE
PROVIDING. MEDICAL SERVICES TO
OUR ENTIRE COMMUNITY I AM NOT
TALKING ABOUT JUST LGBT BUT OUR
ENTIRE COMMUNITY OUR SYSTEMS
LACK. THE ABILITY. FOR US. TO BE
OUR TRUE SELVES WHAT DO I MEAN
BY THAT MOST IN MOST HEALTH CARE
SETTINGS THEY ASK YOU FOR YOUR-
GIVEN NAME. WHICH MAY OR MAY NOT
BE THE NAME THAT I GO BACK TODAY. THEY ASK YOU YOUR GENDER BIRTH
WHICH MAY OR MAY NOT BE THAT THE
VENDOR BOOK WHICH IDENTIFY.
RIGHT IN MOST HEALTH CARE
SETTINGS THEY ASK YOU ABOUT YOUR
WIFE OR HUSBAND. MOST HEALTH
CARE SETTINGS. IT'S NOT SAFE FOR
ME TO BE MYSELF. BECAUSE EITHER
PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE ME PEOPLE
HAVE AN ACCENT LIKE I DO PEOPLE
THAT HAVE THE SAME COLORS CAN.
AND THE LIST GOES ON AND ON AND
ON. SO AGAIN WE NEED TO BE
INTENTIONAL WE NEED TO BE
PERSONAL PROPOSAL AND WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THE FINAL OUTCOME WHAT
DO WE WANT THE INTERVENTION THAT
MEDICAL INTERVENTION IT WE'RE
TALKING A MEDICALLY
SPECIFICALLY. WHETHER WE WIN THE
AKRON OF THE MEDICAL
INTERVENTION TO BE HE SAID JUST
TO GIVE YOU A BANDAID AND SAY.
YOU KNOW THIS IS NOT COVERED.
WELL THIS IS NOT- SOMETHING
RELATED TO ANOTHER MEDICAL
ISSUE. GO HOME BECAUSE I KNOW
BETTER THAN YOU DO. NOW WE HAVE
TO BE INTENTIONAL AND WE HAVE TO
BE PURPOSEFUL ABOUT WHAT WE DO
AND I DO APPRECIATE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- GIPSON REVERSE FOR THE
LETTER- AND THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE. WHO
WROTE THE LETTER TO THE GOVERNOR
BUT I WOULD- YOU KNOW ENCOURAGE
YOU TO THINK ABOUT.
INTENTIONALITY AND IMPACT S. THE
OVERARCHING GOAL OF THEIR
RESOURCES BECAUSE AGAIN LIKE-
YOU KNOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER REAL
ESTATE WHAT WORKS IN ONE AREA OF
THE STATEMENT OF WORK IN A
DIFFERENT AREA BUT WE LEVERAGE
THE EXPERTISE THE KNOWLEDGE LIVE
EXPERIENCES OF THE COMMUNITIES
WE TRYING TO. AFFECT IT WILL
HAVE A MUCH BETTER DESIRE.
UNLESS UP THERE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE IT. AND I WILL WHEN
IT'S TIME TO ASK QUESTIONS I
WANT TO PUT THIS ON YOUR MIND
ARE WE ASKING FOR TOO MUCH ARE
WE ASKING FOR ON THINGS THAT ON
A REASONABLE FOR OUR COMMUNITY
SO MUCH OF PONDERED OVER THAT
WELL WE GO TO OUR- STUDENTS OUR
NEXT PRESENTER- OUR NEXT
PRESENTERS TERRY SMITH WHO IS
THE DIRECTOR. OF HIV PREVENTION
SERVICES AT A. P. LA. HEALTH
WHO'S WITH US PHYSICALLY SO
TERRY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE IF YOU CAN YOU HAVE
UP TO SIX MINUTES AGO PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND THEN
PROCEED WITH YOUR PRESENTATION
AND HAPPY THAT YOU JOIN US THIS
MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
MY NAME IS TERRY SMITH I AM
DIRECTOR OF SEXUAL HEALTH AND
HIV PREVENTION SERVICES. A. P.
LA HEALTH. ON I THINK TO KIND OF
BEGAN. TALKING ABOUT HOW WE
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE APLE HEALTH
IS COMMITTED TO NASA'S MISSION
TO PROVIDE QUALITY CARE FOR THE
LGBT COMMUNITY. I THINK WE TALK
ABOUT HEALTH DISPARITIES. IT'S
IMPORTANT HAVE A CONTEXT ARE
LISTED A WONDERFUL JOB OF LAYING
OUT. ON THE IMPACT OF HIV IN OUR
COMMUNITY NOT JUST ONE
UNDERSCORE FROM THINGS I THINK
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT. L. A.
COUNTY MAKES UP TWENTY FIVE
POINT 2% OF THE POPULATION THE
STATE. IT HAS THIRTY FOUR POINT
2% OF ALL HIV DIAGNOSIS. THE
MOST COMMON MEANS OF
TRANSMISSION IS MEN WITH SEX
WITH MEN EIGHTY ONE PERCENT. 50%
OF THESE DIAGNOSIS WERE AMONG
LATINO MSM 20% WHITE 21% BLACK
AND 5% APR. BLACKS MAKE UP 21%
OF NEW HIV CASES IN L. A. COUNTY
IN SPITE OF BEING A PERCENT OF
POPULATION. IT IS JUST M THE
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS MAKE UP
QUITE ONE THE TWENTY POINT 5% OF
THE TOTAL PACKAGE L. A. COUNTY
YET THEY MAKE UP 2% OF NEW HIV
POSITIVE DIAGNOSIS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AND HIV CONTINUES TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT YOUNG
GAY BISEXUAL MEN OF COLOR. ALONG
WITH HIV WE ARE TALK ABOUT STDS
AS WELL BECAUSE WE CURRENTLY
HAVE AN STD EPIDEMIC THAT'S OUT
OF CONTROL WITH UNFORTUNATE
ABOUT THIS IS THAT WE ARE NOW IN
A TIME WHERE WE HAVE EVERYTHING
THAT WE NEED TO END HIV
EPIDEMIC. AS WELL AS A FEW
DIFFERENT IMAGE WE GET WE DON'T
AND SO I THINK THAT THIS IS. A
CHALLENGE BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO
ALREADY IMPACTED BY RACIAL
ETHNIC DISCRIMINATION.
UNDERSCORE CARLOS'S POINT
THEY'RE BEING DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST BY WHO THEY ARE AND WHO
THEY LOVE. AND THIS LACK OF
ACCESS TO CULTURALLY RELEVANT
SERVICES AND SO I THINK THE
LUCIANS REALLY ARE ABOUT
PROVIDING RESOURCES TO EXISTING
CBO TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES. TO EXPAND THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SERVICES. I THINK
ALSO FOR ANYONE WHO PROVIDING
SERVICES ARE FUNDED BY THE STATE
THE RELEASE BE CLOSELY COPSEY
TRAINING ON TERMS OF HOW TO DEAL
WITH LGBTQ FOLKS BECAUSE IT IS A
SPECIAL. TYPE OF THING AND ALL
YOU NEED IS SOMEONE TO GO INTO A
SPACE WHERE THEY TRY TO GET
SERVICES. AND THEY ARE THEIR
INCOMING SOME NONSENSE AROUND I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHO YOU ARE I
DON'T GET TO PRO NOW YOU DON'T
LOOK LIKE THIS AND ALL THAT
RIGHT IT'S ABOUT PROVIDING
SERVICES. WE TO ADDRESS HIV
STIGMA BECAUSE IT IS STILL REAL
THAT KEEP PEOPLE FROM ACCESSING
SERVICES. WE ALSO NEED TO
ADDRESS HOMOPHOBIA TRANSPHOBIA
COULD AGAIN THOSE ARE THINGS
THAT PERPETUATE AND KEEP PEOPLE
OUT OF SERVICES AND NOT JUST
THOSE PEOPLE OUT THERE FOR FOLKS
IN OUR OWN COMMUNITY SINCE WITH
A REAL HARD CONVERSATIONS. ABOUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS THAT.
WOULD ALSO ENSURE THAT FOLKS
HAVE ACCESS TO SOCIAL SERVICES
IN THEIR COMMUNITY INCREASE
FUNDING FOR STD SERVICES BECAUSE
STD SERVICES AND CALIFORNIA HAVE
BEEN WOEFULLY UNFUNDED FOR
YEARS. AND THEN ENSURE THAT
PROVIDERS A SEXUAL SERVICES FUND
TALK ABOUT HIV TESTING STD.
SCREENING AND TREATMENT PREP AND
PAP X. THE GET TO CARE FOR P.
WHO ARE A- POSITIVE. THE BILL.
ARE ALSO- IN A NEW RIGHT. NOT
JUST. HOURS RIGHT SO. A CRACK
OPEN A TO FIVE IS NOT SERVING
THE COMMUNITY. A CLICK OF OPEN
TO FOR. IS NOT SERVING THE CAN
PEOPLE WORKING HAVE LIVES OR
WHATEVER IT'S A REALLY BEGINNING
TO PUT- SPACES WERE OUR
COMMUNICATIVE AND ACCESS TO
SERVICES AT TIMES THAT ARE
CONVENIENT TO THEM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH- AND WE
GET TO THE QUESTIONS- SEGMENT OF
A PHOTO TO DR DAVID DOCTOR DAVIS
YOU WITH US- EIGHT WANT TO PUT
ON YOUR MIND- MISTER SMITH IS-
WHICH TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT GETTING TO ZERO
AND NOW WE CAN GET A ZERO BASED
ON THE STATISTICS YOU TO SHARE
WITH US SO I WANT TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE-
BECAUSE WE'RE ALL PUSHING THE
CAMPAIGN GETTING TO ZERO I WAS
PART OF IT. AND NOW THIS
PANDEMIC ENTER INTO OUR WORLD
AND IT'S HARD TO SEE AS GETTING
TO ZERO NOW BECAUSE WE'RE IN THE
MIDST OF A STAR DR DAVIS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US IF
YOU COULD JUST PLACE PLEASE TAKE
UP YOU KNOW- WE HAVE SIX MINUTES
FOR YOU AND YOU CAN JUST
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND-
PERCEIVED REPRESENTATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING BACK
AND JOINING US. NO PROBLEM THANK
YOU. ARE YOU SO- NO COST IT IS
TRYING TO WITH OUR INTERNATIONAL
OKAY. MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME
IS WANTS TO DO- AND I'M THE LOS
COUNTY OFFICE. I AM NOT TO BE
HERE WITH YOU TODAY- YOU KNOW
TALKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE. I
REMEMBERED MANY IDEA AND THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING STATION OR
SAYS THE SCENERY AND- I WAS VERY
PLEASED TO BE HERE WITH YOU. I
APPRECIATE ALL THE POINTS OF AN
ARE SO FAR. I SAID MOST MY
CAREER WE'RE TOWARD TRYING- IN
MY- WE'RE- HAVE ASKED TO SOURCE
IS NOT NEEDS PRIOR. ONE OF THE I
ENDED IN HEALTH IS HE AFTER LIKE
I AM DOING IT BY. IF YOU DO
BETTER THAN MINE IN SUPPORT. OF
THIS QUESTION I MEAN I THAT- ALL
BECAUSE- ABOUT TO SAY GOODBYE
BEING ABOUT THE SIZE OUT THE
LOWER. THOSE THINGS THAT MIGHT
BE TO RUN TO. A HEALTH AND- THAT
COULD QUALIFY AS. ACTUALLY BROWN
WORKS AND HEALTH INEQUITIES
CALIFORNIA'S IMPORTANT
RESTAURANTEURS IN THE PROCESS OF
THESE ACTIVITIES. I WANNA START
ST DISPARITIES. OUR MANY
DIFFERENCES IN USINESS OWNERS
THIS ZARIF FIRST AND- YEAH
COMMUNITY TO FOR- ACETATE. MYERS
AT GUARANTEED A DIFFERENT TO
GROUPS OF PEOPLE RACKERS. AND
HAVE ALWAYS COME FROM DISEASE OR
- AND YOUR IN DEVELOPING BEING
TO RACHAEL AMERICANS YOUR WRIST
LAST THE LAST ORDER SO LIKE MINE
WHILE YOU A STRESS. IN ADDITION
PERSONS AND HAVE OFFICE. BUT
PEOPLE THAT RESPECT IS ARE LARGE
SHAPED BOB OF BOTH A- IN WHICH
OF ALL. GROW WORSE ANTI EIGHT
AND RESOURCE ARE TO READILY SEE
THAT. WE'RE WE SEE AND THAT
WOULD VETERANS AWARE AND I JUST
WORKING ON. I CONTROL. CATION
SAFETY ETCETERA UNLESS ALL. AND
WHEN WE BETTER HEALTH YES IRAQ
OF ILLNESS OR INJURY ARE AT B.
THIS IS GONNA BE MANNER BY OKAY
ADDITION ACCESS TO RESOURCES AND
OPPORTUNITIES NEED WE SEE THAT
SOMEWHERE. IN THE- OUR MISSION
IS AN OPERATOR ACCESS THE
RESOURCE AND OPPORTUNITIES
THAT'S GENERALLY HOW THE NOT.
READ TO WEAR SOMETHING THAT BEEN
THERE SINCE AND RENTAL ACCESS TO
THOSE AND OPPORTUNITY OR OUT AND
ABOUT IN IT SHE OUR POLICIES.
PROCEDURES A BUSINESS IT IS THE
SECOND EVER. IT IS THE WAYS IN
WHICH OUR VALUES AND BACK IN A
BUYING SPREE A SYSTEM THAT TALK
ABOUT. THAT VERY THAT AWAY AND I
WILL. WHICH MAINTAIN OUR THAT
AND SEE. WHEN I GOT BUSINESS
ALREADY. POLICIES PRACTICES
ORANGE. OR UNFAIR CREATE STAINED
RADIOLOGY. AND IN POINT IN WELL
EDUCATION. AND ARE AT THE CORE
OF. FROM THE TOP AND FINING
COMPLEMENT POLICIES TIME THAT
ISN'T AS GOOD AS FOCUSED ON
OUTCOMES AND UNIVERSALLY
ALTERING OUR COMMUNITY HEALTH
AND WELL BEING WITH A FOCUS ON
CLOSING THE GAPS. WHILE
IMPROVING HEALTH FOR ALL. AND
FOR ON OUTCOMES NOT MEASUREMENTS
OF HOW MANY DID YOU DO. BUT DO
YOU ACTUALLY CHEATED OUT OF THE
INSTANCE OF THIS LEGISLATION THE
INTENT OF THIS POLICY. IT IS
ENERGY BOTH ON OUTCOMES- SHE BY
WHATEVER SERVICES CAN PROVIDE.
THEY'RE ALSO BE REQUIRED TO.
THIS IS A PERMANENT ABOUT
ADDRESS THE NEEDS AND GET OUT OF
THE ROOT CAUSES OF THINGS AND
BACK ALSO- BECAUSE BECAUSE OKAY
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIP
ACROSS SECTORS MANAGEMENT
BUSINESS THE BANK LEADERS TO
HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICE SECTOR
RELATED PROVIDERS. ACROSS THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR COMMUNICATION I
AM LEADERSHIP AND THE
POPULATIONS THAT ARE OFTEN
EXCLUDED FROM DECISIONS THAT
MOST IMPACT OR HEALTH. ISSUES
COLORED YOUTH INTERESTED IN MORE
THAN MEN ARE THIS IS AN
ENGAGEMENT MAY INCLUDE COMMUNITY
GUYS BECAUSE ALREADY CENTER
PRODUCTS ABOUT HIS RIGHT BY YOUR
STAFF THE SENATE WITH THE
COMMUNITY PLAYING A PIVOTAL ROLE
IN THE DECISION MAKING AND
HEARING THE SAME INFORMATION
THAT WE SEE AS WE ARE ENTITIES
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT. WHAT
HAPPENS IF I MEAN WHAT WE DO
WITH. PROGRAMS WE DO THE SERVICE
. WHICH ALSO JUST REYES THE
IMPACT OF WHAT WORKS AND IN
TERMS IS DOWN. WE SHOULD LEARN
BUT ALSO. AND YOUTHAT TO WE
ASSESS AND REFINE THE OUTCOME OF
THE WAR THAT WE'RE. FOR THE CALL
THAT ARE IN PLACE. THERE SHOULD
BE A PROCESS BUILT IN FOR FORMER
IN VALUATION AND WHATEVER WE-
ARE INTACT AND MONITORING
PROGRESS. UNLESS WE GET ON THE
START AND LET'S NOT WAIT IN
THOSE CYCLE AND IT IS NOT RACES
IN THE OF THE YEAR BUT IT SHOULD
BE SOMETHING THAT IS OUT ON A
ROUTINE BASIS FOR ADJUSTMENT
AND- WHAT'S BEING DONE IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE BUILDING
TOWARDS ACHIEVING THE OUTCOME.
OF THE PROGRAM OF. THE POLICY I
WAS BITTEN BY. IT'S AN IMPORTANT
THAT COMING UP A POLICY INSIST
THAT WERE FOR OUR MOST.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THESE THE
POLICY DOESN'T THAT WORK FOR ALL
. BUT WE ALSO ON THE MAP WE WILL
. AND WE WERE GOING TO SEE THE
SERIES CITY. OKAY S. TERM IN. I
WOULD TO BE IN A- IS. FOR OUR
COUNTY STATE. AND IS IMPORTANT
AND- WE SEE PEOPLE OF COLOR WE
NEED HIGH POVERTY I NEED. SONG
CABALLERO INTO. AND SUSTAINABLE
FUND. MORE THAN WHAT WE HAVE SO
FAR. IT REQUIRES A VERSATILE
WORKFORCE AND A LITTLE INVESTED
IN POLICIES THAT OFFER WORKERS.
SPORTS ALL BUSINESSES FOSTER
PARENTS ABILITY. AND SUPPORT
OVERALL WELL BEING MIKE MORRELL
HOUSING ACCESSIBILITY CREWS SAFE
PLACES AROUND REALLY OUTDOORS
OPPORTUNITIES ALSO SUPPORTING.
ACCESS TO ACKNOWLEDGE. LOS IN
THE MEDICINES WORK- IN THE
SATURDAY S. OUR- WE'RE STATE
FIVE AND HAVE TO THEM TO USE
LOCAL- HOWEVER IS NATURE FINDING
A IT DIFFICULT TO FIND IMPLEMENT
A PROGRAM. GO BEYOND GOVERNOR'S
AND RECOVERY AND EVEN FOR SOME-
UNDER ARE NOT RELATED. MILLIONS
OF THE ASK US UP THE LONG TERM.
I THINK CODE. THIS IS IMPORTANT
TO DO TO OUR- WITHOUT A
CONSISTENT- THE SIMPLE ABOUT AND
BONDING. AND ALLOW THIS IS SAME
AND CURRENTLY. AND I HAS STRONG
SUPPORTER EIGHTY THIRTY AND IT'S
A PRETTY OF THE EFFORTS. AGAINST
AND THOSE THERE'S A STANDING
NETWORK SAY OF SAN OUR- PROGRAM
IS WELL BY THE LAW TERM
INVESTMENT FOR LOCAL DEPARTMENTS
COMMUNITY. TO ADDRESS SOCIAL.
THAT ARE ACTUALLY. THE AND
REDUCE THE DISPARITIES. WE ALSO
HAVE A MANIFESTATION AND
MINISTERS A SORT INVESTMENT IN.
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY DOLLARS AN ONGOING
BINDING BEGINNING IN FISCAL YEAR. TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE BUT IT
. ORDINATION OF. ARE NOT
ACTIVITIES ON THE GROUND. MANY
OF US IN A OR NOT ENHANCING.
COMMUNITIES THE DESIGNERS- BY
SYSTEM PEOPLE ON. HER DOOR AND
RAISING THE FOR NO- THIS IS A
LIST. AS WHERE DID PRODUCTS AND
IT CONTRACTED ME. ARE THAT WE
HAVE- MAY- NOT GO ALL THE TIME.
EVEN IF HE ACTIVITIES HI THIS IS
A TO KNOW HAVE YOU FIVE. THINGS
THAT ARE ARE SIMILAR OR COMMON
AND OF THE THINGS WORKING TO.
AND THEY'RE AWARE OF. FORTY
EIGHT IF I UNDERSTAND FOR
STREAMLINED FUNDING A PARTNER
AND OF THE OF THE SIGNS AS
IMPORTANT. MEETING ORGANISER MAY
HAVE JUST- A MOBILE SAY OR
FEDERAL ABOUT IT DOLLAR FOR
SIMILAR- BUT IT WAS- IN TERMS OF
ANY. OH WHO HAVE SEE WHAT'S- THE
PROACTIVE. SENATE REGIONAL
AROUND A CONTRACTOR PARTNERS ON
HOW. SOME OF THE ISSUES WE. OR
FORTY WILL OFTEN AS WELL. MANY
CLOTHING THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR- THE FIRST ORGANIZATIONS
RIGHT NOW THAT WE WERE THAN
ARGUE. I FROM OURSELVES OF ALL
THE TIME EDUCATION ARE. NOT JUST
OF THE PART IN YOUR AND- BUT
EVEN THERE ARE WELL SETTLED THAT. I'M I'VE SEEN BUT POWER
READING IS. A TRANSFORMATION
CHANGE. ARE WE I'M ALWAYS THAT
AND OUT OF FORTY CONVERSATION
EVER AGREED TO GAP- WELL HELD
OFF ON OFTEN MEMBERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY DOCTOR FOR YOUR
PRE. I WAS TRYING TO NOTES AD
WILL OF THE CAN STE- SO- STEM BY
WE WERE WE THIRTY ONE AND I JUST
AS NOT DAVIS'S JUST ARE TO. HIS
PRESENTE I WANT TO THROW IT OUT
THERE- AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
FOR YOU TO PONDER OVER IT NOW
THE GOVERNOR INDICATED THAT WE
HAVE A THIRTY BILLION THIRTY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS. BUDGET SURPLUS
. SO IF. YOU HAD TEN BILLION
DOLLARS WHAT WOULD YOU DO THAT
TEN BILLION DOLLARS TO HOLD THAT
THOUGHT TO WRITE IT DOWN. AND
THEY WERE GOING TO COME BACK TO
YOU SOON OUR NEXT PRESENTER IS
MISS VIRGINIA I HENDRIX I'M WITH
THE SECOND DIRECTOR THE
CALIFORNIA. COMES IN- COMES-
URBAN LEAGUE IN URBAN INDIAN
HEALTH- WHO'S JOINED US ARE YOU
WITH THIS- MS HENDRICKS. I AM
GOOD MORNINGS CLINIC WHERE HE
ALREADY. VERY WELL SO YOU HAVE.
PLEASE WE HAVE SIX MINUTES AND
PLEASE- BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
. THANK YOU SQUARED AWAY
ACKNOWLEDGING HEDRICK SHOWING ON
A LAST. LOOK LAW GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S VIRGINIA HEDRICK I'M A
MEMBER OF THE YUROK TRIBE WAS
WANTING TO BE STRONGER EDUCATION
HUMBOLDT COUNTY. I. READ YOUR
MIND. I WAS VERY ACTUALLY OUT OF
THE HOUSE HE- WITHOUT ALL- AND
ENTRAP OVER AN HOUR AND A HALF
TO THREE CLASSES GET HIS HIGH
SCHOOL IN ONE LANE ROADS AND I'M
YOUNG AND I. YOU ALSO KNOW THAT
IT IS USED OF AB. YOUNG USUALLY
IN HOW AND HOLDING UP IN.
ELECTRICITY AT ALL SIX YEARS
AGO- SO THERE ARE SOME STEPS
FORWARD. I NOW ANY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIANS
WORKING- IMMEDIATE HEALTH AND
EVERYTHING BY CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA'S CAPITAL CITY I'M
ZOOMING IN ARE LACKING IN TODAY
FROM THE TRADITIONAL HOMELANDS
OF ANYTHING ON ANY WHAT PEOPLE.
ON A VISITOR HERE. ORGANISERS
YEAR THEY ARE ALL OF YOUR AND MY
U. S. HOW DO YOU- AS I THE
DRIVING EXPERIENCE OF FROM A
VERY REALLY. AND ALL LIVING IN A
CHILDREN AND- URBAN AND TO I
STILL. ARE IN FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
AND COMES TO ME THROUGH THE
FOSTERS IS AN ACTION. YOU USE
ARE OVER REPRESENTED AND- OFTEN
ALONG. BRANCH AND THIS IS A HAS
. AND AUSTRIAN. YOUR TABLET OR
THAT NEEDED FIVE WE'RE COUNTY
STDS SEVEN MOST IN STATES WOULD
BE TRIBES IT IS COMES PRICES NO
ONE AND CERTAINLY NOT ME THAT
AMERICAN ALASKA NATIVES IN
UNITED STATES AND CERTAINLY IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE YOU
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THIS AND ANY. OF I DON'T KNOW.
THAT HAS ANY CREATED IN. I'M
COMING AFTER WE ARE KNEW AND.
AND YOU KNOW THE OF COLOR WE
ALREADY HAVE A ROD YEAH BOTH
URBAN AND REALLY. WE ARE ALL
WE'RE ALREADY DISPROPORTIONATELY
BY RESPIRATORY DISEASES LIKE
ASTHMA WE ALREADY WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
EDUCATIONAL GOODBYE AMERICAN
INDIAN USED IN CALIFORNIA- ARE
SUSPENDED AT LEAST TWO AND A
HALF TIMES THAT NON HISPANIC
WHITE YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT EDUCATION WE'RE
LOOKING AT EDUCATION SYSTEM THAT
IS TELLING YOU THEY DON'T THEY
DON'T DESERVE TO BE IN THE
CLASSROOM AND SO THEN WHEN THEY
DON'T RETURN TO CLASSROOMS. AND
EXPERIENCE THE HIGHEST RATE
AFTER THE TWO YEARS AND WE GET
ANY SURPRISE. WHEN THEY HAVE
SOME OF THE HIGHEST RATES OF
DROP. OUTS AND LOW EDUCATIONAL.
THE PRIZE I- BE. LUCIEN OF WE
GET IT OUT. DOING BETTER WE ARE
YOU YOU YOUR CALIFORNIA NOT JUST
ON A KNOWLEDGE ADDRESS ON THE
EDGE DISPARITIES AND TERMS OF
HEALTH- YOU KNOW SOMETHING
ORGANIZATION AND OTHER OF OUR.
ORGANIZATIONS PASSED YOU IS WE
HAD A CHANCE HOW INFORMATION IN
REAL AND IN AND WORKING TALK
ABOUT. ABOUT TRANSLATING AND
IT'S PROGRAM SHE SAYS WAY- FOR
CAN. MAY SEEN AS CAL ON HEALTH.
WILL CONVERT WORKING FOR THAT
SAME DEAL BUT BOUNTY ON HER HEAD
TO BE A KILLED ASKING CHEN THAT
FUELS. SAME WAY AND YOU HAVE TO
COME ARE. YEAH ARE ONLY A BIGGER
OUT RIGHT ARCHIE AND IT WAS LONG
ENOUGH- WITH WHAT WE THOUGHT AT
. EARLIER THIS YEAR WE SAW LAST
NIGHT LISTED. BEING RIGHT. AS WE
DIDN'T. WE CALL OUR HE WEARING
MASKS A TIME WASN'T AND IT WILL
ANYTHING HOW WERE ALL WE WASH WE
CAN'T PRETEND THAT WE'RE ALL THE
IN YOUR WHEN YOU THEY WERE ALL
IN IN THE- TOGETHER AND. WE NEED
A SAME STORE BUT WE'RE DIFFERENT
THAT FOR SURE AND SOME OF OUR
WORKING AWAY A FEW. YEAR AGO AND
AS WE THROUGH THIS IT'S NOT A
CITY EXPERIENCE. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE EIGHTY HOW I WAS RED LINING
. SESSION THIS NEED HELP. WAS
THE. ONE COMING OUT OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ADDRESS TO HELP
HER OUT THERE ISN'T A CALL TO
ACTION TO BE HONEST PROGRAM
CITIZENS OF HOUSTON AND IT IS
RED LINE ON THAT. THE MOST
RECENT CALL REQUESTED A FULL
FUNDING TO DATE PROGRAM FOR
LEAST ABOUT A HALF AN RAM. AND
TRIBAL URBAN. THAT'S THERE IS TO
HELP YOUR DELIVERY THAT IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE- TRIES THOSE
ARE COVERED BY A BOARD I MEAN
EVERY YOU KEEP. IN URBAN SETTING
WE NEED. AN IMMEDIATE HEALTHCARE. I'M I ENCOURAGE- YOU KNOW I
AUDITORS ENCOURAGE THAT ARE.
SERVICES DO YOU SEE- MEASURES.
AT SYSTEM WHICH IS. EARLY
ETERNITY ASIAN ASK TO. THE RIGHT
OUR TRAVEL PARTNERS HAVE A
ANCHORS OF OURS LAWMAKERS THE
SAME STRENGTH HOW AFTER. AND
INCLUDE HOLDING ANNIVERSARY FOR
ME CENTER AND WE CAN'T STOP
THEIR WHEN IT COMES TO HEALTH
HAPPENING SURE THAT I THE-
HEATING AND AIR. AND CLIENTS ARE
ACCESS WE CAN'T WHAT I'D
ACCIDENTS HEALTH CARE BY PUTTING
IN MEASURES. NINA WE DON'T
INTERNET YOU'RE ABLE TO CALL IN
ON THEIR SIDE. IT COMES TO YOU
KNOW. HOW. YOU HAVE A UNDERSTOOD
EARLY BETWEEN. WELL MENTAL
HEALTH AND PHYSICAL ANYTHING THE
WEST WORLD YOU HAVE TO SO EACH
WAY ARE ENTIRE STATE ONLINE AND
THERE WAS SMOKE EVERYWHERE WE
WERE IN THE MIDDLE THE- I HOPE
THAT HIGHLIGHTED THAT ALSO
HAPPENS TO. A WE WANT TO TAKE
CARE OF THE PEOPLE USING BE SEEN
AS- AND WE COME UP ON A SIX AND
A IS ALL ON THE SAME LOOKING FOR
TO CONTINUED SUPPORT CAN YOU
TELL CENTERS. OR AND YET SYSTEM
AND ALL OF THE SO DETERMINANTS
WHICH AFTER INCLUDE BRING YOU
CAN'T THE TIME TO WITHOUT
TALKING TO RACE- POLICY AND
POWER AND HOW EMAIL. YOU SO MUCH
- OF VIRGINIA- HENDRIX FOR YOUR
- AND THANK YOU MUCH OF THE PART
OF THIS PANEL. THE IT'S
ABSOLUTELY. THAT WE MAKE THAT IN
WE THESE CAN. WE HAVE INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE I WAS VERY. THOSE
REPRESENTING INDIAN TRIBES TO
BEING PART OF THAT CONVERSATION
BECAUSE WE LOOK AT THE PEOPLE
BEING DISENFRANCHISED CERTAINLY-
THEY ARE IN THAT SAME CATEGORY
SO THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR
AVAILING YOURSELF. I WANT TO GO
NOW TO MISSOURI AND A PREVIOUS
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENTAL AND
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR THE
COMMUNITY CLINIC ASSOCIATION OF
LOS AGELES COUNTY THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH FOR BEING WITH US HE'S
WITH US- PHYSICALLY AND PRECIADO
YOUR TIME. WITH US AND LOOK
FORWARD TO- YOUR PRESENTATION SO
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU SO
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND- THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY I'M
REALLY HAPPY TO BE HERE IN SUCH
ESTEEMED COMPANY INCLUDING A
COUPLE OF OUR MEMBER COMMUNITY
CLINICS AND HEALTH CENTERS HERE
ON THE PANEL WITH ME- SO AGAIN
MY NAME IS TO INCREASE I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AND
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS. AT THE
COMMUNITY CLINIC ASSOCIATION OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. WE ARE A
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION WE
REPRESENT SIXTY FOUR NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY CLINIC AND HEALTH
CENTER ORGANIZATIONS. OPERATE
OVER THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SITES ALL ACROSS L. A. COUNTY SO
LANCASTER DOWN THE LONG BEACH
WAY OUT EAST YOU NAME IT-
SERVING OVER ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION PATIENTS HERE IN L. A.
COUNTY ANNUALLY- AND THAT'S AT
LAST COUNT. SEE WHAT THE DATA
SHOWS NEXT TIME AROUND- SO I WAS
YOU KNOW ASKED TO SPEAK TO SOME
OF THE MAIN HEALTH DISPARITIES-
ISSUES CAUSING YOU KNOW HEALTH
INEQUITIES AND DISPARITIES AND
IN A CLINIC SETTING AND I THINK
YOU KNOW THE FOUR. PANELISTS
TODAY HAVE REALLY TOUCHED ON.
PRETTY MUCH YOU KNOW THE LAUNDRY
LIST OF THINGS WE'RE SEEING IN
THE CLINIC SETTING RIGHT I MEAN-WE ALL KNOW THESE THINGS ARE
IMPACTING OUR PATIENTS. FROM
POVERTY TO RACISM EDUCATION
WE'VE GOT JOB INSECURITY LACK OF
JOB STABILITY- AND ADEQUATE
WAGES. FOOD AND SECURITY I MEAN
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON RIGHT ON
HOUSING IS A BIG ONE- LACK OF
HOUSING OVERCROWDED HOUSING-
TRANSPORTATION CHALLENGES AND
THEN I WAS MENTIONED EARLIER ON
WHAT WE SAW REALLY DRIVEN HOME
BY THE PANDEMIC DIGITAL
INEQUITY. TURNS OUT TO HAVE BEEN
A FAR BIGGER ISSUE PERHAPS THAN
WE THOUGHT IT WAS. I'M IN THE
HEALTHCARE SECTOR PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC- ALSO MENTIONED EARLIER
TODAY I THINK ENVIRONMENTAL
FACTORS WEIGHING IN AND
IMPACTING PATIENTS OR BY CLINICS
ACROSS L. A. COUNTY- YOU KNOW
WE'VE GOT. POLLUTION WE'VE GOT
DRILLING WE'VE GOTTEN. THAT WILL
SCHOOLS REALLY AREN'T ORANGE
COUNTY WE'VE GOT DRILLING WE'VE
GOT PORTS AND FREEWAYS WE'VE GOT
YOU KNOW IMPACTING KIDS AND
ASTHMA- SO YOU NAME IT THE
CLINICS SEE IT AS FAR AS- SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
INEQUITIES- FEW OF USER DATA
JUST TO SHARE WITH YOU JUST TO
PAINT A PICTURE OF WHO CLINICS.
ARE AND WHO THEY SERVE IN L. A.
COUNTY- 92% OF CLINIC PATIENTS
AND CALIFORNIA HEALTH CENTERS
ARE NON WHITE SO I. HI TO DIG
FOR THAT DATE OF HERE FOR L. A.
COUNTY COULDN'T UNDER THAT BUT
92% AND CALIFORNIA. ARE NON
WHITE AND THAT IS THE PATIENTS
CLINICS ARE SERVING. IN L. A.
COUNTY JUST PAINTING A PICTURE
OF THE POVERTY LEVEL IN THE
REALITY OF OUR PATIENTS ECONOMIC
SITUATIONS. 77% OF CLINIC
PATIENTS. HOUSEHOLD INCOME UNDER
2100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL- 90% OF THE PATIENTS
SERVED BY CLINICS IN L. A.
COUNTY ARE EITHER UNINSURED. OR
ON MEDICAID. AND CLINICS IN L.
A. COUNTY AT LAST COUNT SERVING
ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
PATIENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS EACH YEAR- SO THE
NUMBERS REALLY SPEAK TO WHO THE
CLINICS ARE AND WHO THEY'RE
SERVING- AND THE IMPACT OF
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS ON. ON THE
HEALTH OF PATIENTS IN THE LIFE
EXPERIENCE OF PATIENTS I THINK.
GOES ON SAID TO THIS AUDIENCE-
HOPE IT REALLY DROVE HOME THE
INEQUITIES ARE COMMUNITIES WERE
FACING I THINK IT BECAME READILY
APPARENT VERY EARLY ON IN THE
PANDEMIC- JUST WHAT THE
SITUATION WAS. AND I WILL SHARE
THE STORY THAT THAT WE FACED
EARLY ON YOU KNOW. AND IT IT
REPEATED ITSELF A COUPLE TIMES
BUT WE ARE IN A BETTER SITUATION
NOW AND THAT WAS WHEN YOU KNOW
THE CODE FIRST HIT AND WE WERE
TRYING TO GET TESTING SUPPLIES
INTO CALL THE CLINIC SETTING-
AND STARTED BECOME APPARENT
WHICH COMMUNITIES WERE THE
HARDEST HIT BY. COVERT NINETEEN
. HAVING TO FIGHT FOR THAT I'M
REALLY HAVING TO SAY HEY YOU
LIKE. CLINICS ARE IN THESE
COMMUNITIES THESE ARE PATIENTS
THAT ARE BEING THE HARDEST HIT
AND- HOW CAN WE GET THE TESTING
SUPPLIES THE FLOW TO CLINICS
LIKE HOW CAN WE ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE THIS CAPABILITY IN THE
CLINIC SETTING. SIMILAR PLAYED
OUT AGAIN WHEN VACCINES BECOME
AVAILABLE AND WE WERE HAVING SAY
. THE CLINICS NEED VACCINES WE
NEED TO DISTRIBUTE VACCINES TO
THE HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES- I'M
REALLY HAVING TO PUSH HARD TO
GET THAT TO HAPPEN- BUT I'M HARD
TO SAY THAT WE'RE IN A MUCH
BETTER SITUATION- OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH L. A. COUNTY
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH WE ARE
FORTUNATE COUNTY I THINK TO THE
REMARKS MADE EARLIER THAT. NOT
EVERY COUNTY WORKS REALLY
CLOSELY WITH THEIR CEOS AND WITH
THE CLINICS AND THEIR LOVE
JURISDICTION. HERE IN L. A.
COUNTY OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
PH IS PRETTY STRONG THESE DAYS-
I KNOW THEY PARTNER VERY CLOSELY
WITH A LOT OF THE CLINICS ARE
DOING THE WORK ON THE GROUND
WITH A GUARD TO VACCINATION.
THEY THEY COME KNOCKING WE SEE
EMAILS FLUTTER IN BOX YOU DON'T
WHEN BOOSTERS ARE APPROVED IT'S
OKAY HOW CAN WE GET CLINICS
INVOLVED HOW CAN WE ENGAGE THE
CLINICS IN THIS WORK. THE LATEST
CONVERSATIONS AROUND CODE
THERAPEUTICAL AND THEY REALLY DO
RECOGNIZE. HOW DO WE GET THIS
INTO THE HANDS OF CLINICS HOW DO
WE GET THIS AVAILABLE TO CLINICS
TO DISTRIBUTE TO THEIR PATIENTS
. I'M JUST REALLY APPRECIATING
THAT RECOGNITION THAT THE
CLINICS ARE. IN THE VERY
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN THE
HARDEST HIT I MEAN. PHYSICALLY
THINKING ABOUT HEALTH IMPACTS
BUT ALSO ECONOMICALLY BY THE
PANDEMIC- WE ONCE TOOK A MAP
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU MAY HAVE
SEEN IT- WE DID SHARE A PRETTY
WIDELY LAST YEAR. EARLY ON MORE
WE LAYERED. THE HARDEST HIT
COMMUNITIES LIKE OVER NINETEEN
ON TOP OF A MAP OF WHERE
COMMUNITY CLINICS AND HEALTH
CENTERS ARE LOCATED IN L. A.
COUNTY. AND THAT MAPS ALMOST
IDENTICALLY I'M JUST REALLY
SPEAKING TO WE ARE IN THESE
COMMUNITIES THIS IS WHERE
CLINICS ARE. I'M THINKING ABOUT
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH-
VERY GRATEFUL TO SEE THE
MATERIALS FOR THIS HEARING JUST
THAT RECOGNITION THAT WE CAN'T
DO IT WITHOUT RESOURCES AND I
THINK THAT'S BEEN SPOKEN TO BY A
LOT OF THE PREVIOUS PANELISTS-
JUST HOW ESSENTIAL THAT. IS WE
DO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT
TEN THIRTY EIGHT AM WHICH WOULD
HAVE. A GROUP GRANTS TO ENTITIES
LIKE COMMUNITY CLINICS- VERY
POSITIVE AND THE FUND THAT
YOU'RE REFERENCING EARLIER AGAIN
VERY POSITIVE STEPS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION- PROBABLY. YOU KNOW
SOMETHING I WANTED TO FLAG IS
JUST HOW WIDELY VARIED CLINICS
ARE- YOU SEE TWO OF THEM HERE
TODAY AND THEY SERVE DIFFERENT
PATIENTS HAVE DIFFERENT FOCUSES
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS THEY WORK
WITH- CLINICS PROVIDE A WIDE
VARIETY OF SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
TO HELP MITIGATE TO HELP.
ADDRESS SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH. WHETHER YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT. FOOD PANTRIES IN ROMAN
INTO CALFRESH- HOUSING
NAVIGATION. THERE'S A LONG LONG
LAUNDRY LIST YOU'RE YOU'RE
PROBABLY FAMILIAR WITH THE SOUTH
LA CLINIC THAT HAS A PROGRAM TO
HELP PATIENTS ADDRESS HOUSING
ISSUES PROVIDING LEGAL SUPPORT-
WE'VE GOT A PATIENT A CLINIC ON
SKID ROW TAT'S HELPING PATIENTS
WITH MEDICATIONS STORAGE JUST
THE LITTLE THINGS TO TRY TO
HELP. PATIENTS ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE LARGER THINGS IN THEIR
LIFE THAT ARE IMPACTING THEIR
HEALTH- I FLAG THAT ISN'T
THINKING ABOUT SOLUTIONS OF
COURSE WE MENTIONED RESOURCES
BUT I WILL FLAG FLEXIBILITY AND
RESOURCES- THAT NEED FOR CLINICS
TO BE ABLE TO. TO DO WHAT THEY
DO BEST TO DO WHAT WILL MEET THE
NEEDS OF THEIR PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES AND THE PATIENTS
THEY SERVE- THAT IT'S NOT ONE
SIZE FITS ALL WHEN IT COMES TO
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES- I DO THINK THAT THE
FLAG WORTH MAKING. CLINICS ARE
TAKING SOME STEPS IN THIS
DIRECTION ALREADY WERE. WORKING
WITH DHS TO ADJUST THE WAY
CLINICS ARE PAID- WHICH WILL
PROVIDE GREATER FLEXIBILITY AND
ALLOW CLINICS TO USE DIFFERENT
PROVIDERS PROVIDE. ADDITIONAL
WRAPAROUND TYPE SERVICES- SO
THAT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. BUT MAINTAINING
TELEHEALTH IS ANOTHER IMPORTANT
FLAG ON SO MAINTAINING THE
ABILITY OF CLINICS- MAINTAIN THE
ABILITY OF MEDI CAL PATIENTS TO
CONTINUE UTILIZING TELEHEALTH
ACCESS CARE- SO MANY POTENTIAL
BARRIERS THAT THAT CAN OVERCOME
WHICH WE SAW DURING THE WHOLE OF
IT. YOU KNOW NOT NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF IT IN THE NEED TO YOU
KNOW SOCIAL DISTANCE OR STAY
HOME. BUT ALSO TIME OFF WORK
CHILD CARE TRANSPORTATION RIGHT
TELEHEALTH HAS SO MUCH PROMISE
FOR OUR BEING ABLE TO EXPAND
ACCESS IN THE FUTURE. AND WHEN I
MENTIONED TELEHEALTH- WE MENTION
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE- AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF RETAINING AUDIO
VISITS. AND WE CAN'T JUST DO
TELEHEALTH AND ASSUME THAT
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO YOU KNOW
STREAM FIVE G. AND VIDEO VISITS-
THE REALITY IS IT'S NOT POSSIBLE
YET FOR MANY OF OUR PATIENTS-
AND SO MAINTAINING THAT
CONNECTION VIA AUDIO AS WELL AS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT- TWO. TWO
THINGS THE FLAG ONE WHICH DR
YOUNG REFERENCE SOME AND ALLUDED
TO IS THE BIGGEST CRISIS
POTENTIALLY FACING CLINICS RIGHT
NOW IS WORKFORCE- I CAN I THINK
I CAN SAFELY SAY EVERY SINGLE
CLINIC ON OUR MEMBERSHIP. HAS
MULTIPLE POSITIONS OPEN THAT
THEY ARE STRUGGLING TO FILL-
THIS WAS A CRISIS PRIOR TO COPE
WITH IT AND IT'S JUST BEEN
EXACERBATED BY COVE IN. EXISTING
WORK FORCES OVER BURDENED
OVERWORKED STRESSED OUT- WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH WE DON'T HAVE
PHYSICIANS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS WE DON'T HAVE ALLIED
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS YOU KNOW
THE- SOCIAL WORKERS. CALL
CENTERS FRONT DESK WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH STAFF. AND THAT WILL
HAMPER OUR ABILITY TO DO
ANYTHING ABOVE AND BEYOND- SO I
FLAG THIS BECAUSE I AM A BIT
DISSIPATING THAT WILL BE LOOKING
TO LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR. TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT WITH REGARD TO
HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE IN A
PARTICULAR PRIMARY CARE WORK
FORCE- AND SO THAT'S YOU KNOW
LONGER PAYMENT OF THINGS THAT
WERE MENTIONED- IT'S ALSO.
PROGRAMS AND SUPPORTS TO MAKE
SURE DEVELOPING THE WORK FORCE
THAT LOOKS LIKE AND FEELS LIKE
OUR PATIENTS I THINK THAT. YOU
KNOW CARLOS TORRES OF REMARKS
HERE- WE NEED A WORKFORCE THAT
OUR PATIENTS ARE COMFORTABLE
WORKING WITH RIGHT WE WANT
PEOPLE TO WALK WALK INTO A
CLINIC AND FEEL LIKE. THEY'RE AT
A PLACE WHERE THEY CAN BE SERVED
IN THAT THEY CAN BE APPRECIATED
AND TREATED APPROPRIATELY- AND
THAT'S A TOUGH NUT TO CRACK-
WHICH STRUGGLING JUST WITH
PROVIDERS IN GENERAL- AND SO
REALLY GROWING THAT WORK FORCE-
AT ALL LEVELS- IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES WE FACE RIGHT
NOW. AND IT FEELS REALLY HARD TO
IMAGINE DOING. MORE YOU DON'T
RESOURCES FOR SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS ARE GREAT BUT IF WE
DON'T HAVE THE WORK FORCE TO PUT
BEHIND IT WILL BE
EXTRAORDINARILY CHALLENGE SO I
THINK THAT'S- ONE TO MENTION.
AND I'VE LOST TRACK OF MY TIME
BUT IF I MIGHT MENTION ONE LAST
THING- SPEAKING TO FLEXIBILITY
AND RESOURCES AND HOW CRITICAL
THAT IS. CLINICS MANY CLINICS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE LOOKING AT THE
IMPENDING LOSS OF ONE OF THE
MORE FLEXIBLE FUNDING STREAMS
THEY HAVE. AND THAT'S THE
RESOURCES ASSOCIATED THAT THEY
GET UNDER THE THREE FORTY DRUG
DISCOUNT PROGRAM. AND THE
STATE'S CHANGING WELL
INTENTIONED THE PHARMACY BENEFIT
MEDIC HELL BUT LONG STORY SHORT.
IT WILL ELIMINATE THE SAVINGS
THAT CLINICS ARE ABLE TO REALIZE
FROM THAT PROGRAM AND WE'RE
TALKING TO THE TUNES OF TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS I'M FOR A
LOT OF ORGANIZATIONS. AND THOSE
ARE REALLY FLEXIBLE RESOURCES
THEY'RE RESOURCES THE SUPPORT
SOME OF THOSE WRAPAROUND
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT
REALLY HELP CLINICS GEAR THEIR
SERVICES TO THE SPECIFIC NEEDS
OF THEIR PATIENTS AND WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT. COOKING
CLASSES OR GROUP CLASSES- ALL
THOSE ABOVE AND BEYOND AN EXTRA
SERVICES. NEED THOSE KIND OF
FLEXIBLE RESOURCES. AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT THAT DRYING UP
SIGNIFICANTLY AFTER JANUARY ONE
SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER I CAN'T THANK
YOU ENOUGH YOU CHAMPION THIS FOR
US IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET CYCLE- WE ARE GOING TO BE
BACK IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
REALLY LOOKING AND HOPING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WILL AUGMENT THE
FUNDING POOL THAT WAS PUT IN
PLACE TO OFFSET THAT LOSS- SO WE
ARE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
EXISTING FUNDING. BUT CONCERNED
THAT IT'S NOT SUFFICIENT FOR
CLINICS TO CONTINUE DOING GOOD
WORK THEY'RE DOING. THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND I'VE TAKEN
SOME POINTS OUT. CERTAINLY BRING
OUT- WITH RESPECT TO. HOW DO WE
ENSURE CLINICS ARE NOT LEFT
BEHIND IF IN FACT THAT THE
PANDEMIC. WESTING HERE SO THAT'S
WHAT YOU PONDER OVER THAT WILL
COME BACK DURING THE QUESTION
PERIOD- NEXT I WANT TO BRING UP-
OUR FINAL PANELIST AND- SOMEONE
WHO HAS A- I HAVE A PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH AS DR JERRY
ABRAHAM THE DIRECTOR OF
CATHERINE'S VACCINE. AND
DIVISIONS OF KATHRYN'S-
COMMUNITY. HEALTH CLINIC WHO HAS
BEEN ON THE FRONT LINE DONE
YEOMAN'S WORK WAS PARTNER WITH
US AS WE WENT DOOR TO DOOR
KNOCKING ON PEOPLE'S DOORS AND
WHAT'S AND ALSO WOMAN TEN- HE'S
BEEN RIGHT THERE- SO DOCTOR
ABRAHAM THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
FOR AVAILING YOURSELF WITH THIS
TODAY- TAKE A COUPLE MINUTES
INTO JUST SELF AND THEN. MOVE
RANGE OF PRESENTATIONS. GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE WITH YOU
ALL TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE
GIPSON ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS. ESPECIALLY TO SOME MEMBER
GAPS AND IT REALLY MEANS THE
WORLD NOT. ONLY TO US TO DO THIS
DAILY. FOR A LIVING BUT TO THE
PATIENTS AND THE LIVES THAT ARE
CHANGED IN TRULY SAVED BECAUSE
OF THE- VACCINE ROLLOUT BECAUSE
OF INCREASING ACCESS TO CARE SO.
REALLY APPLAUD YOU AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH I KNOW THAT WE STILL
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO AND WATCH
IN WILMINGTON AND OTHER PARTS
OF. ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTY FOUR
WE'VE COME A LONG WAY BECAUSE
OF. YOUR INTENTIONAL WORK TO
HELP OUR COMMUNITY HAVE ACCESS
ESPECIALLY TO THESE LIFESAVING
ESSENTIAL MEDICINES. AND MY NAME
IS DR JERRY ABRAHAM I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF KATRIN VACCINES IN
SOUTH LOS ANGELES. I'M A
COMMUNITY AND FAMILY MEDICINE
PHYSICIAN EPIDEMIOLOGIST AND A
MEDICAL QUALITY SPECIALISTS
PRACTICING IN SOUTH LA-
CATHERINE IS AN ACUTE
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL AND
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTER A MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY
CLINIC ASSOCIATION. AND WE WERE
STARTED IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
BY TWENTY TWO BLACK PSYCHIATRY'S
PSYCHIATRIST BACK. DURING THE
WATTS RIOTS- WHEN BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE HAVE NOWHERE TO GO
FOR MENTAL HEALTH ACCESS AND WE
WERE IN A RISIS AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHERE WE FOUND OURSELVES
AGAIN. IN TWENTY TWENTY WHEN THE
PANDEMIC HEAD. WE NEED. MARCH
TWENTY TWO. ONE THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY IN THE PANDEMIC WERE
DECLARED THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO.
AS WE ALWAYS HAVE AS INGRAINED
IN OUR DNA TO BE A PART OF THE
SOLUTION THAT WE WERE GOING TO
BE THAT LIGHT ON HEALTH. THAT
BEACON FOR HEALTH EQUITY THAT WE
WEREN'T GOING TO SIT ON THE
SIDELINES BUT RATHER WE TRULY
WERE GOING TO BE. ON THAT DESERT
ISLAND WRITING SOS AND THE SAND
JUMPING UP AND DOWN AND WAVING
OUR HANDS AND SAYING DON'T
FORGET ABOUT US PLEASE. GIVE US
WHAT IS OURS WE WILL COME AND
TAKE IT PROUDLY. AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE DID ON CHRISTMAS
EVE EVE- DURING A WHEN THE
VACCINES I TO. RECEIVE THE
MERCIES AUTHORIZATION- FIZER
BACK IN DECEMBER- KNOWING
CONTACTED CATHERINE OUR PATIENTS
OUR STAFF HAD COVERT OUR
COMMUNITY. IN NINE ZERO ZERO ONE
ONE SOME OF THE HARDEST HIT ZIP
CODES WHERE ONE OUT OF FOUR
PEOPLE WERE SUFFERING FROM COLD
AND MANY WERE DYING FROM COVE
IT. AS YOU SAW THE STATS THAT
WERE ALREADY PRESENTED. HOW
COULD YOU FORGET ABOUT US SO I
PICKED UP THE PHONE ON CHRISTMAS
EVE AND I DEMANDED WHERE ARE OUR
VACCINES AND- YOU KNOW AS
ALREADY MENTIONED THANK GOD THAT
WE HAVE THIS WONDERFUL
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH WHO
IS OUR SISTER. PARTNER
ORGANIZATION AND IN THIS
BEAUTIFUL FASHION OF PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS WE WERE
ABLE TO FIGURE OUT WHERE WHAT
HAPPENED. AND HOW DO WE GET
ACCESS TO THOSE VACCINES AND BY
NEW YEAR'S EVE EVE WE HAD
RECEIVED OUR FIRST SIXTY DOSES.
AND THEN THE NEXT DAY WE PUT
HUNDRED DOSES INTO THE ARMS OF
OUR NURSES AND PATIENTS. AND
THEN ONE FIFTY TO NOW OVER FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND VACCINES INTO
THE ARMS OF. SOUTH ANGELENOS AND
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES. IN ADDITION TO THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN TESTED. AND AGAIN
THANKS TO ALL OF THE RESOURCES
PROVIDED BY THE COUNTY EMERGENCY
SERVICES. THE COMMUNITY CLINIC
ASSOCIATION BECAUSE WE COULDN'T
DO ANY OF THE SALON. THANK YOU
KNOW WE'RE JUST SO THANKFUL FOR.
THE ACCESS TO THESE LIFESAVING
ESSENTIAL MEDICINES THAT OUR
COUNTRY TOOK ACTION WE BROUGHT
TOGETHER IN THIS. PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP. FASHION TO BRING TO
SCALE AND TO. REALLY DISTRIBUTE
THESE VACCINES BUT AS I TELL THE
MANUFACTURERS FAIZABAD DHARNA
AND JOHNSON AND JOHNSON. THEIR
VACCINES ARE ABSOLUTELY AND
UTTERLY USELESS IF THEY DON'T
GET INTO THE ARMS OF THE PEOPLE
THAT NEED IT THE MOST AND
SOMETHING THAT WE WERE VERY
INTENTIONAL ABOUT. I SAID ON
THAT COUNTIES- COMMITTEE FOR.
THE EQUITABLE VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION AND WE WERE VERY
INTENTIONAL WE WERE GOING TO
MAKE THE SAME MISTAKES THAT WERE
MADE IN SHOULD. AGO IN DC THE
VACCINE LANDED IN THE EXACT
OPPOSITE ZIP CODES. OF WHERE
THAT ACTUAL INFECTION WAS AND
WHERE PEOPLE WERE ACTUALLY DYING
FROM COVE IN NINETEEN SO. WE
REALLY RACED AGAINST TIME TO GET
THESE VACCINES INTO. PEOPLE'S
ARMS BUT WE WERE MATT MOMENT
AFTER MOMENT WITH BARRIER AFTER
BARRIER- YOU KNOW WHAT
APPOINTMENT HOW WERE OUR
PATIENTS SUPPOSED TO GET AN
APPOINTMENT THAT CLUNKY. YOU
KNOW. IN THE BEGINNING WAS PROP
MODERN MY TURN. THESE WERE NOT
EASY ESPECIALLY FOR PEOPLE
SENIORS THOSE THAT ARE AGING
THOSE WITH. UNDERLYING MEDICAL
CONDITIONS DEVELOPMENTAL
CHALLENGES MANY BORE SHOT OUT NO
INTERNET NO EMAIL NO CELL PHONE.
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE AN ADDRESS
BECAUSE THEY ARE HOUSING IN
SECURING IT THAT WAS A REQUIRED
FIELD IN THE EARLY DAYS TO GET
AN APPOINTMENT. WE THOUGHT
PEOPLE TO HAVE TRANSPORTATION
AND THAT WAS THE ONLY WAY TO GET
TO DODGER STADIUM WHERE WE
SUPPOSED TO GO FOR YOUR VACCINES
IN THOSE EARLIEST DAYS. I DIDN'T
SPEAK ENGLISH WHERE MY SUPPOSED
TO GO WE MADE SURE THAT THAT WAS
NOT A BARRIER LIMITATION TO
GETTING ACCESS TO VACCINES. IN
OUR COUNTY WE MADE SURE THAT IF
YOU COULDN'T SEE WALK TALK
SOMEONE WOULD HOLD YOUR HAND AND
GET YOU THROUGH AND GET YOU
VACCINATED. AND BECAUSE OF ALL
THE STRATEGIES WE HAVE THE
VACCINE RATES THAT WE HAVE. AND
MANY LIVES HAVE BEEN SAVED
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY FOR SURE.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
SAVED BECAUSE OF THESE VACCINES
BUT THE LESSON HERE. IS THAT WE
WERE NOT AT THE TABLE WHEN THOSE
VACCINE. WHEN THE DISTRIBUTION-
ALLOCATIONS WERE MADE THEY WENT
TO WONDERFUL PLACES AND WE
APPLAUD THEM. USC UCLA
CEDARHURST DIGNITY HEALTH KAISER
PERMANENTE. BUT IT'S REALLY THE
ROOTS IN THE GROUND IT'S REALLY
THAT NETWORK IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT. IS READY TO RESPOND AND
WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN HERE BUT AGAIN
WE SOMEHOW GET. LEFT BEHIND WHEN
THESE DECISIONS ARE MADE WHEN
THOSE DISCUSSIONS ARE BEING HAD.
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE LEFT BEHIND IF WE ARE WE
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THAT IS.
SOMETHING THAT- IS VIEWED AS- WE
THINK ABOUT IF THIS TYPE OF
ATROCITY OCCURS AGAIN IT'S
NOTHING SHORT OF CRIMINAL TO BE
HONEST I MEAN FOR THE MASCOT.
ALL RIGHT- SO I ALSO WANTED TO
SAY AND THE EARLIEST DAY AS WITH
HER. RIDICULOUS THAT THERE WAS
BLACK AND BROWN VACCINE
HESITANCY FORTY TO SIXTY
PERCENT. INSTEAD WHAT WE SAW IN
OUR COMMUNITY WAS. WHAT VACCINE
I'VE NEVER BEEN OFFERED A
VACCINE HOWEVER HOW MAY BEING
DOCUMENTED AS SOMEONE WHO. IS
RELUCTANT HESITANT REFUSING A
VACCINE WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE
TO TURN TO GET VACCINES IN OUR
COMMUNITY- IN ADDITION TO THOSE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACED IN
GETTING THESE VACCINES OUT. WE
KNEW THAT- YOU KNOW WHAT
CATHERINE WE PRACTICE THIS THING
CALLED THE CADRE WE HAVE MANY
MANTRAS AND- ONE IS THAT THE
EXPERIENCE COUNTS WE TREAT
PEOPLE LIKE PEOPLE. WE RESPECT
THE DIGNITY AND WORTH OF EVERY
HUMAN BEING. AND WE MEET PEOPLE
WHERE THEY ARE VERY INTENSELY WE
ENGAGE YOU EDUCATEYOU VACCINATE
AND ACTIVATE YOU. WHETHER YOU'RE
WHITE BLACK BROWN YELLOW WHOEVER
YOU ARE YOU HAD EVERY REASON TO
HAVE. THESE CONCERNS QUESTIONS
AND IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY IS
OUR TRUSTED HEALTH PARTNER TO
TAKE THE TIME TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS TO BE HONEST. TO
EDUCATE YOU AND REALLY THAT'S
HOW WE WOULD OVERCOME MANY OF
THE LOWER VACCINATION RATES
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY. THIS IS
NOT A EXPERIMENT ON OUR
COMMUNITY THIS ISN'T THE
TUSKEGEE TRIALS THE ABUSE OF
HENRIETTA LACKS CELLS. THIS IS
NOT THE UNDER TREATMENT OF BLACK
PAIN IN OUR HOSPITALS THESE ARE
LIFESAVING ESSENTIAL MEDICINES
AND UNFORTUNATELY DIGITAL
DEMANDS. HAVE SPREAD LIES THAT
ARE ADVERSELY IMPACTING TRULY
KILLING OUR COMMUNITY AND THAT-
THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
STRUCTURAL ISSUES THAT WE MUST.
CONTINUE TO SQUASH AS I WRAP UP
MY COMMENTS I JUST WANT TO SAY
WE'VE LEARNED A LOT OF LESSONS.
THIS IS NOT JUST A PANDEMIC OF
AN INFECTIOUS ILLNESS THIS IS A
SOCIAL ILLNESS AN ILLNESS OF
ISOLATION OF DEPRESSION ANXIETY.
THIS IS A PANDEMIC OF MISSED
CARE MISSED OPPORTUNITIES. TO
PREVENT TO MAINTAIN OUR HEALTH
WE MUST GET BACK TO THAT. AND
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IS THAT WE
CAN DEMOCRATIZE HEALTH THAT WE
CAN MOVE AWAY FROM THE
TRADITIONAL FOUR WALLS O OUR
CLINICS AND HOSPITALS. THAT WE
CAN AND TO THE EPIDEMICS HIV THE
HEPATITIS PANDEMICS THE STI
EPIDEMICS THAT ARE ALL AROUND
US. AND WE DO ADVICE
DECENTRALIZING EQUITY LET'S TAKE
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED WITH THESE
MOBILE VACCINATION EFFORTS THIS
EQUITABLE VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
MODEL. AND LET'S TACKLE THOSE
BIG CHALLENGES THAT ARE FACING
OUR PATIENTS IN SOUTH LOS
ANGELES AND ACROSS THE STATE.
LET'S REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE LET'S
ADDRESS INCONSISTENT POLICING
LET US IMPROVE MATERNAL AND
CHILD MORTAITY IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY. LET US ADDRESS GLOBAL
CLIMATE CRISIS HAD ON LET US
CONTINUE TO TACKLE THE HOUSING
SECURITY THAT IS ADVERSELY. MY
PATIENTS AT MY CLINIC BUT WHEN
WE ALL COME TOGETHER IT MAY NOT
BE A DOCTOR OR NURSE WHO SOLVES
IT MAY BE YOUR TEACHER MAY BE
YOUR CULTURE MAY BE OUR PASTOR.
YOUR COMMUNITY LEADER YOUR
POLITICIAN YOU'RE A BALLOT YOUR
T. ARE YOUR NEIGHBORS BUT WHEN
WE ALL COME TOGETHER WILL ALL
ACHIEVE THIS HEALTH EQUITY THAT
WE SAW- YEARN FOR AND DESERVE
EVERY PERSON OUR COMMUNITY DOES.
OKAY WITH THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY DR ABRAHAM
IT IS GREATER YOU GAVE A GREAT
SUMMERS ASIAN OF EVERYTHING
KERRY HERSELF. THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. AS WELL AS YOUR
PRESENTATION AND YOUR COMMITMENT
TO OUR COMMUNITY AS ALL OF YOU
ARE COMMITTED TO OUR COMMUNITY.
THAT THIS POINT IN TIME WE WANT
TO- I'M ASKING QUESTIONS- WE
WANT YOU TO PONDER OF THOSE OF
THOSE QUESTIONS BUT MY I'M GOING
TO- DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE- SILVA
RIVAS TO ASK THE FIRST QUESTION.
AND THEN I'LL WILL BE JUST DO AN
INTERCHANGING A DIALOGUE
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE TIME THAT
WE HAVE. I'M TOGETHER SO. MEMBER
RIVAS LAW. ALL- AND ALSO I'M
SORRY WE ALSO HAVE INDIVIDUALS
THE STILL- VIRTUALLY WITH US AS
WELL SEE WHEN CALLING THEM AS
WELL YES I APPRECIATED THOSE
COMMENTS AND THE PANEL AND IT
WAS. YOU KNOW- AT- EDUCATIONAL
LEARN ABOUT WHAT WAS EXPERIENCE
HERE ON THE GROUND CERTAINLY
WHEN IT KIND. THE ONLY COMES TO
THE VACCINE. THE DISTRIBUTION.
PROCESS THAT WE EXPERIENCED AND
YOU KNOW AND CENTRAL BECAUSE
WORKING WITH AGRICULTURAL
FARMWORKERS. VERY CHALLENGING SO
MANY CULTURAL BARRIERS THAT WE
HAD TO- YOU KNOW. BREAK DOWN-
YOU KNOW IT'S SO WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT. YOU KNOW. WHAT WE'VE
HEARD TODAY IN A RESOURCE.
DESERT'S RESOURCE. CONSTRAINTS
AND REALLY THE ALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES. THROUGH THIS EQUITY
LANDS. IS THIS IS BEST DONE BY
LEVERAGING OUR LOCAL AND
REGIONAL PARTNERSHIPS AS HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED. AND IF SO- YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE WAYS IN WHICH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA COULD
SUPPORT OUR LOCAL CBO'S
NONPROFITS THE WORK YOU GUYS DO
. BEYOND JUST INSURING THAT YOU
HAVE RESOURCES AND YOU KNOW THE
WAY OF MONEY AND- THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES IS THERE SOMETHING
ELSE WE SHOULD BE LOOKING- WHEN
IT COMES TO THIS AREA OF SUPPORT. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A QUESTION
SURE I CAN TAKE A STAB FIRST- NO
PUN INTENDEDI DO VACCINATE ALL
DAY. SO I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS
DECENTRALIZATION AND
DEMOCRATIZATION ARE CRITICAL.
CONCEPTS THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO IMPLEMENT WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO GO TO
QUATERNARY. ACADEMIC MEDICAL
MECCA AS AND OUR PATIENTS CAN'T
GET THEIR THEIR SHUT OUT BUT
THEY MAY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THE SERVICES IN THEIR
PUBLIC HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IN
THEIR SCHOOLS IN THEIR CHURCHES
IN THEIR PARKS AND RACKS I
REALLY THINK THAT THISCONCEPT
OF HEALTH. IN EVERY POLICY NEEDS
TO BE FURTHER EXTENDED TO REALLY
HEALTH IN EVERY INSTITUTION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THERE
REALLY NEEDS TO BE A WAY TO
ACCESS THAT SO NOT ONLY THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES. BUT TRULY
CREATING BOTH THE PHYSICAL AND
THE METAPHORICAL SPACE WHERE WE
CAN REALLY TACKLE HEALTH AND
NONTRADITIONAL HEALTH SETTINGS
WILL GET US A LOT FURTHER AND IT
SHOULD BE ABLE TO PAY EVENT SO
THAT IN CRISIS THAT BECOMES
TRULY YOU'RE A MEDIA. NETWORK TO
RUN THAT LAST MILE FIRST TO GET
THOSE SHOTS IN ARMS IN THIS
EXAMPLE THE PANDEMIC BUT REALLY
JUST LIKE THE AMERICORPS JUST
LIKE OUR- YOU KNOW PEACE KEEPING
MISSIONS DURING PEACEKEEPING
TIMES WE CAN BE PLANTING TREES
WE CAN BE DOING. THE GOOD WORK
WE NEED TO DO BUT DURING CRISIS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO ADD ACTIVATE
AND PIVOT IN OUR COMMUNITY IS
CAPABLE OF THAT AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO MESSAGES THAT PEOPLE
SOMETIMES DON'T REALLY GIVE US
ENOUGH CREDIT TO KNOW. HOW MUCH
WE CAN DO WHEN WE'RE TRUSTED WE
WANT TO BE GOOD STEWARDS TO OUR
OWN PEOPLE OUR OWN COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S FANTASTIC I APPRECIATE
HEARING AND SO IT'S- BUT NO BUT
JUST TO MAKE CLEAR. THESE THESE
THESE THE OF THIS SPECIFIC
HEALTH MODEL OR THE- THE
DELIVERY OF THE HEALTH SERVICES.
THEY DEPEND ON BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY IT'S JUST YOU KNOW.
THE MODEL EXISTS BUT IT'S JUST
HAVING THAT FLEXIBILITY TO DO IT
IN OTHER AREAS OF THE STATE
OBVIOUSLY. AND I JUST TOOK OF
THAT AND I WILL GO BACK TO
SOMETHING THEIR- FELLOW
PANELISTS SAID THAT THE
FLEXIBILITY BUT THEN I GO BACK
TO THE INTENTIONALITY OF RIGHT
SO WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU THE
FLEXIBILITY. TO DO THIS BUT THE
STARTING OUTCOMES THAT WE EXPECT
AS A RESULT RIGHT SO NICE JUST
IS NOT A BLANK CHECK IF YOU
WILL. TO DO ACTUALLY WHICH IS
LIKE YOU DO. YOU CREATE A
PARTNERSHIP THAT YOU FEEL ARE
NECESSARY BUT THEY'RE ACT COMES
ANY TO BE ATTACHED. TO THOSE-
PARTNERSHIPS ARE I THINK THAT
THAT THE GAME. INTENTIONALITY
BECOMES CRITICAL. DR ROSS-
FISHER ARE YOU STILL WITH US.
OKAY I DON'T THINK HE IS STILL
WITH US OKAY- RESTORES ONE ASK A
QUESTION CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE US
AN UPDATE- ON THE LATEST
STATISTICS ON HIV AND THEN I
HAVE ONE FOR TERRY SMITH TO
FOLLOW UP ON AS WELL. ABSOLUTELY
SO EXCITED AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER PARTICULARLY IN IN THE
LONG BEACH AREA WHICH IS WHERE-
WE FOCUS OUR OUR SERVICE
DELIVERY. AT THE RATE AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER AND THE LATEST
REPORT WHICH IS FROM TWENTY
NINETEEN S. YOU KNOW SOME OF
THESE DATA IS THERE'S A DELAY IN
GETTING THESE NUMBERS UT. BUT
WE IN LONG BEACH- AS OF TWENTY
NINETEEN HAD TWICE THE RATE OF
HIV INFECTIONS AS TO THE STATE
SO WE'RE AT TWENTY SIX- PER
HUNDRED THOUSAND ESTATE WAS AT
THIRTEEN PER ONE HUNDRED. SO
IT'S IS VERY LERMAN AGAIN LIKE
TERRY SAID EARLIER HE CONTINUES
TO IMPACT YOUNG MEN WHO HAVE SEX
WITH MEN AFRICAN AMERICAN
LATINO. AND THE OTHER PIECE THAT
IS REALLY. THERE BUT NOT THERE
YET IS THE IMPACT ONOUR TRANS.
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AGAIN
BECAUSE THEY DATA COLLECTION
DOESN'T REALLY REFLECT WHO THEY
ARE SO SOMETIMESTHEY GET. PUT
IN THE CATEGORY S. MAINLY SIX OF
MAN WHEN IN FACT THIS KNOW WHO
THEY ARE AS AN INDIVIDUAL SO
THAT THERE'D BE A TRUE NUMBER IS
A LITTLE UP SKEWER BECAUSE OF
THAT. ANY WE CONTINUE TO DO YOU
KNOW THIS BY THE EFFORTS OF HIV
TREATMENT WHICH WE KNOW IS VERY
EFFECTIVE A PERSON CAN GET TO
UNDETECTABLE. AND HAVE VERY VERY
IF NOT ZERO CHANCE OF
TRANSMITTING HIV VIA SEXUAL
ACTIVITIES WE HAVE CRAP. BUT THE
SERVICE DELIVERY HOW THE MESSAGE
GET TO THE INDIVIDUAL IN THAT IN
A MANNER THAT IS CONSISTENT
WITH. Y. M. MY LIVED EXPERIENCE
IS WILL I THINK THERE'S A
CONTINUES TO BE A GAP AND OF
COURSE. STI'S OR SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS IS A
PRETTY GOOD PREDICTOR IN MANY
CASES OF A POTENTIAL HIV
INFECTION SO. WE CONTINUE TO
HELP OUR TO DO IN THAT REGARD
AND IT'S THIS THAT THEY SIX
CONTINUE TO BE ALARMING
UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT. WHAT WILL
BE EMAILED TO ME YOU MADE
MENTION OF IT BECAUSE WE HAVE
PREPPING WE HAVE TAP AND IT
SEEMS LIKE THAT THAT WOULD HAVE
REDUCED THE RATE BUT YOU'RE
SAYING THAT LONG BEACH IS- AS AS
HIGH AS IT IS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN ITS TOTALITY SO
I'M ALARMED BY THAT BECAUSE
AGAIN THE CAMPAIGN WAS GETTING
TO ZERO- AND THERE WAS A LOT H.
CATION BEING DONE AND FUNDING TO
GO ALONG WITH THAT BUT WITH YOUR
NUMBERS YEARS DISTRICTS. THAT WE
SHOULD ABSOLUTELY BE ALARMED
BECAUSE IS DOUBLE OR EQUAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL AFFECTION
RATE AROUND HIV CORRECT AND SO
AGAIN I GO BACK TO THE
INTENTIONALITY RICE SO WE
GETTING TO ZERO WHO'S GETTING
THAT MESSAGE AND IN WHAT CONTEXT
RIGHT BECAUSE- THEY CAMPAIGN CAN
BE FANTASTIC I THINK I HAVE ALL
THE APPROPRIATE RESOURCES. BUT
IF THAT MESSAGE DOESN'T GET TO
ME IN A WAY THAT I CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT IS
APPLICABLE TO MY LIFE. THE POINT
RIGHT. IS IT'S POINTLESS. RIGHT
MAP IF I TRANSIT PERSON WHO'S
HOMELESS WHO'S FOOD INSECURE WHO
DOESN'T HAVE THIS STABLE.
HOUSING DO I CARE ABOUT PREP
PROBABLY NOT. I CARE ABOUT IS
THE ICE PROBABLY NOT THE AQABA
HIV PROBABLY NOT BECAUSE I'M
HOMELESS I'M HUNGRY I'M BAREFOOT
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR THEIR OVER
DRAMATISATION BUT THAT'S THAT'S
THE THING A PICTURE THAT'S
IMPORTANT YEAH I. DON'T HAVE TO
BE APOLOGIZE APOLOGETIC FOR THAT
WE APPRECIATE THAT DRAMATIZATION
BRING THAT MESSAGE HOME UP FOR
MISTER SMITH- I HAVE BEEN A
CHAMPION OF PREVENTION ACTIONS
TOWARDS HIV CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE
US AN UPDATE ON HOW COBIT
NINETEEN HAS IMPACTED HIV
PREVENTION SERVICES. I'M THE
IMPACT HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANT- WE
TALKING ABOUT ACCESSING SEXUAL
HEALTH SERVICES SO HIV TESTING
STD SCREENING AND TREATMENT CRAP
HAPPENS- OTHER SERVICES ARE
SEVERELY RESTRICTED BY OF
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE THEM
BECAUSE THEY WERE BUSY
RESPONDING TO COLD IT AND YOU
KNOW RIGHTLY SO- AND THEN
PREVENTION PROGRAMS THAT FOR
TRADITIONAL ABOUT KIND OF
BRINGING PEOPLE TOGETHER
PRINCIPALLY THE TABLE HAVING
CONVERSATION BUILDING COMMUNITY
WE COULDN'T DO THAT BECAUSE I
WAS DANGEROUS. FOR THE COME
TOGETHER AND SO ON THE IMPACT IS
IN PRETTY SIGNIFICANT AND I
THINK THAT WE ARE GOING TO SPEND
A LOT OF TIME TO CATCH UP. YOU
KNOW- REPEAL A WE IMPLEMENTED A
HOME TESTING PROGRAM RECENT TEST
KITS OUT TO PEOPLE AT HOME AND
THAT HAD HAS HAD SOMETHING TO
TAKE BUT I THINK THAT- WHAT CAN
WE WORK FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISENFRANCHISED AND AN IMPACT IS
REALLY. BRINGING US TOGETHER-
SITTING AROUND A TABLE COME-
NORMALIZING SEX HEALTH
ADDRESSING THE HOMOPHOBIA
TRANSPHOBIA ALL THE THOUGHT THAT
EXIST WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S GONNA HELP US GET AHEAD.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WANTS TO
AT THAT. I ASKED THE QUESTION
I'M GOING TO GO BACK TO- DR- THE
BALL- WITH RESPECT TO THE-
GOVERNOR JUST CAME OUT WITH.
INTEREST AND RUBIO THAT THERE'S
GONNA BE A THIRTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS A SURPLUS- IN THE STATE
AND IF YOU HAD TEN BILLION OF
THE THIRTY ONE BILLION. HOW
WOULD YOU DIRECT THOSE RESOURCES
AND WHY. THANK YOU I LOVE THIS
QUESTION AND THIS OPPORTUNITY-
SO FIRST I WANT TO CONTEXTUALIZE
MY RESPONSE AND I WANT TO KNOW
THAT OUR CHILDREN RIGHT NOW ARE
SLATED TO HAVE A LOWER LIFE
EXPECTANCY THAN THEIR PARENTS.
AND THAT REALLY DEMONSTRATES FOR
US THAT WE'RE SLIPPING BACKWARDS
IN TERMS OF SOCIAL AND HEALTH
PROGRESS AND THAT OUR CURRENT
SYSTEMS ARE FAILING US IN TERMS
OF HEALTH EQUITY. AND SO THIS IS
THE PRODUCT OF MULTIPLE CRISES
THE PANDEMIC CERTAINLY POLLUTED
WATER AS WAS MENTIONED WILDFIRES
PEOPLE CAN'T BREED RACIAL
VIOLENCE THERE ARE MULTIPLE
PANDEMICS THAT WE ARE GRAPPLING
WITH DAY IN AND DAY OUT. AND SO
THIS IS A MOMENT TO SHIFT FROM
THINKING ABOUT INCREMENTAL
CHANGE OR REACTIONARY APPROACHES
TO TRANSFORMATIVECHANGE TOO
DEEP AND LASTING FUNDAMENTAL
CHANGE AND TO GO TO GET THERE WE
REALLY NEED TO BE INVESTING IN
HISTORICALLY OPPRESSED GROUPS
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE AT
THE CENTER OF DESIGNING AND
IMPLEMENTING SOLUTIONS TO THESE
ISSUES. WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE AT
THE TABLE AND ARE EMPOWERED TO
SHARE THEIR VISIONS AND
SOLUTIONS TO THESE ISSUES WE ARE
THE CARETAKERS FROM THEIR WORLD
AND WE CAN BE LISTENING TO THEM-
AND LEANING ON THEM FOR THESE
SOLUTIONS. AND THIS PROCESS
WOULD YIELD CONTEXTUALLY AND
CULTURALLY SPECIFIC ACTION PLANS
ARE THAT ARE BOTH LOCALLY
SPECIFIC AND ALSO PROVIDE A
PLATFORM IN A FRAMEWORK FOR
GUIDING STATE LEVEL WORK AND I
WOULD POINT TO SYSTEM LEVEL
CHANGES AS WELL AS NEW COMMUNITY
DRIVEN SOLUTIONS AND SYSTEMS. AT
TO POINT US ON A PATH TOWARD
HEALTH EQUITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I WANT SOMEONE ELSE ASPECT
ANSWER THAT QUESTION FROM YOUR
OWN- LANDS BUT I WANT TO. BEFORE
I OPEN THAT QUESTION UP AGAIN I
WANNA GO TO- MS HENDRICKS ARE
YOU STILL WITH US. VIRGINIA YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A MEMBER
OF THE NATIVE AMERICAN CAUCUS
CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE US AN UPDATE
ON WHAT TYPE OF SERVICES THE
CALIFORNIA CONCERT CONCERTS
CONSORTIUM OF URBAN INDIAN
HEALTH IS DOING- AROUND THIS
WORK PROMOTING HEALTH EQUITY.
WHAT ARE SOME THE WAY AROUND I'M
HEALTH EQUITY. YEAH SO OR WE ARE
OUT HE IS REALLY A- IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAVE THE SAME WELL
ACCESS THAT MONEY AND PROGRAMS
AS OUR TRAVEL PARTNERS OR ARE HE
HEALTH CENTERS- IN ADDITION TO
THAT WE WORK. CLOSELY WITH STATE
ECONOMY AND- HOW. ON TRYING TO
CLOSE GAS AROUND DATA RELEASED
AMERICAN YOU LAST NEEDED PEOPLE
A INVOLVING ARE SOME OF THE-
MOST RACIALLY MISCLASSIFIED
GROUPS IN THE STATE THAT YOU
NEED TO GO TO A STATE HOSPITAL
AND WE HAVE A HISPANIC SURNAME
WILL BE. RACIALLY MISCLASSIFIED
YOU KNOW HE'S GETTING HELP OR
YOU KNOW THAT OUR PEOPLE WERE
DEVASTATED BY TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEMS AND WERE. GIVEN THE NAME
HER LONG LAST AND SO THAT WE SEE
THAT BACK ON US WHEN IT COMES TO
HEALTH DATA SO WE ARE VERY
LITERALLY BEING BORN AGAIN AND
DYING WHITE THAT BEING ARDESTAN
AGAINST YOU KNOW DIRECTORS ARE
YOU GETTING ARE EASY AS- WHITE.
OR HISPANIC. PHENOTYPICALLY IF
YOU'RE WHITE BLACK WILL BE LAID
ASSET AND- THERE'S A- GAS IT IS
UNDER. THAT HOW OF CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST LEGAL AND THOSE PEOPLE WHO
WERE. THROUGH FEDERAL AND- TO
THE DATA CALIFORNIA AND NOW
HEALTH. GENERATIONS OF I'M WE DO
WORK YOU KNOW YOU WORK ON
INCREASING- HEALTH COMMUNITY.
MANAGER HEALTH- AND THIS IS. OF
WE HAVE A REALLY LARGE AROUND I
GOT A SINGLE UNIT THAT THANK YOU
AND I JUST WANT TO KNOW LIKE
SUBSTANCE STARTED IN GOAL LATER
IN THIS HAD AN IMPACT AROUND
USING YOU TO GET UPDATED BY.
APPDYNAMICS AND NOBODY REALLY
CARED ABOUT. THAT IT ENTAILS
WHITE PEOPLE STARTED DYING
OPIOIDS IN FACT CHARGING YOU
HAVE AN IDEA HEROIN OVERDOSES OR
JACKIE'S AND WE WANT TO MAKE
THIS PRESCRIPTION DRUG PROBLEM
BUT THAT'S NOT THE ONLY PROBLEM
THAT EXIST. IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND ANY. TALK ABOUT IT BUT WE
HAVE TO START EQUITY ENDING LIKE
. ASSISTED WE FOUND THAT HE
SHOULD THIS IS. THINGS LIKE THAT
ALSO GOES WAY FOR COMMUNITY AND
WALKING AROUND REALLY MEET OUR
HANDS ON IT TO SAY WERE. MORE
NOT WORK- SO. YOU KNOW ANYMORE
WE. CAN YOU HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
. TO WORK OF. COMMUNICATIONS IN
COMMUNITIES TALK ABOUT WHAT IS
OUR NEXT. EDUCATION ASSISTANCE.
HOW CAN STARTING OCT IN THE
HANDS EVERYBODY. COULD USE IT I
THINK THAT HE WROTE MANAGED
HEALTH DURING CANADA PASSED
LOADED FOR ACTING IS WAITING
ABOUT. I HAVEN'T OF- BUT- FIRST
TIME OF REPORT. DAYS OF NO NO
SHOWS IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THAT
MEANS EVERY PERSON MILLION
APPOINT SHE UP TODAY. ALL THE
WAY AND WHICH SAYS TRUMAINE I'LL
OF NOW AMERICAN EVEN INSTITUTED
CALIFORNIA DURING THE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU TOO ON A LOT OF
GREAT INFORMATION- I APPRECIATE
THAT- I'M TO GO- TO- WITH THIS
NEXT- AS- IT'S HOW DO WE- THAT
THE CLINICS. ARE NOT LEFT BEHIND
AGAIN- WITH ANOTHER PANDEMIC BUT
BEFORE YOU ANSWER THAT QUESTION
I'M GONNA ASK MY COLLEAGUE-
MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS. EVERYTHING
THAT HAS BEEN RAISED HERE TODAY
IN CONVERSATION. IS WHEN FOLKS
THE LATINO COMMUNITY AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN LADY SO YOU'RE THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE OF THE- LIKE THE
YOU KNOW A LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
I'M A MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS I BELIEVE THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE A HEARING. A JOINT
HEARING WITH BOTH CAUCUSES. TO
REALLY PUSH THE DISPARITY OUT SO
WE CAN ONE NOT ONLY EDUCATE OUR
OWN COLLEAGUES. BUT ALSO COME UP
WITH THE REAL CONCRETE PLANT.
AND WOULD BE WILLING TO- GET
YOUR THOUGHTS IN TERMS OF US
TRYING TO ORGANIZE- WITH THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THE
COMMUNITY WOULD ABSOLUTELY
BENEFIT. SAYING THAT BLACK AND
BROWN LEADERS COMING TOGETHER
AROUND THE HEALTH DISPARITIES
THAT EXIST IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
BECAUSE AGAIN- THIS PANDEMIC HAS
FURTHER EXACERBATED THIS TO THE
AND REYES THEN ROSE TO THE
LEVELS WE ARE RIGHT NOW. WE
DON'T WANT TO GO BACKWARDS MORE
TO MOVE FORWARD BUT WE WANT TO
LEARN FROM THE PAST. SO THAT WE
WON'T REPEAT IT AGAIN SO THAT'S
A CHALLENGE TO YOU AND QUESTION
YOUR THOUGHTS. OR THE JOINT YEAH
SO YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT TO
WORK- YOU KNOW- ON THAT- ISSUE.
WHEN YOU A YOU KNOW I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE INFORMATION
THAT'S BEEN SHARED IT'S BEEN
INCREDIBLY EDUCATIONAL- BUT AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- MISTER GIBSON
THE- INJURED JUST MENTIONED YOU
KNOW THE- IMPACTS. THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED THAT WE KNOW EXIST
THAT ONLY BE EXACERBATED BY THIS
PANDEMIC. WE KNOW THAT. GOOD
DATA OR THAT. THAT THAT RESEARCH
AND THAT DATA SHOULD DRIVE
PUBLIC POLICY THE DATE AS YOU
HAVE ALL MENTIONED EXISTS IS
THERE ARE WE KNOW THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE BEING LEFT
BEHIND. NOW WE GOTTA DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT- AND YOU
KNOW. I'M PROUD TO BE A MEMBER
OF THE LEGISLATURE AM PROUD TO
BE PART OF THE LATINO CAUCUS THE
LARGEST AT THE CAUCUS OF ANY
STATE LEGISLATURE AND ALL OF.
THE UNITED STATES. WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO BECAUSE TOO MANY
OF OUR COMMUNITIES ARE BEING
LEFT BEHIND IF HISTORICALLY BEEN
LEFT BEHIND. AND SO IF WE CAN'T
DO SOMETHING NOW- IT YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW CERTAIN- YOU KNOW
THAT'S- A DISAPPOINTMENT. AND TO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO GET SOMETHING
DONE BECAUSE- IT'S- INCREDIBLY
OVERDUE. RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH JOINT. THANK YOU YES THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER- AND I DO
LIKE THE IDEA OF BRINGING
MULTIPLE CAUCUSES TOGETHER ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE- SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT GIVE ME TIME TO
NOODLE ON THE- HOW. WE CAN
ENSURE THAT CLINIC ASSOCIATION
CLINICS ARE LEFT OUT IN FUTURE
PANDEMIC- I AGAIN I'M FEELING
HEARTENED BY THE POSITION THAT
C. C. A. L. A. C. THE CLINICS IN
LOS ANGELES OR IN A RELATION TO
OUR COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT IN OUR COUNTY HEALTH
SERVICES. I FEEL LIKE WE'RE IN
BETTER SHAPE IN MY CONCERN IS
PROBABLY MORE BROADLY FOCUSED ON
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE WHERE I
KNOW MY COLLEAGUES IN OTHER
REGIONS DON'T HAVE THE KINDS OF
RELATIONSHIPS THAT WE HAVE WITH
OUR LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
HERE IN LA- IF I WAS LOOKING AT
PIECES THAT CONCERNED ME
THINKING GOING FORWARD WITH THE
NEXT PANDEMIC LOOKS LIKE. I
WOULD BE SOMEWHAT CONCERNED AND
CURIOUS HOW WE MIGHT
INSTITUTIONALIZE THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
IN REGARDS TO. YOU KNOW PANDEMIC
PLANNING. WE HAVE A LOT OF
REALLY GOOD RELATIONSHIPS WITH A
LOT OF INDIVIDUALS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
RIGHT NOW. BUT HOW DOES THAT
RELATIONSHIP GET TO THE
INSTITUTIONAL LEVEL SO THAT YOU
KNOW IF WE HAVE TURNED OVER AND
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE NO LONGER
THERE. DID IT DOES THE
RELATIONSHIP FLOUNDER A LITTLE
BIT- SO THAT'S SOMETHING ON MY
MIND AND I THINK IT'S PROBABLY
ON THE MIND OF LOTS OF FOLKS
LOOKING FORWARD- AT MY
ORGANIZATION. YOU KNOW WE RUN AN
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT PROGRAM WE
DO WORK CLOSELY HISTORICALLY
WHAT DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WE WORK WITH PUBLIC HEALTH FUND.
YOU KNOW AS- IS- AND HIV BUT
THIS ISSUE OF PANDEMIC PLANNING
FEELS. FRESHER NEWER TO US- SO
YEAH REALLY MAKING SURE THAT
THAT'S PART OF. EMERGENCY
PLANNING THAT IT'S NOT JUST
EARTHQUAKES TERRORIST EVENTS
SOME OF THINGS THAT WERE
INCLUDED. BUT ONE OF THE THINGS-
FOR ME I WAS RUNNING AROUND MY
TEAM WAS RUNNING AROUND LIKE A
CHICKEN WITH ITS HEAD CUT OFF.
WE WORK OF HUSTLING- WE WERE
BEGGING FOR PP- COUNTY
UNIVERSITY MINGUS HILLS THE
STUDENTS WERE MAKING A MASK AND
WE I PURCHASED- FIVE HUNDRED-
MASS I'M VERY GRATEFUL THESE ARE
THE SCHEELS SCHEELS- THAT THE
STUDENTS HERE CASSIDY UNIVERSUM
IN HIS HEELS ARE MAKING ON A
DAILY BASIS. AND I TOOK THOSE MY
TEAM TOOK THOSE WITH PP
EQUIPMENT AND- FACE MASKS
DANCING WE TOOK THOSE TO
CLINICS. IN THE HEIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC. I DON'T WANT TO GO
BACK TO THAT AGAIN. YOU SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO- DOCTOR HEALTHCARE
PROFESSION SHOULD NOT HAVE TO.
IN THE FIFTH WORLD ECONOMY
DAMMIT WEAR THE SAME UNIFORM
OVER AND OVER AGAIN- WHILE
TRYING TO SERVICE. I'M IN THE
MIDST OF A PANDEMIC- I WAS VERY
DISHEARTENED BY THAT- I KNOW
THAT THIS IS OUR FIRST TIME
BEING IN SUCH A PANDEMIC. SO
THERE'S NO ROAD MAP IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE NEED TO DO I WAS BY
TRIAL AND ERROR I DO WANNA TRY
THAT NO MORE. I SAID NORMAL.
OKAY SO. WE NEED TO IS THERE A
PLAN IN PLACE FOR CLINICS MOVING
FORWARD BECAUSE A WHAT JUST
TRANSPIRED ON THE NEWS- WITH
THIS NEW VARIANTS. I DON'T KNOW
I CAN'T REMEMBER THE NAME OF IT
. GLOBAL ON THE CALL. THAT ONE
OKAY. SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT THIS IS CREEP INTO OUR
RICK THAT WE HOW TO HAVE IT AND
MY CONCERN A- THAT THE CLINICS.
HAS COMMUNICATED WITH KNOWLEDGE
COUNTY HEALTH OF DEPARTMENTS BUT
THE STATE AS WELL TO MAKING SURE
THAT THIS IS THE BLUEPRINT BASED
ON OUR PREVIOUS KNOWLEDGE THAT
IF SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPENS
THAT WE KNOW WHAT TO DO
IMMEDIATELY IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT EXISTS. I DO BELIEVE IT'S
IF NOT FULLY FLESHED OUT- IN
BETTER SHAPE THAN IT WAS
PREVIOUSLY- I SAID OUR
ARRANGEMENT WITH THE COUNTY FOR
DISTRIBUTION OF PP WALL ROCKY AT
FIRST AND LARGELY. THAT WAS
BECAUSE THE COUNTY DIDN'T HAVE
IT TO DISTRIBUTE- ONCE THEY DID
IS JUST IN PLACE WHEREBY GOT.
FOR THE COUNT WE JUST THAT TO
MEMBERS. AND MEMBER- CLINICS
ALSO GET P. P. DIRECTLY FROM THE
COUNTY. BUT THERE IS A BIG
CHALLENGE IN A BOTTLE NECK WAS
THAT WE RENTED STORAGE UNITS THE
CLINIC ASSOCIATION. RESTORE PP
SO IT STARTED FLOWING IN BUT
CLINICS DON'T HAVE THE PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO STORE THREE OR
SIX MONTHS OR A YEAR WORTH OF PP
ON SITE- AND THAT'S A VERY THAT
I THINK. STILL NEEDS TO BE
OVERCOME IN LOOKING FORWARD AND
THINKING ABOUT FUTURE PANDEMICS
IS THAT THEY OPERATE ON SUCH
TIGHT MARGINS AND SPACE IS AT A
PREMIUM AND THEN A LATE. SPACE
COST A FORTUNE- AND HAVING THAT
TYPE OF STORAGE PROVED A VERY
SEVERE LIMITATION- AND YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT YOU DON'T.
SEE CLEC RENTING A STORAGE UNIT
IS PROBABLY NOT A GOOD LONG TERM
SOLUTION IN THINKING ABOUT
FUTURE PANDEMIC PLANNING-ABSOLUTELY. ADD TO THAT PLEASE
BUT I DON'T. GT THIS ONE TO ADD
A CUP QUICK COM. BUT YOUR- WHO
THAT ONLINE. SORRY MONEY TO
START OF THE WAY BUT I'M GOING
TO ENOUGH I CAN THE WATER. ONE
FIVE I DIDN'T GET ANY TO BE YOU
WHY. NOT PROVIDED THERE ANYTHING
ALL THE BACK ON THE LARGE. ALL
IN ONE. WONDERS WHO AND IS FOR
THE STATE. YOU HAVE NOT ONLY A-
DIVISIONS AT. IT AT HOME. THAT
ASKED THE LOCAL CAN ON LAW OUT.
SO IF YOU HAVE A WHERE HOW. YOU
KNOW WE ALL PD AND IN THE THAT
TO OUR DATA. WORKERS OF THE OR
GET A IT ON THE OF DIDN'T ROW.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL THE DAY WITH
NOT A- THAT'S ONE. WE HAD A
LITTLE AND- LOT ANGELES COUNTY-
WE DON'T HAVE THE BILL TO DO
THAT AMONG. THAT IS ONE WAY TO
CONSIDER PEOPLE DIDN'T HAVE TO
UPDATE AND SURE TO CONDITION WE
WERE OKAY- IN OUR- WHO'S ALWAYS
FRESH. THE TWILIGHT ZONE YOU
KNOW IS THIS REALLY THE
WEALTHIEST COUNTRY THAT YOU KNOW
FIRST WHATEVER. ICONOMI AND SO-
SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE
SELECT COMMITTEE IS FOCUSED ON
INFECTIOUS DISEASES IN ADDITION
TO HIV. HEPATITIS AND S. T. EYES
WHEN WE LOOK AT THESE PANDEMICS
LIKE CORONAVIRUS- YOU KNOW WHAT
ROLE DOES THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PLAYED NOW AS A
NATION AND WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT
THE- AN- EQUAL DISTRIBUTION OF
RESOURCES GLOBALLY. KNOWING THAT
IT DOES HAVE A DIRECT IMPACT
HERE AT IN CALIFORNIA. SO WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN SUB SAHARAN
AFRICA RIGHT NOW WITH THE SOUTH
AFRICAN VARIANT IF AFRICA DOES
NOT GET ACCESS TO VACCINES THERE
WILL BE ANOTHER MUTATION AND IT
WILL TRAVEL THE WORLD AND IT
WILL COME BACK TO CALIFORNIA SO.
I THINK THERE HAS TO BE PRESSURE
APPLIED TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THERE HAS TO BE AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT INFECTION SEE
NO BORDERS OR BOUNDARIES SO WE
TALK ABOUT BORDER AN IMMIGRANT
HEALTH. THOSE HAVE DIRECT-IMPLICATIONS ON THE HEALTH OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND SO I
THINK WE HAVE TO HELP OUR STATE
FOCUS SOME ATTENTION AND
RESOURCE THERE. AS WELL AS
PUTTING THAT PRESSURE ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
UNDERSTANDING WHEN APPROACHING
THESE ISSUES IT IS ABSOLUTE
RESPONSIBILITY TO ALSO ADDRESS
THAT AT SOME GLOBAL LEVEL AS
WELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DR
YOUNG ARE YOU STILL WITH US. I
DON'T THINK YOU ARE STILL YOUNG
FROM. STRAIGHT FROM CHARLES
UNIVERSITY OF MEDICINE AND
SCIENCE- SOCIT PROFESSOR IF
AGAIN THE QUESTION- IF IN FACT
WHAT THE GOVERNOR REVEALED THAT
HE HAS THIRTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS SURPLUS OF IF YOU HAD
TEN BILLION BECAUSE YOU WERE ON
THE FRONT LINE AND- WE SPOKE-
EXTENSIVELY AT. SIX O'CLOCK IN
THE MORNING ASKING FOR HELP AND
WE STOOD UP AND GOT THE KIND
HELP THAT YOU- HOPEFULLY NEEDED
TO DURING THE TIME- AT THE
HEIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC SO WITH
THE RESOURCES. TEN BILLION
DOLLARS YOU HAD IT WILL YOU DO
WITH IT. I THANK YOU FOR THAT
PERSON I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
SAY IS THAT. I AM. DURING THE
NEXT WALKING AROUND PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN DILLON IZED. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WANT TO SAY IS
THAT WE CANNOT DO THAT WE CANNOT
BLAME THE OPPRESSED FOR WHAT HAS
OCCURRED IT TO THEM BUT THE
OTHER THING THAT IS REALLY COME
FORTH DURING THIS TIME IS THAT
IT'S- I. UNDERSTANDING COMES TO
REALIZE JUST THE LEVEL OF TRAUMA
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
EXPERIENCED. I'VE COME TO
UNDERSTAND AND REALIZE THAT THE
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE WHO WERE
LIVING ITSELF IN MANY OTHERS
NEEDS ARE REFUGEES. I THOUGHT
THAT ONE OF THE PASTORS IN
COMMENTED THAT THE SAME CHURCH
IS MY FAMILY HE'S TEXAS. MY
FAMILY LEFT THE SOUTH BECAUSE OF
THE OPPRESSION OF THE EXPERIENCE
THERE THEREFORE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE MUST INVEST IN.
IS TRAUMA INFORMED CARE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES THIS IS ALSO TRUE
FOR. OUR AS ADAM. WITH MY
GENERAL HENRIK. THAT PEOPLE HAD
A BOUNTY ON THEIR HEADS. THAT
YOU HAD TO CLEAN IT THAT THEY
WERE. LATINO OR MEXICAN SO THAT
THEIR VILLAGES THAT ARE
COMMUNITIES WENT BE WIPED OUT SO
IN ADDITION TO YOUR- AB OR
REALLY TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS OUR PAST WE HAVE
TO ADDRESS THE GLOBAL PHARMA.
BECAUSE WITHOUT THE PROBLEM
BEING ADDRESSED WE HAD NOT.
FULLY RECOVER AS A COMMUNITY I
HOPE THAT THAT KIND OF MAKES
SENSE I THAT SUBSTANCE ABUSE
ISSUES IT IS TEN- HE- SERVICE
THIS IS AN AREA THAT WE'VE GOT
YOU BESTED SO WITH TEN MILLION
DOLLARS WHAT WILL YOU DO. WE
WILL EDUCATE OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
STARTING IN HIGH SCHOOL AND I'M
- MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID. WE
WILL PROVIDE BASIC LEVELS OF
TRAINING FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE SO
THAT THEY CAN TAKE CARE OF OUR
NEEDS THEY CAN TAKE CARE OF
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS. WE WILL
DEVELOP A HOSPITAL IN THOSE
AREAS THAT WE YOU. NEED HIGHER
LEVELS OF CARE. WE DON'T HAVE
ANY Q. AND SOUTH LA. YEAH WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST MORTALITY RATE
OF INCIDENCE. COUNTY WE DO NOT
HAVE A LEVEL ONE TRAUMA CENTER
IN SOUTH PHILLY YEAH WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST MORTALITY RATES. MORE WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO PARTNER WITH
OUR CLINIC SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE
. YOU KNOW ACCESS TO THE
HOSPITAL IS SO HARD TO GET
SOMEONE INTO A HOSPITAL AND HOW
THE ADMITTING PRIVILEGES. WITH
THE CURRENT SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
. MORE ONE OF THE IDEAS I HAVE
WITH THIS TEN BILLION SB DO IT
ALL THE TEN MILLION THIS IS ALL
IN FEW KEY SAFETY TOOLS B. R.
INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL BE TRAINED
NOT ONLY AND- YOU KNOW THAT C.
P. R. EMTS THAT HAVE ACCESS TO
NALOXONE. SO AGAIN WE HAVE
STRATEGIES THAT CAN WORK WE CAN
TAKE CARE OF OURSELVES. AND I
THINK DOCTOR ABRAHAM'S
STATEMENT. YOU KNOW WE KNOW HOW
SHE NAVIGATES OUR COMMUNITY WE
KNOW HOW. TO TALK TO OUR OWN
PEOPLE. WE CAN MANY OF US ARE
MORE. MANY ARE MORE. WE KNOW HOW
TO MOVE BETWEEN COMMUNITY. SO
TEN BILLION. YES PLEASE NOT DOOR
. THOMAS DID IT DOWN AND WE'LL
GET IT DONE AND WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE FOR OUR PEOPLE. VERY MUCH
FOR THAT- LET ME GO TO THE
DOCTOR ABRAHAM WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE NEW WHAT ARE SOME OF THE I
WILL SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BECAUSE- YOU RAISE THE ISSUE I'D
WE I HEARD IT A LITTLE BIT HERE
BUT YOU BROUGHT IT HOME. AND
THAT'S THE TRAUMA- THIS PANDEMIC
HAS MISSED A WHOLE BUNCH OF
PEOPLE UP- WITH YOUR HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONAL OR NOT WHERE THE
DIFFERENCE I THINK WE ALL SUFFER
FROM SOME FORM OF TRAUMA- AND
RESOURCES GOING IN THAT AREA IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL- I'M GOING
IN IN THE IN THIS SPACE SO.
SOMEBODY MAY WANT TO ALSO TOUCH
BASES ON THAT BUT I'LL GO TO
DOCTOR ABRAHAM WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE NEW THE NEWS- YOU ARE
HEARING OR ON THE GROUND OF AS
IT RELATES TO VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION- WHAT ELSE IS
NEEDED IN OUR COMMUNITY TO
ADDRESS- THE LACK OF RESOURCES
IN OUR COMMUNITY. SURE I'LL
START BY JUST TALKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW DR YOUNG AND I'VE WORKED
TOGETHER IN THE PAST WE'VE
WORKED SPECIFICALLY ON VACCINES
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY I MEAN THIS
REALLY GOES TO SHOW WE ARE ALL
IN THIS TOGETHER SO MANY OF US
HAVE ACTUALLY WORKED TOGETHER IN
MANY DIFFERENT CAPACITIES.
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE SO THAT
NETWORK IS THAT POWERFUL AND
STRONG IF ONLY WE HAD THE
RESOURCES AND INVESTMENT- BUT I
WILL SAY ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
STRUCTURALLY. WE CAN DO TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES AS I THINK WE
HAVE TO APPROACH HEALTH AS A
CONTINUUM AND THAT CONTINUE MUST
INCLUDE PRIMARY CARE. AS ONE OF
ITS FOUNDATIONS ALONG WITH
MENTAL HEALTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ALONG WITH PUBLIC HEALTH AND
RIGHT NOW THOSE SILOS ARE ALSO
DESTRUCTIVE THERE COME WE'RE
COMPETING INTERESTS RIGHT NOW
AND THAT'S- TROUBLESOME BECAUSE
WE REALLY NEED TO APPROACH THIS.
AS HEALTH A CONTINUUM AND THAT
NEEDS TO INCLUDE PRIMARY
SECONDARY TERTIARY QUATERNARY
CARE BUT ALSO EVERYTHING WE'VE
DONE TO COMPARTMENTALIZE MENTAL
HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE ADDICTION
AND ALL THIS. DETERMINE
INCLUDING HOUSING. AND THEN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH PEACE AND WE SEE
THAT FRAGMENTATION HERE IN THE
COUNTY THAT EXIST IN THE STATE.
AND SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
TYPES OF BITING STRUCTURAL
BARRIERS IF WE CAN FIND WAYS TO
MOVE. FURTHER AND RESOURCE
ALLOCATION BETWEEN THOSE SILOS
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE HELPED US A
LOT SOONER DURING THE PANDEMIC.
OF AS FAR AS THE VACCINES WHERE
DO WE GO FROM HERE I MEAN IT'S A
TOUGH THING TO SAY EVERY DAY
WE'RE HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH
PEOPLE EVERYDAY PEOPLE. ARE
STRUGGLING TO CHOOSE VACCINES
FOR THEMSELVES THEIR CHILDREN.
NOW WITH THIS OMICRON VARIANT
WE'RE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
AFRAID ABOUT SHOULD I GET A
BOOSTER NOW OR WAIT UNTIL AND
NEXT GENERATION. VACCINE IS
DEVELOPED WE REALLY HAVE TO SAY
LOUD AND CLEAR IF YOU HAVEN'T
GOTTEN YOUR FIRST OR SECOND
DOES. PLEASE GO GET VACCINATED
NOW WE REALLY RECOMMEND EVERYONE
OVER EIGHTEEN TO PLEASE GO GET A
BOOSTER RIGHT OW. I BELIEVE
THAT THE MANUFACTURERS WELL LOOK
AT NEXT GENERATION VACCINES
ESPECIALLY IF WE REALIZE THAT
HOME ACROSS ON. THE ESCAPE RISK
IS HIGH AND THESE VACCINES ARE
NOT AS EFFECTIVE WE WILL HAVE TO
CHANGE OUR STRATEGY BUT WE HAVE
LEARNED SO MUCH IN THE LAST
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY MONTHS THAT WE
WILL NOT HAVE TO GO. TO THE DARK
DAYS OF MARCH TWENTY TWENTY AND
GO DOWN THAT SHUT DOWN THE ROAD
SO I APPLAUD ALL THE MEASURES
THE STATE HAS TAKEN. THE COUNTY
L. A. U. S. D. WITH THEIR
VACCINE MANDATES THESE ARE ALL
THE STEPS THESE ARE THE LAYERING
STEPS THAT KEEP US SAFE AND WHEN
WE DO THOSE THINGS. WE CAN KEEP
OUR ECONOMIES OPEN WE CAN SEND
OUR KIDS TO SCHOOL WE CAN GET
BACK TO DOING ALL THOSE THINGS
THAT WE MISS DOING FOR FIFTEEN.
TO TWENTY MONTHS SO YES GET BACK
SAY CONTINUE TO WEAR MASKS
SOCIAL DISTANCE HAND HYGIENE
THAT'S ALL PART OF IT BUT OF
COURSE RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN THIS
MOMENT WE'RE GOING TO WATCH VERY
CLOSELY. WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THIS PARTICULAR VARIANT HOW
CONCERNING IS THAT THEIR FIFTY
PLUS MUTATIONS ON THIS VARIANT
AND WHAT DOES THAT MEAN DOWN THE
ROAD AND EVEN FOR FUTURE
VARIANTS AND AS I MENTIONED IF
THE WORLD ISN'T VACCINATED. THIS
WILL CONTINUE TO BE A MAJOR
THREAT MOVING FORWARD. YOU A
DOCTOR A REVIEW HIT ON SOMETHING
A NERVE- WHAT IS. CROSS ON- AND
THEY SPEND. THAT HAS OBVIOUSLY
ORIGINATED. IN AFRICA- WOULD YOU
SAY THAT IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. UNITED STATES
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
RESPONSIBILITY. TO PUT RESOURCES
THERE. SO THAT IT WON'T COME
HERE. I MEAN I THINK THE MESSAGE
HAS TO BE NOW IN THE STATE BUT
ALSO FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- TRIED
TO GET AHEAD OF THIS THING SO
THAT AGAIN WE DON'T SEE. IT
POPPING UP HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
NOTHING JUST CLOSED THE BORDERS
IN SAYING TO PEOPLE CAN COME IN
IS NOT ENOUGH WE HAVE TO PUT
RESOURCES. INTO THAT JUST AS
MUCH AS WE NEED TO PUT RESOURCES
IN ALL COMMUNITIES AND
EVERYTHING BOILS DOWN TO THE
RESOURCES COMING INTO OUR
COMMUNITY SO THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
THE HEALTH DISPARITIES THAT
EXIST IN THIS IN THIS COMMUNITY
AND TRYING TO A UNDER- NOT ONLY
UNDERSTAND BUT ALSO ADDRESS
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS.
THAT PEOPLE ARE DEALING WITH IN
OUR COMMUNITY SO WITH THAT-
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH- DOES
ANYONE ELSE. WANT TO CHIME IN ON
ANYTHING THAT WAS SAID OR YOU
WANT TO MAKE SOME ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE NOT COVERED. AROUND THIS
TOPIC. I KNOW WE'VE COVERED-
AWFUL- A LOT OF AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE CAN ADD NE
IMPORTANCE OF CONCEPT HERE IS
THAT I THINK THE CORPORATE TO
VACATION THAT WE'RE SEEING WITH
AND TO HELP SPACE HAS SERIOUS
NEGATIVE IMPLICATIONS ON THE
GROUND SO YOU SAW THAT RETAILERS
AND MAYBE RETAIL PHARMACIES HAD
ACCESS TO VACCINES AND THEY WERE
ABLE TO SECURE THEM AND LOCK
THEM AWAY RIGHT WITH- OUT REALLY
DISTRIBUTING THEM AND YET IT WAS
THE COMMUNITY CLINICS AND- THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT THAT
REALLY WAS OUT THERE GETTING
THOSE SHOTS AND ARMS IN SOUTH.
WHEN WE LOOK AT HOW BIG THESE
MEDICAL MECCA AS AND OTHER
PIECES OF THE HEALTHCARE
LANDSCAPE AND THE
CANNIBALIZATION THAT'S OCCURRING
IN THE CORPORATIZATION THEY HAVE
A REAL NEGATIVE IMPACTS THEY MAY
NOT HAVE P. P. SHORTAGES BUT
EVERYONE ELSE DID THEY MAY HAVE
GOTTEN VACCINES FIRST AND THEN
THEY LOCKED HIM UP THOSE TYPES
OF WE'VE CREATED A STE-
INFRASTRUCTURE WE'VE CREATED A
SCENARIO WHERE THIS IS HAPPENING
AND IS ALLOWED TO HAPPEN WE'VE
GOT TO FIND WAYS TO CHECK AND
BALANCE THAT. AND I THINK THAT
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH WHERE WE
HAD WITH INCREASING ACCESS TO
CARE WE'RE GONNA TO WATCH REALLY
CLOSELY THESE VERY LARGE
ELEPHANTS THAT ARE IN THE ROOM
THAT WE CANNOT CONTROL TO THE
STATE LEGISLATURE THAT ARE YOU
KNOW REALLY ABLE TO LOBBY THEIR
BEST INTERESTS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL BUT THEY HAVE REAL SERIOUS
IMPLICATIONS FOR WHETHER WE HAVE
ACCESS TO LIFE SAVING ESSENTIAL
MEDICINES WHETHER WE HAVE ACCESS
TO CARE INOUR COMMUNITIES. AND
SO I REALLY THINK THAT
CORPORATIZATION NEEDS TO BE
PRIORITIZED AND SEE HOW DO YOU
PUT SOME CHECKS AND BALANCES ON
THAT ROUTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MY COLLEAGUE MADE MENTION OF THE
SITUATION THAT TRANSPIRED IN HIS
DISTRICT WHERE- IN THE- I THINK
WAS A YOUNG PERSON HAD TO GO TO-
A BUSINESS ECSTATIC MITIGATE
INTERNET- TELEHEALTH IS A MODERN
DAY- TECHNOLOGY THAT WE USE
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT WE
COULD NOT GO TO THE HOSPITAL-
AND WE COULD COULD NOT CONSULT A
DOCTOR SO WE YOU YOU- TELL A- IN
ORDER TO BE TO COMMUNICATE.
WHATEVER THE SITUATION MAY BE
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO REALIZE-
THAT PEOPLE THAT BROADBAND
WASN'T REALLY AVAILABLE IN.
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
SPECIALLY AND I KEEP ON SAYING
THIS- PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED HOUSING.
ARE YOU CAN EXPECT SOMEONE OR
YOU CANNOT EXPECT A CHILD TO DO
DISTANCE LEARNING- AT HOME WITH
THEIR INTERNET SERVICE IS NOT
EXISTENCE RIGHT. AND SO THE
LEGISLATURE PUT OF THE GOVERNOR
PUT SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN TO
TRY TO CONNECT. CREEK
CONNECTIVITY- FROM THE RULE AND
URBAN COMMUNITIES- AND SO WE
HAVE IT IS REYES AS THE ISSUE
BECAUSE- SOME PEOPLE HAVE TO USE
THAT METHOD OR TO COMMUNICATE.
AND IF YOU DON'T IF YOU'RE NOT
CONNECTED YOU CAN'T COMMUNICATE-
AND I KNOW OUR SENIORS BECAUSE
I'VE- HEARD IT MULTIPLE TIMES.
THAT I DON'T HOW TO USE A
COMPUTER- BUT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T LEAVE THAT
POPULATION OF OUR COMMUNITY OUT
THOSE ARE ELDERS THOSE ARE
SENIORS. AND THAT'S A VERY-
BARBEL POPULATION EXPANSION WE
TALK ABOUT THIS PANDEMIC AND SO.
WE'RE MINDFUL WHEN WE WE'VE DONE
THE WORK AND WILL CONTINUE TO
RAISE THIS ISSUE- WILL RETURN
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE- IN
JANUARY I WANT TO GO TO- MISTER
SMITH- TERRY SMITH- TEN BILLION
DOLLARS BROTHER. TEN BILLION
DOLLARS TELL ME BECAUSE WE TAKE
IT IS IDEAL TO WRITE THEM DOWN
AND WE WANT TO TRY SOMETHING WE
NEVER TRIED BEFORE INFLUENCE OF
WHATEVER IMPLEMENT. BUT WE ALSO
WILL BE A MOUTH PIECE FOR YOU
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS A CONVERSATION
SACRAMENTO SO TEN BILLION
DOLLARS I THOUGHT ABOUT IT- K.
SO IF I HAD TWO MILLION DOLLARS
I WOULD OPEN UP A CHAIN OF.
JIFFY LUBE LIKE. SEVERAL
CENTERS. FOR PEOPLE TO GO AND
GET SCREENED. HIV STDS GIVE
CRAP- LATE HOURS WEEKENDS
WHATEVER MAKE THIS EASIEST
POSSIBLE GET YOU KNOW THE
SOONEST POSSIBLE. I WOULD DO IT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY. AS
POWERFUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI
IS ANYONE ELSE I HAVEN'T ASKED
THAT QUESTION TO THE- TIME IN ON
THAT PARTICULAR QUESTION.
BECAUSE AGAIN WE'RE TAKING THIS
FEEDBACK IN WHICH- YES DOUG
DAVIS PLEASE. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE A QUESTION AND-
APPRECIATE THE KIND OF MADE A
SPECIALLY. DR YOUNG I DON'T KNOW
WHAT NEEDED TO ADDRESS. BUT I
ALSO THINK THAT WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT AND CHANGE THE
CONDITION THAT REYES BACK FROM
IN THE FIRST PLACE WE HAVE TO DO
ABOUT. IT RIGHT THE IMPACT IT IS
RECOMMENDED MORE FROM BEING.
IMPACTED BY- KNOW WHO THEY- WE
LOOK BACK. ON THE- YOU KNOW OUR
IT'S HAVING RELEASED. DULL
MINIMUM TO DO THAT WERE AND WE
AND I AM GONNA TO THE- SO I
WOULD BE REMISS IN NOT THAT. YOU
KNOW FULL FUNDING HEALTH OF THE
LOCAL. TO BE ABLE TO CREATE A
WORK FOR. UPDATED QUICKLY AND-
WE ARE THE ONLY INTO. IN OF THE
STATE PROFIT AND THAT IS CHARLIE
WITH PULLING A OF HOT YOU KNOW
DATA THE CALIFORNIA WE ALL.
CHARGED WITH OF THE SO PACKAGE
BACKING UP AND WE DON'T HAVE
THAT DATA BUT IT THANK OKAY ARE
PUTTING OUR CITY. I WHILE THE
DATA KNOW THE IDEA- CLINICAL
LITTLE HAVING YOU KNOW. A
ELECTRONIC HEALTH. RECORD
FUNDING TO GET INTO THE HABIT OF
NOT GETTING THE HELP OF THE
PERMANENT ACTUALLY ABLE TO
ANALYZE THAT DATA. AND
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES OUR PROGRAM
PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT BUILDING
NEEDED- IN TERMS OF INCREASING
OUR TRAINING- TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE PUBLIC HEALTH
SURVEILLANCE ANALYSIS- WE DO A
LOT DURING THE TIME YOU HAVE A
FULL DIVISION II LAND OR TO HELP
WITH THAT IN TERMS OF HAVING
AGENCIES- WE ALSO COULD YOU
THERE'S- FUNDING TO APPROVE THIS
. AND THAT WE PROVIDE FOR ATTACK
OUR COMMUNITIES THE PERMANENT IF
YOU'RE GONNA HAPPEN. I'M GONNA
LOOK. BUT THE MOST. AND I ALSO
IS DOING THOUGH THE THING A
LITTLE. ACCORDING PARTNERSHIPS
COMMUNITY ENTITIES NONPROFIT AND
FOR PROFIT DIDN'T ALL HAVE A
ROLE AND IMPACT OF THE CONDITION
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT
RATE ON THAT INCREASES THEIR
USUAL. INCREASE THE RISK. OF
ILLNESS OR INJURY. PEOPLE THAT
KNOW THE COMMUNITY. AND ARE ABLE
TO HELP US BETTER INTERACT. I
DON'T UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU KNOW TO RUN AGAIN- IN TERMS
OF OUR PROGRAM HOW COME. WE CAN
INCLUDE THAT ARE IMPACTED BY ALL
THE WORK BIODUN BUSINESS
PROBABLY NONPROFIT AND THOSE-
INTERNET AS WELL THOUGH AND
HEALTHCARE. SO LITTLE
PARTNERSHIP NEEDED TO PAINT- BUT
MORE FUNDING IS NEEDED FOR TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A STRONG
BUT THIS AND AMERICAN ON. THANK
YOU FOR MUCH WE HAVE TIME AND
FOR UP COM- MODERN WHAT IF YOU.
OPEN THE LINE- FOR ANYONE OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO ASK A
QUESTION OR TO MAKE A STATEMENT
WE WANT TO- GIVE WAY AT THIS
TIME FOR THEM TO PARTICIPATE. SO
MODERATE YOU COULD PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE UP AND PLEASE- PLACE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE QUEUE- SO
THEY CAN PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROCESS. AND LET ME KNOW IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
PUBLIC COMMENTS. AT THE TIME WE
HAVE THREE IN OUR QUEUE. STICK
HELLO PLEASE HOLD THE LINE
OUTSIDE OUR BORDERS. ONE
FOURTEEN LIGA. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON INTERNET THE INTERNET
MAINTENANCE I NEED AN EDITOR
TOWN HALL THAT YOU TO THE IS
USUALLY HOW BERMAN LITTLE HALTED
HER OR A THANK FOR HOLDING A
HEARING ON A CRITICAL ISSUE HOW
DID AND HURTING HER TOGETHER
LIKE AND I EVER HEARING HOLDEN
EIGHTEEN THE HOBBIT AND HIGHER
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER ON THE
FLOOR AS AND WE'RE NEW ANNA TO
BE HEARD WITH ANYTHING ANY AND
COMMUNICATING IN THE AND I
PARTNER OR ANYTHING NEED-
REPRESSION EARLY IN. ALONG THAT
A COMMUNITY STRATEGY. I KNOW
THAT A LOT OF HARD TO CONNECT
NEEDING HELP EVEN IF THAT ANGRY
COMMUNITY HEALTH IMPROVEMENT
PLAN CREATED WITH INPUT FROM THE
COMMUNITY OR NATION ARE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT. AND
ALTHOUGH. COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
AND HE'S IN A VERY PROGRAM. I
DON'T REMEMBER ANYTHING YOU ASK
WHAT UNITY YOU MIGHT BONTA THE
FULLY FOLLOW. WILL HOLD HER
THANK YOU GREAT WORK THERE AND
IDEA AND I'LL COME ANY TRACKING
HER REALLY COMMUNITY INPUT
INTEGRATED AND THE LATTER
HOWEVER THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
DO IT BECAUSE. I HAD THAT I
WANTED. YOU HAVE THAT ARE COMING
AB I NEED TO AFTER THE ERROR.
DAY HE AND I REPLENISH. THE
FINAL ALTERNATE- BOTH FIND WE
CAN INCORPORATE EXPERIENCES
LETTERS OF HER CAN IMPROVE HOW
EQUITY AND THE CONTINUE TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH OF OUR- WHICH
IN EVERY EVERY BURKLE TO RETURN
AND I OF WORK. AND I MAY HAVE A
CRITICALLY NEEDED AND HAD BACK
TO ARTICLE PERSONALITY I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE COMMENT THE HEARING
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
REALLY APPRECIATE- FUNDING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO A
PARTICULAR LEVEL OF THEM WHAT
THEY HAVE RIGHT NOW AND ONE OF
THE THINGS YOU TOUCHED ON THAT
MADE SENSE THAT I DON'T KNOW AND
PEOPLE CAN CORRECT MORAL.
COORDINATION I THINK THERE NEEDS
TO BE COORDINATION BUT I DON'T
KNOW IF THIS COORDINATION IS
BEING DONE FROM THE FROM THE-
STATE AND FEDERAL COUNTY AND
LOCAL LEVEL WHERE EVERYBODY IS
ON THE SAME PAGE. AS RELATES TO
CARE THE RAISE THE INTERESTING
QUESTION AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR- SHARING YOUR THOUGHTS WITH
US. MODERATORS OR ANOTHER ONE ON
THE LINE PLEASE OPEN UP. HELLO
NOT ALIGNED TO FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS PATTY BURKE HE
GONNA GET A DIRECTOR OF HELD IT
IS USUALLY OF HOW HAS ANYONE
EVER ONE OF MY AND- ARE GETTING
YOU TO DATA SAID. AND GO THERE
COMMON IN THE DEAD OF THE SAID
AND THEM AND THANK YOU AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE CANADA TO HELP
WE AND TO DETERMINE IF. WHY EXIT
- BUT PUBLIC AND HE'S BEEN A
FORGET. HAS BELIEVES APPRECIATE
YOU CALLING MORRIS TODAY AND I
WANNA THAT FOR ON FUN THAT IS
WHY TIME. FUNDING BY IF IT IS BE
EASIER TO THAT PROGRAM BUT WE ON
GOING TO SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
- LONG TERM CAREER THIRTY ONE
THE COMMUNITY AND TO HELP
PREVENT DISEASE- YOU HIRE SAID
WITH HAND BUT ON KNOW HIRE AT
RATED AND- NOT GO TO. HAPPEN AND
HOW US IN THE LONG AND TO TAKE
IT HERE- ON AND THAT SORT OF
THING FOR A YEAH. ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I'M CALLING ON THE
HOUSE IN THE ASIAN PARTNERS
HOUSING ADVOCACY AND LEADERSHIP
ALTHOUGH NOT APPEAL I'M SURE THE
NATIONAL HEALTH OF THAT
ORGANIZATION WORKING TO SEE HOW
AGUIAR-CURRY AMERICAN VEHICLE TO
DETERMINE AND OTHER UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. THERE ARE MORE OF
THE DRIVERS WHO ON IS WORKING
OUT HE ADDRESS AND HELD IN A
MEETING WITH A HOW. FIRST YOU
LIKE TODAY. IT'S BEEN VERY
UNIFORMLY. STERN SHOW SUPPORT-
HELLO A MEETING INTO. SHE YEAH
ONLY GOT HIGH JOHN NEED A FADE
INCLUDING MANY ARE EIGHT USED
COMMUNITY IS. WE URGE YOU TO THE
ASSEMBLY KRIEGER OPPORTUNITIES
FOR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES ARE
FINDING CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
AGREED WRITING JOHNSON SON EIGHT
YEAR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
OPERATORS ARE ANOTHER THAT YOU
CAN OPEN THE LINE UP. AND HAVE
THEM. SPEAK WITH THEIR COMMENTS
. NOW WILL YOU LINE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
LADIES ANTHONY HOW THE FBI YOU
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR HOSTING THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING AND CONTINUING TO
HIGHLIGHT THE ISSUES SURROUNDING
RACIAL EQUITY AND HEALTH
DISPARITIES IN OUR COMMUNITY. WE
REPRESENT LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WORKERS AS WELL AS
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
WORKERS WHO WERE FROM DAY ONE ON
THE FRONT LINES OF THE
HANDANOVIC- AND CONTINUE TO THE
CORE GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS THAT
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH- INCLUDING
PANDEMIC RELATED FUNCTIONS AND
IN A REGULAR DAY TO DAY WORK- I
WOULD MENTION BY MY COLLEAGUES
IN SHE ASK AND HOW ARE- WE HAVE
LONG BEEN UNDER FUNDED AND UNDER
RESOURCE. ALLEN WE ARE REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THE HISTORIC BUDGET ON
MEDICATION AND- DEDICATED PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE NUMBER ONE WAY WE
WILL EXPAND IT WOULD BE STUDENTS
ARE THAT WE CAN RECRUIT AND
RETAIN ALL CLASSIFICATIONS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS AT A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND STATE GOVERNMENTS
LEVEL- ONE OF THE GREATEST
CONCERN WE HAVE. TO DEAL WITH ON
MAKING SURE WE HAVE SUFFICIENT
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES PUBLIC
HEALTH INSPECTORS MICROBIOLOGIST
IN FACT A TO DO ALL OF THE BAY
AREA AN IMPORTANT WORK THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS DO WE ARE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE EXPANDED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR- INCORPORATING
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS WHO
HAVE LIMITED EXPERIENCE CULTURE
CALL CULTURAL COMPETENCY AND
LINGUISTIC COMPETENCY- TO A
GREATER EXTENT. BOB WOULD KNOW
THAT OUR. LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT OUR INCREDIBLY AND
LIVE AND WERE IN HAVE A LACKS A
COMMUNITY THAT THEY SERVE. THANK
YOU. THANK VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CALL CERTAINLY- RECRUIT AND READ
PEOPLE IN THE CARE AS NURSES AND
DOCTORS AND THOSE HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT WE HAD A SHORTAGE AND WE
NEVER WILL BE CAUGHT- IN
SITUATION LIKE WHAT WE'VE HAVE
BEEN AS RELATES TO A SHORTAGE OF
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS. WE
NEED TO REALLY FOCUS ON HOW TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN THOSE HAVE
THOSE HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMMENTS
APPRECIATED MODERATED YOU PLEASE
OPEN A LINE OF FOR NEXT- PUBLIC
COMMENT. AT THE TIME THERE ARE
NO OTHERS INTERVIEW. RIGHT YES
WE WILL OPEN IT UP TO THOSE WHO
ARE- IN THE AUDIENCE WITH US
PHYSICALLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE AND WAITING SO
PATIENTLY- WE WILL GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON THIS
CONVERSATION ALL THE INFORMATION
PARDON AND YOU'VE BEEN AT THE
BEGINNING SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR. I TAKE IT ALL IN THE STATE
YOUR NAME AND TO SEE WHICH ARE
COMMON THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PANEL MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ARTI QUORUM- MY WIFE
ORIGINAL RETIRED FROM UCLA
HEALTH AS AN ADMINISTRATOR- AND
I HAVE AND I'M A RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNER IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES. BUT
INVOLVING TELEHEALTH SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIVE WHEN WAS STILL
TELL WHAT. AND THERE'S SOME
THINGS THAT I'M AND THIS IS NOT
TO BE MY ULTIMATE COMMON HERE
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS
THAT ARE BEING DONE WE WANT
AROUND THE COUNTRY THAT WE ARE
NOT DOING HERE. TO BRING ACCESS
IT AND THESE CAN BE OFFLINE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE CAN DO
MUCH BETTER TO BE BRINGING PRE
CONDITION ANALYSIS TELEHEALTH
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT TO ANY
EXTENT LIKE THEY'RE DOING IT IN
OTHER AREAS OF THE COUNTRY.
ANOTHER CONVERSATION BUT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THAT I HAVE GONE
TOO FAR I AND I HAVE NOT GONE TO
YOU JUST A LACK OF TIME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON SO THIS IS
NOT ON YOU. BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
THOSE THAT WE TALK ABOUT IN THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THE
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE RESIDENTS
AND RENTAL PROPERTIES. AND I'M A
BIG BELIEVER- AND THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YOU KNOW A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT I DID IS VOLUNTEERING
SOLVING HOMICIDES IN SOUTH
PHILLY AND SO FORTH. WHAT
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE DID. AS
RENTAL OWNERS. THIS IS ABOUT THE
DELIVERY SYSTEM IN SUPPLY CHAIN
WE TALK ABOUT GETTING HIM IN THE
CHURCH LOTS WE TALK ABOUT
GETTING MENSAL FIVE STADIUM.
WHAT IS A RENTAL PROPERTY OWNER.
I IMMEDIATELY KNOW. WHICH OF MY
RESIDENTS DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
THE INTERNET WHO HAS THE
DISABILITIES WHO WERE THE
SENIORS. AND WHEN I WENT
SHAMEFULLY TO A NUMBER OF OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND AGAIN I
JUST DID NOT HAVE THE PHYSICAL
TIME TO GET TO YOU. I WENT TO
OUR HEALTH DEPARTMENT I SAID
HEY. I HAVE A LOT OF
RELATIONSHIPS WITH HUNDREDS OF
OWNERS THOUSANDS OF OWNERS. I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED THE RENTAL HOUSING
TRADE ASSOCIATIONS. AND I SHOULD
HE LETS US. YOU KNOW WE KNOW ONE
HARD BETWEEN THESE INDIVIDUALS
ARE. SO FINALLY WE JUST MY WIFE
AND I JUST KIND OF BOOTSTRAPPED
AND- AND- EMAILED- HUNDREDS OF
OWNERS MANAGERS AND OUR
RESIDENTS. AND OUR RESIDENTS
KEY. AND AND I SAY THAT THE
FIRST ELECTED OFFICIALS
UNDERSTANDS HOW TO PROPERLY
ALIGN THIS RELATIONSHIP BECAUSE-
ALL THEY'VE DONE IS THEY'VE
CREATED THAT ABBAS OUR
RELATIONSHIP. SO KIND OF ON A ON
A ON A SUPPLY CHAIN AND GRAVY
TRAIN TYPE OF THING. WE GOT
HUNDREDS OF OWNERS MET ROB
MANAGERS AND OUR RESIDENTS.
MAKING APPOINTMENTS MY WIFE AND
I GOT ALMOST A HUNDRED
APPOINTMENTS MADE WITH SOME OF
OUR RESIDENTS FOR GOING OVER
TAKING THEM OVER TO GET THE
SHOTS. AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS STATEWIDE IS IT IS IT
IS. ALMOST EASY TO DO. BECAUSE
WE CAN BUILD THE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH OUR RESIDENTS ARE FOR
MANAGING OUR PROPERTIES PROPERLY
TO AND BUILD THAT TRUST. FOR
THOSE WHO WON'T GET AND GET
THOSE- GET THE SHOTS. AND WE DID
IT. BUT AGAIN I WANT TO MAYOR
GARCETTI THOUGH INTERESTING WENT
TO OUR HEALTH DEPARTMENT NO
INTEREST. SO YOU KNOW FROM FROM
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYBE YOU'LL
HELP. USE YOUR LEADERSHIP TO GET
THIS. OUR SUPPLY CHAIN OF
DELIVERY SYSTEM GOING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK
YOU RAISE A REAL RELEVANT ISSUE-
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO RENTERS-
AND SO I SEE AN OPPORTUNITY
THERE THAT I WANTED TO EASE OUT
AT SOME POINT IN TIME. BY MAYBE
GETTING THE ASSOCIATION TO MAKE
COMMITMENT- THE WE CAN WORK OUT
. FOR AND TRYING TO MAKING SURE
THAT ONE. THERE'S RESOURCES
THERE BUT ALSO THERE'S AN
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION. DONE BY
THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION- AND I
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS BY
MAKING SURE. THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THERE RECEIVE
INFORMATION BUT ALSO MAKE SURE
THEY GET THE VACCINE. AS WELL AS
OTHER WRAPAROUND SERVICE IN THE
HEALTHCARE SPACE THAT THEY
ABSOLUTELY NEED. SO I THINK YOU
YOU HIT THEM- YOU KNOW NAIL ON
THE HEAD- BY EXPLORING TEASING
THAT- THAT OPPORTUNITY OUT I
WANNA. HAVE A- CONVERSATION WITH
YOU SEE HOW WE CAN MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. ARE THERE ANYONE ELSE
I'M HERE IN THE AUDIENCE- THIS
IS A PUBLIC COMMENT SECTION.
THAT WE HAVE- SET ASIDE SO THAT
OUR PUBLIC IN. PARTICIPATE IN
THIS CONVERSATION. I'M SAYING NO
ONE ELSE- I WANT TO TURN IT OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE FOR FINAL
COMMENTS AND THOUGHTS AND THEN-
WELL BEFORE WE DO THAT WHEN WE
HAVE- START WITH MISTER SMITH.
AND THEY WORK AWAY ROUTE AROUND
THE ROOM FOR ANY COMMENTS OR
FINAL THOUGHTS YOU WANT TO LEAVE
WITH US BEFORE WE CONCLUDE AND
THEN. I'LL GO TO- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS. AND THEN MYSELF.
THANK YOU- JUST BRIEFLY I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY I THINK IT'S REALLY.
ALWAYS A GREAT TIME. TO COME
TOGETHER TO KIND OF TALK ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE AND
PROPOSE SOLUTIONS AND SO. OFTEN
HATS OFF TO THE FAMILY MEMBERS
FOR ORGANIZING THIS EFFORT
FIGHTING US AND- AND- AGAIN JUST
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MICHAEL BLAHA. I'LL
JUST RE EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF FOCUSING ON HEALTHEQUITY
WHICH I KNOW THAT YOU'RE BOTH
HIGHLY INVESTED IN AT BUILDING
COALITIONS AND ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE
ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN DECISION
MAKING AND IMPLEMENTATION
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE'RE
ELEVATING THE WISDOM VISION AND
SOLUTIONS OF GRASSROOTS
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I WILL AT ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES AND SAY THANK YOU
THANK FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY AND FOR HOLDING
HEARING ON THIS TOPIC I THINK IF
I WAS GOING TO FLAG ANYTHING IN
A FINAL REMARK IT WOULD BEAT THE
NUMBER OF TIMES- WORK FORCE WAS
MENTIONED AND SO APPRECIATING
THAT A NUMBER OF MY COLLEAGUES
DID MENTION THAT TODAY AND I'M
JUST HEARING IT ALL ACROSS THE
BOARD THAT. WE'RE ALL IN THE
SAME BOAT REALLY STRUGGLING WITH
WORKFORCE IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SPACE AND IN THE HEALTH CARE
SECTOR- AND SO REALLY HOPE THAT
MESSAGE CAME THROUGH LOUD AND
CLEAR FROM ALL OF US TODAY AND
JUST. TO ECHO WHAT I THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS SAID EARLIER
THAT WE'VE BEEN SAYING
FREQUENTLY IS THAT WE CAN'T GO
BACK TO THE WAY THINGS WERE THAT
AS WE MOVE TOWARD HOPEFULLY CODE
RECOVERY REALLY CONTINUING TO
PRIORITIZE THE COMMUNITIES THAT
WERE THE HARDEST HIT BY THIS
PANDEMIC AND MAKING SURE WE
LANDED A BETTER PLACE THAN WE
WENT INTO IT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER TAURUS.
YES SO. AGAIN THANK USED TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON AND
REMOVE US FROM BRINGING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO OUR COMMUNITY. I
THINK IT'S ITS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO. AB MAINTAINED THAT LENDS AND
HEAR FROM THOSE AT THE GROUND
LEVEL. I WILL- MY FINAL COMMENT
WILL BE A ONE WORD AND IT WILL
BE INTENTIONALITY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WANNA GO TO
THE LINE IF DR- DAVIS ARE YOU
STILL WITH US FOR A FINAL
COMMENTED AND DR YOUNG. ARE YOU
STILL WITH US. YEAH I'M GONNA GO
TO. IT GIVE. I'M I JUST NEVER
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GETS
AND AGAIN FOR GIVING UP CHANGES
SHARE WHAT'S ON MY HEART AND- I
NEVER. ATTENDED ANY I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU HEAR US. AND I BRING
MEETINGS FOREST YOU THAT IT
BROUGHT TO ME BY OTHER SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT I ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I THAT I WANT TO SEE RIGHT
NOW THE CLOSING IS THAT THIS
WORK IS NOT IMPOSSIBLE. IT'S NOT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO ACHIEVE
HEALTH EQUITY. BUT IT'S NOT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THOSE OF US
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA TO LIVE OUR
BEST LIVES INTO THE FULL LIST OF
OUR POTENTIAL. AND I REALLY DO
HOPE. THAT THOSE DECISIONMAKERS
WILL HEAR US AS YOU HAVE HEARD
US TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IT'S NOT IMPOSSIBLE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD I'M SORRY RIGHT. PERCY NO
PLEASE PLEASE PROCEED DAVIS.
THANK YOU- I AGREE WITH THAT-
HARDLY- I ALSO AGREED THAT. AT
THE END OF AN ALLEY. AND A LONG
TERM IT IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN
IN READING IT IS AN BUT IT
BATMAN IN THE PEOPLE OUT. WHO
ARE BEING USED RESOURCE ANY SORT
OF. RT IS. WORK IN TERMS OF ALL
THE THINGS WE NEED HERE- I ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE IT IS
BUILDING FOR THE POOR. ATTY HOT
ABOUT THIS THAT WE ABOUT BUT
COMMITTEE ON. BEING HARD HIT. WE
WILL BE GOING TO THE DISPARITIES
IN THAT ARE ADDED OR- BUT I HAVE
THE SAME CONDITION- BLACK AND
BROWN OF IN BUT WE ABOUT THESE
THINGS. WE CANNOT LOSE THAT IN
ORDER TO BUILD A SUPPORT STATE.
WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
THAT THEY ARE COMMITTED THE
THANK IT IS LOOKING BACK HOW.
BUT WE HAVE TO BE INCIDENT ABOUT
THE GAP WHERE EVERYTHING. OR WHO
EVER ARE BEING SEEN. IN TERMS OF
THE MOVING. THAT BEING SAID MANY
OKAY WERE IN IS LONG TERM AND IT
NOT IMPOSSIBLE. THANK YOU MUCH.
DAVE FOR YOU TIME AND YOUR IN-
NEXT I WANT TO. TURN OVER TO CAR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS FOR
HIS. A IN FINAL THOUGHT. YEAH US
I RE HAVE THAT THIS I HAVE A NOTES HERE- THE
COMMERCE. WE HAD TODAY OF THEM.
FROM THE PANEL IS REALLY. SERVED
AS A REMINDER FOR ME AS TO- WHY
CALIFORNIA IS CONSIDERED A
VANGUARD STATE- BECAUSE- WE ARE
A VERY DIFFERENT STATE AND THE
WAY WE ADDRESS ISSUES AND
PROBLEMS WE'VE GOT TO DO IT.
VERY DIFFERENTLY- AND ALSO. YOU
KNOW. IT REMINDS ME OF THE FACT
THAT WE ARE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER. YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S
YOU KNOW NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RURAL
CALIFORNIA IRVINE CALIFORNIA. WE
ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER AND
CLEARLY COVER NINETEEN HAS BEEN
A VERY TRYING TIME FOR ALL OF
US- BUT IT'S ALSO EXPOSED. THE
VULNERABILITIES- WITHIN OUR
STATE WITHIN OUR COUNTRY. THE
VULNERABILITIES IN RESPONDING TO
A GLOBAL HEALTH CRISIS FROM THAT
PP- THE- INABILITY TO. OKAY ARE-
THE PP. TO THE EVOLVING AND YEAH
I KNOW VERY FRUSTRATING SHIFTY
LOGISTICS AND HOW. WE RESPONDED.
TO THESE COVERT IMPACTS- BUT AT
THE END OF THE DAY. YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY AS AS MY COLLEAGUE HAD
MENTION OF. YOU KNOW THIS IDEA
OF BRINGING THE TWO ETHNIC
CAUCUSES THE BLACK CAUCUS IN THE
LOT LATINO CAUCUS TOGETHER TO
DISCUSS ABOUT. YOU KNOW OUR
PREPAREDNESS BECAUSE
PREPAREDNESS IS CRITICAL AND HOW
WE'RE GONNA RESPOND TO ANY
FUTURE CRISIS OR- HOWEVER LONG
THIS PANDEMIC IS GOING TO. BE
DRAWN OUT BECAUSE OF THESE
VARIANTS. OF PREPAREDNESS IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL BECAUSE
UNLESS WE FIND A WAY TO BUILD A
BETTER FUTURE FOR. ALL
CALIFORNIA- YOU KNOW THESE-
INEQUITIES HOW THE NECK WHITIES
AND- THESE DISPARITIES WILL
ONLY. GET WORSE THE BILL ONLY.
PERSIST AND ONLY GONNA GROW AND
CLEARLY IT'S OUR MOST VULNERABLE
REGIONS OF THE STATE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS THEY
DESERVE BETTER- AND- YOU KNOW
THEY CERTAINLY DESERVE MORE- AND
THEY NEED OUR MOST IMMEDIATE
ATTENTION- AND THEY DESERVE- YOU
KNOW AN EQUITABLE SHARE OF
RESOURCES AND SUPPORTS AND SO
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
YOU GUYS DO. AND LOOK FORWARD
TO- THE FOLLOW UP THAT- MYSELF
IN MISTER GIBSON AND COLLEAGUES
WILL HAVE TO ENSURE THAT WE DO
OUR PART- TO BE THE VOICE OF THE
DISTRICTS WE REPRESENT. A TO
ENSURE A STRONGER AND MORE
EQUITABLE OUTCOMES IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
DON'T WANT TO BE- A- MISS- MISS
HENDRIX ARE YOU STILL WITH US.
VIRGINIA HENDRIX. HEARING THAT
SHE'S NOT HERE AGAIN I HEARD-
IT'S NOT IMPOSSIBLE
INTENTIONALITY CLOSE THE GAP AND
PREPAREDNESS- THESE ARE ALL-
THEMES THAT CERTAINLY RINGS OUT
IN MY MIND AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WE'RE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU TO TRY
TO RESOLVE THIS ISSUE WE
UNDERSTAND WE WILL RADIC EIGHT
HEALTH DISPARITIES BUT WE SHOULD
DO OUR TO PUT SOMETHING IN PLACE
THAT CHANGED THE NARRATIVE- AND
NOT GO BACK BECAUSE OF MOVING
FORWARD AND SO WE'RE COMMITTED
TO DOING THAT I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES- ROBERT RIVAS FOR
CHAMPING THAT COST IN SACRAMENTO
THROUGH HIS LEADERSHIP- AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH ALL OF YOU
BECAUSE YOU BRING TO THE TABLE.
SO MUCH A WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE
AND EXPERTISE AND YOUR YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE YOUR HANDS ON THE POLLS
AND THAT'S A WE NEED TO BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS
ALL THE QUESTIONS AND SO WE NEED
PEOPLE WHO ARE BOOTS ON THE
GROUNDS THAT CAN ADVISE US AND
HELP US MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
GOING I'M IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
THAT WE LEAVE NO ONE BEHIND
BECAUSE OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN LEFT BEHIND BARCELONA AND
ISN'T AND IT'S TIME THAT WE
DON'T- WE WOULD MAKE SURE THAT
NO ONE IS LEFT BEHIND MOVING
FORWARD. I WENT THEY COUNTY
DIVERSITY MAKE HIS HEELS AND-
DR- I'M THOMAS PAR HAN AND-
DOCTOR RATS ON EVERYONE FOR
HELPING AND ALLOWING AND BEING
ARE ARE WONDERFUL HOSTS HERE
TODAY FOR THIS HEARING-
APPRECIATE THE PADDLE FOR AGAIN
GOING OVER BEYOND THE CALL OF
DUTY I WILL AVAIL MYSELF TO YOU
SO IF THERE'S ANYTHING THAT YOU
THINK I NEED TO KNOW PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO REACH OUT TO I'M TO
MYSELF AND I CERTAINLY WANT TO-
GO AS FAR AS TO SAY PLEASE REACH
OUT TO MY COLLEAGUE AS WELL
WE'RE COMMITTED IN THIS SPACE TO
WORKING TOGETHER TO HELP RESOLVE
SOME. OF THESE OUTSTANDING
ISSUES IN OUR COMMUNITY WE CARE
ABOUT OUR COMMUNITY I STAND ON
THE SHOULDERS OF THOSE WHO'VE
COME BEFORE ME. AND I THINK WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION AND A DUTY TO
MAKING SURE. THAT NO ONE IS THIS
. DOCUMENTS AND NO ONE IS LEFT
BEHIND- NO INDIGENOUS PERSON- NO
AFRICAN AMERICN OR LATINO
COMMUNITIES AGAIN THOSE ARE THAT
THAT'S THAT THAT THAT'S THE
DEMOGRAPHICS THOSE ARE THE
NUMBERS. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE LIVE AND NOT DIE
SO I WANNA SAY THANK OU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING PART OF THIS OF
THIS HEARING. THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INFECTIOUS DISEASE
I LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU GOD BLESS YOU
HAVE A- GREAT. HOLIDAY SEASON
MERRY CHRISTMAS AT LEAST NOT A
DODD HOW BECAUSE IT ALL THOSE
THINGS GOD BLESS YOU ALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH. INSTEAD OF GERMS.